[Music]
jack started to write
is after world war ii
and uh a lot of guys who never had the
opportunity to go to college
gi's came out of school
and were very lucky than that the
government provided funds for these guys
to go to college
and uh jack was one of them he went to
the new school
which was paid for by the gi bill
and
i think
what jack was able to
uh state is that he came from a blue
collar background
went to new york and was able to
uh
create havoc with the establishment who
really resented these gi's going to
college and getting a degree because
this was strictly a middle class or
upper middle class thing to do
but
i think that jack's style is something
that was developed after he had already
developed a style in the uh in the vein
of
thomas wolfe as you recall his first
book the town the city was very much
written like
thomas wolfe
and i think he was trying to develop a
style of his own what had happened was
he had read a lot of books he had
discussed literature with a lot of
people who were very literary
and
there was something i think he felt that
was lacking in the way
uh the uh
literature was being written at the time
a very formal way of writing we're all
taught to write in this very formal way
back in the 40s and 50s
and jack just sort of had the idea and
he finally developed the idea to just
write the way you talk or the way you
think just don't edit your
your thinking or your talking or you're
typing when you're doing it
just do it
and hopefully it's going to work out the
way you want it to and that's what
happened well the beast says you the
fathers of the beats work
ginsburg
burrows
cowack
and lucian carr
as for the beat generation
i always think the beat generation with
all those
kids going to college and just getting
out of college
uh in the late 40s and early 50s and
these are the guys who are influenced by
jack and allen ginsberg
it's a
a cultural event that occurred in the
50s and 60s
[Music]
tomorrow c-span school bus number one
visits youngstown university in ohio
meanwhile the crew from the new bus
tours the negro league baseball museum
in kansas city missouri
importance of the scroll today
how do football and jack kerouac go
together
well um as you know i'm sure jack was
was quite a football player um
before he hurt his knee and
that was
kind of coincidental with
me getting involved with the scroll but
i i think as he
participated in football and that was
part of his journey i i think a lot of
writers obviously hemingway
for instance
lived
their life
and
trying to draw a line between what they
wrote and what they lived was often
obscured by
by not really knowing with some people i
i think um jack
and the beats allen and
william and and
you know the great neil cassidy who
really really was
was an interesting character because
really um
he inspired kerouac so much just just by
the way he lived and i think
um
those those are the things to me that uh
really make writers interesting some is
myth some as reality and
so i was
i'm a writer i i write
songs poetry
um just
not just about everything so i i have a
great admiration
for those who have had the courage to
dedicate their lives to
being a writer i i mean i don't do it
professionally although i've done some
under assumed name that i've published
but it's never been something where i've
had to make my livelihood from it and
you have to have a lot of courage to go
out there and and do that and um
just i was just with paul mccartney in
in florida and um you talk about the
influence and kerouac and and trying to
tie the 20th century together but
you know paul
was with alan ginsberg before allen died
in new york and did some shows with alan
some word speak stuff and paul played
but that's
where the influence comes from the 60s
from these radical seed planters as i
like to say
from the 50s and
it was radical to do what what people
like the beatles and and lennon
mccartney and other people did certainly
in the 60s um
but to do it even before in the 50s was
extremely radical because if you go back
to those times
um
america was just coming off the second
world war and it settled into a pretty
much of a comfortable situation with you
know the economy uh being good after the
war and just people wanting to raise a
family and settle down and kind of
uphold a certain ideal
which was certainly idealistic um and
and not really reality um and and
a lot below the surface um and these
guys um
you know paul was talking about a song
blackbird and that's actually from the
white album but that's actually a civil
rights song that he wrote by going to
the south and being influenced
by his presence in america during those
turbulent times in the south and
these guys and and jack kerouac i mean
they were
the people that were doing
and saying
really radical ideas i mean some that
that
arguably
particularly
burrows and ginsburg
may have certainly crossed some lines
for most people if you know about
their
careers but
jack
was
i you know he
definitely had some some hemingway in
him and and that's probably not fair
because there's somewhat contemporaries
but uh hemingway's before him somewhat
and everyone knows of hemingway and how
he lived his life
but
jack really did that with neil cassidy
and took the proverbial
road trip and um
why does that interest you so much what
is it about jack kerouac then
i
life's a journey not a destination and
um
you know it's said that um
we're we're not
human beings having a spiritual
experience but we're spiritual beings
having a human experience and
that's the way i look at it and it's
just you know as my friend jerry says
it's a strange trip down here sometimes
and um
this this was their their journey in
essence and i i know myself and and my
youth
had very much similar journeys um
with with friends and and um it was
really
something to to kind of um go on a road
trip go out in in americana and and just
smell the streets
the alleys from new york city you know
to the
to the plains and everywhere in between
and i think um
that romantic notion is um
somewhat an ideal because i i think it
as you get older
um
i think it it it changes you and
hopefully frees you um
from some of the bonds
and and really i mean there's only love
and fear and and i think fear is
something
if we can derail fear um
we can live a lot happier and and a lot
more
of who our authentic self is and i think
these guys helped tremendously because
you know someone's got to step forward
sometimes and take a pie in the face
and have the courage to do that and
like any
great story uh jack
walked around the manuscript and and um
and and no one really wanted to publish
it and and even when they did publish it
in 57
um
you know they were saying you know what
are you bringing me with this scroll and
um
so um
i know that that jack has a rye smile on
his face to see
2.43 million sitting here
from his session uh
and um
[Music]
it's just really so cool because i i
think there's this myth behind the
scroll and you know it's
119 or 20 feet and
it's it's kind of
you know has an aura about it that's
unprecedented um so
how did you hear about it tell us the
story of how you heard about the scroll
and then why did you want to buy it well
i had um
been influenced by all those guys and
and had read
um a lot of their stuff naked lunch and
you know the the various um
the various
books that they had written
and through their influence hunter
thompson's a a close friend and and him
and i
talked from a distance
hunter you're
you're 61 you're still unsafe to be
narrow
uh
so
i just you know when it came time
and this this kind of this jewel became
available
i kind of wanted to see you know where
in in the 20th century where with
literary work
um
this this ranked and so cameron crowe is
a really close friend who's
a great writer and you know wrote for
rolling stones now does movies direction
and writes him and and um i got to know
him well through jerry maguire which i
was briefly in very brief um that's
another story but um
uh and so i talked to cameron i talked
to
hunter thompson just tried to get a
grasp from from writers that i knew
um
where they felt
things uh fell into place with the
scroll and and
it was pretty much unanimous and
and i had gotten
close to doug brinkley and and we had
had some long conversations and he
certainly helped convince me that um
this was kind of the crown jewel of the
beats
and the beats
i mean connected
you know
jelly roll with john lennon you know
so um i think rarely
do you get to participate in a world
record number one um
uh be it short live probably but um did
you want it to be a world record did you
care sure why not i mean
um that that would make it more
enjoyable i i think
um
you know if you're gonna spend more than
two million dollars a world record would
be nice
um
so
i i really didn't know what to expect
have you ever been to an auction before
no i haven't but i have since
so this was may of
2001.
uh
however yes yes
yes it was you go to new york you know
go to new york and and um
y'all i always get in the mood in new
york because there's this room at the
waldorf astoria which is is just steeped
in tradition where
jfk's rocking chair is in there and
franklin delano roosevelt's desk is in
there and jackie onassis has a
a laws up you know high and um
and so you know we we were there and um
you know woke up and
you know i think one of the kids had
some stuff on jfk's rocking chair i said
get that stuff off and you know have
some respect there
clear the chair you know be careful um
were you there to bid on the scroll
specifically we we came to the city to
do that and
where else to be but new york city and
um
uh
christie's you know they just do a great
job and and and
we um i went there and and just kind of
talked about it with the family and just
said
i think i'm gonna you know get this
thing for sure i kind of had some last
minute conversations uh
doug brinkley was there um and i talked
to cameron crowe right before i was
leaving the room and he said you know
jim
dylan's uh blood on the tracks lyrics
may appear for instance um
uh and different things are going to be
coming up and and we talked about the
significance
and just
where my heart is with um
uh knowing that i think a lot of things
are going to be start becoming available
in the 21st century early on so um you
know how do you pace yourself
but i've never been one for pace i don't
think um
but we talked and i just viewed it as a
really unique opportunity and um
like i said
it's it's the crown jewel of of that era
and that era has such a connection to
the early part of the 20th century and
and certainly after it and as we go
forward so
um i was
certain i wasn't going to be outbid
going there so anybody else bid for the
squirrel yeah i i know the guy i was
bidding against and i'll keep his name
confidential but
he has
a steak part steak and a sports
franchise and and is a really uh
great man nice guy and and not that much
older than me i'm 42 so i've made it to
elvis age
um which i'm proud of but uh
some people didn't think i'd make it
here but i hear i said
um
but um
so it was really exciting because i it
was that and then you know the
atmosphere is just incredible i think
you're always at least i'm always trying
to
have the emptiest mind so i can absorb
the really good energy
and that's the way it really happened i
mean i really didn't
know two months before that i was going
to get it i mean
i don't really know how it happened it
just i kind of ended up there but that's
the way i kind of operate
with my life you know very um
just kind of
you know organically
trying to process what the energies are
trying to say and and and
and hopefully
have clear be clear enough to have the
discernment um
to um
hear
which way they direct you so um what
does it mean to you to have the scroll
now to have bought it
i'm just borrowing it you know i i just
uh
you don't own anything it's just dust to
dust and
hopefully i can add a little bit of lore
to it um
i was gonna bury it and then and then
have some clues in my will and have
people look for it a hundred years later
but i figured
they'd desecrate my grave if i did that
although i am being frozen so i won't
tell them where that's happening but um
but i really do take seriously
how people love it and and really my my
main objective was to make sure everyone
has a chance to see it and be part of it
and experience it because the first time
i saw in person
was at the john hancock building in
chicago
and christie's uh has an office there so
i didn't see it in person and then at
the last minute
i said i really want to see it so i i
just got in my helicopter and said could
you stay open a little bit later and
they said they would and their guy was
there nice enough to to stay open past
the time and
when i saw it i knew
then um it was very impactful it was
just
you know in a room in a glass case and
it was it was stunning um
just the feelings that that came about
so i guess
i don't really derive meaning from
ownership i i think
the ego would be misplaced
if
owning made you feel because i don't
think owning something i mean we can
both look at the sunset over the
mountain and if you own the mountain
and i don't i mean the experience
shouldn't be any different if it is
i think you're probably
at least i feel i would be probably
maybe misaligned a little bit
on where i'm coming from
but it's
a great joy to be a caretaker of it um
and
what are your plans for it will scholars
be able to have access to it while you
have it yeah they they already have and
i my plans are really open i i again
look for the the direction of the
spirits to see
where where it should go and what should
happen to it um
when september 11th happened
we were all impacted
greatly
and i think
as a
as not only americans but i think more
importantly
citizens of of a global village that
remains incomplete but
i don't think we can really move forward
until it is complete and i believe it
will be complete on this earth and i
believe
things are moving towards that
in places like the middle east and and
and other places um
but that was really impactful and i i
think that
we all felt that um
that we were blessed
to have freedom and that
that
nothing
is too much to sacrifice for freedom
and without freedom this thing doesn't
get done uh and and in a lot of other
countries it wouldn't have got done but
what america stands for
is freedom and freedom of expression and
uh so
i had the idea that i i wanted to use it
in like a triangular
charitable way
where i would give it to an institution
and the institution would help raise
what it cost and i would get nothing the
victims would get the money
and possibly split it with some local
charities here and and then um
uh
and and and put it someplace uh like the
lilly library here or even possibly the
new york public library came to mind
certainly out in san francisco or even
massachusetts but it just it just didn't
come together
there was a lot of charitable things
going on and
so it didn't happen so i'm like i said
i'm one where i don't um
push something if the energies don't
rise up you kind of put it out there and
if it happens it'll happen and and you
don't want to force it so
right now
really my plans are is to let people see
it get it on tour
we're going to
do that probably at the lily library in
bloomington here to start it off
because i you know duke
in indiana is my home and and i wanted
to start it there but certainly
the places
obviously new york san francisco canada
massachusetts
want to get it out there and just kind
of have it go on the road
at this point
so the people that really
want to
appreciate it and and just be around it
and take a look at it
whether it's scholars or
those beats in those alleys that are out
there right now
somewhere around 7th avenue in the city
they're still there
they always will be
so everyone can see it so um
so that's kind of where where it stands
now with the plans
recently we sat down with sterling lord
jack kerouac's literary agent he
discussed kerouac's writing style
members of congress
[Music]
c-span's american writers series
continues to look at our country's
history through the lives and works of
authors who have chronicled or
influenced the course of our nation
this week our selected writer is jack
kerouac
recently we went to the new york public
library for their exhibit victorians
moderns and beats
a portion of the exhibit focuses on
writings and memorabilia from jack
kerouac
we're standing in the d samuel and gene
h godderson exhibition hall of the new
york public library which is the main
exhibition space for the library the
title of this exhibition is victorians
moderns and beats new in the berg
1994-2001
a main part of this exhibition is the
beat movement in the united states and
virtually half of that is devoted to
jack kerouac and we've taken materials
from the archive in order to
illustrate his work and life
the library acquired the kerouac archive
after a period of long negotiation in
the 90s uh with john sampus who was the
executor who continues to be the
executor of the literary estate of jack
kerouac and it was last year that the
archive itself was physically brought to
the library
there is an entire case in this
exhibition that's devoted to kerouac's
fantasy baseball league and it's an
interesting place to start not only
because not many people know about it
but because
it it represents a side of kerouac that
may not be obvious from his
novels
kerouac was obsessed with statistics
and
obsessed with keeping them with
seeing the various permutations
that occur
when playing a uh when playing a
baseball game uh that he created out of
whole cloth
the game is uh has a number of different
components to it it includes a series of
cards probably about a hundred and all
in which the various baseball events are
recorded and there are a number of
different
graphics that he used in order to
uh help him determine
which uh what which baseball event would
occur in the confrontation between let's
say for example a the level uh hitter
against the sea level pitcher there were
six teams in his league and he began
with
teams named after automobiles
the names of the players as far as we
know are all fictional with one
exception he has pancho villa
playing center field for the boston
fords and interestingly uh this
adolescent jack kerouac doesn't make
himself
the manager of the boston team even
though he was a lowell massachusetts
native but uh rather manager of the
pittsburgh plymouths and i think this is
an instance of carolac trying to show
that he's not just an adolescent router
that he's uh he's serious about this
game and he's going to remove himself
uh his own personal ruling interest from
the equation by making himself manager
of a team that's not boston one aspect
of the game that's particularly
fascinating is that he kept
four different
newsletters
or
newspapers uh about
the game itself one was called baseball
chatter and we show
three issues of that
in the exhibition
and
he interviews players he interviews
managers
the odd numbers of the issues were
devoted strictly to
in-depth one-on-one interviews
and he gives them their own characters
their own histories
you can see a little bit of the
overblown
sports writing style of the time in his
in his own descriptions and
part of this may have been parody in
part part of it may have been his
sincere desire to imitate the sports
writers whom he idolized
there are a number of literary pieces of
course in the exhibition as well and one
of them is a manuscript of something
that he called gone on the road and this
was done in august of 1950
and it's a treatment
of a proposed novel that he has of
course
this would later become
uh part of the original version of on
the road it's about
dean moriarty
actually neil neil cassidy his friend
who
uh whom he met in new york along with
allen ginsberg and later
william burroughs as well
who the beats
idolized in a way is embodying a
dionysian kind of approach to life a
refusal to be bound by the rules and
conventions of society
and
cassidy was a farm boy from the midwest
who had a taste for
harmless auto theft and
um but also a flare for literature as
well and a real interest in it
and
on the road apparently at first was
really supposed to be about him
uh later it evolved into
a story about the narrator's travels
with cassidy but in this first treatment
we see a treatment of cassidy himself
his biography
the period before he actually met
kerouac
and the other beats
we in fact do have the second version of
on the road here on exhibition the
archive also has the third one and this
is a typescript with kerouac's own
extensive
hand demandations and black crayon
pencil
and there are thousands of inundations
not only words and phrases but entire
paragraphs have been crossed out or have
been transposed sometimes even entire
pages
and in one part of the one part of the
typescript he's taken the versos of the
pages the backside the blanks of sides
of the typescript pages and has begun
another manuscript an autobiographical
manuscript for 12 pages working
backwards through the typescript so it's
a
fascinating document and it shows the
extent to which
kerala
had to revise in order to get this novel
in working condition it first tried of
course to
sell the novel as it was in scroll form
when that was rejected
uh he realized that
he was going to have to make some
serious revisions when viking got back
in touch with him
in 1955
he realized what he that he would have
to accommodate their their wishes and so
we get this
massive
uh
work of inundation and excision and
revision
and this will be a an important resource
as will many of the other
fragments aborted attempts at on the
road novels that we have in the archive
this will be a wonderful resource for
scholars
in the future
there are over a thousand manuscripts in
the archive and that includes
draft versions of various novels both
published and unpublished draft versions
of short stories
prose fragments some of these are no
more than a single page others are
50 60 even 100 pages in length then
there are scores of diaries notebooks
journals
that
span
the period from 1939 when kerouac first
went to horace mann school first came to
new york
to go to the preparatory school to
prepare him for colombia um almost until
they till his death in
1969. of course what you're seeing here
is only a minute part of the archive
we have perhaps
40 or so items of kerouac maybe a little
less
and there are thousands
of items in in the archive itself
so it will become a resource
for
literary scholarship about carolac about
the beat movement
and really about a cultural
important cultural period in america
we hope that the visitors who come to
this exhibition will
take from it an appreciation of karak's
great richness of expression
and also a sense of the complexity of
his own life and how that had a bearing
on what he wrote and what his
aspirations as a writer were and what
his aspirations for america
were
this week at
americanwriters.org join in the fighter
series
order it now at americanwriters.org by
clicking on shop
and again this friday night at eight
eastern on c-span's american writers an
encore presentation of jack kerouac
c-span's american writers series
continues to look at our country's
history through the lives and works of
authors who've chronicled or influenced
the course of our nation
this week our selected writer is jack
kerouac recently we sat down with
sterling lord jack kerouac's literary
agent he discussed his writing style the
times in which kerouac wrote and their
relationship the interview runs about 15
minutes
sterling lord when and how did you first
meet jack kerouac
i met jack in 1951
um he
came into my office
and
he was both
uh he was an interesting interesting
looking a little i
regarded him as sort of a diamond in the
rough
and um
he remember
how he looked what he was wearing and he
had with him the manuscript of on the
road
and that manuscript he had although it
had existed in in the form of a scroll
uh up until that point uh before the he
came to see me he'd been advised to
put it all in a on a double space eight
and a half by eleven
type typewriting paper and so it was in
that conventional form when he arrived
but nothing else about it was
conventional
how long did you know jack kerouac
well i first i i knew jack i mean that
was the first time i met him and uh he
was sent by
an editor
and
so i i've known him ever since then and
of course until he died in 1969
and what exactly was was your
relationship to him in those years well
i i think was a good relationship i
spent
we spent some
social time together
i remember going out to northport to
play
let's spend a weekend with him and
he he thought of me as rather
i'd say a desk bomb button-down
uh
uh office worker
uh and he under didn't understand that i
played sports all my life although he
did have a vague knowledge that i was
associated with tennis so
he had a basketball bank board in his
backyard and he created a game that was
scored like a tennis match
and i must say i
beat him hollow i mean it was just
devastating and he had never forgot that
the last time i saw him before he died
he made a remark about that he still
remembered it
so yes we did spend some social time
together
and what about jack kerouac and his
writing interested you as a literary
agent
well
when i read on the road it was obviously
something new and different it was a
fresh voice
and it had a wonderful
policy to it a rhythm
that was extraordinary
and
that and you knew that you were
you were dealing with a very strong
voice
and all those things interested me
enormously
uh it didn't interest editors right away
it did it took me five years to sell a
book
what what seemed to be publishers uh
biggest
rejection of it well it was um i i have
some
rather
vivid
rejection letters in my files
one i remember one said discipline
discipline when will kerouac ever learn
discipline
and
i think apart from that it was something
that it was a form and a voice that was
just so unconventional that a lot of
publishers couldn't accept it
one
two editors in town who were very highly
regarded and were
about karowak's age
so from a generational point of view
they
you might say they were as well equipped
as anybody to
to read and accept and understand it and
both of them turned it down
so it was
and and the publisher that finally
bought it
viking press
it was that's a very interesting story
they had seen the manuscript
of five years
they'd seen it just about shortly after
i did or shortly before i saw it
and
but
the
chief editors at the house were
much older they were much
farther along in life and there but
there was one editor
an advisory editor who was so keen on
the master but he knew what that it was
what it what it was
but he he knew he couldn't get support
so he waited and waited
uh and
by
say four or five years later there were
a couple of young editors at viking who
had gained enough prominence in the
company
so that he that he had his support team
and that's when they came to me and made
an offer
do you remember what that offer the
amount of it was oh i certainly do yes
after i'd been trying for five years to
sell it i got this speech
from this viking editor who called me
uh
about
how good the manuscript was and he
offered me an advance of nine hundred
dollars
and uh despite the fact that i've been
trying for five years to sell it i
turned him down
and i got him up to a thousand
and how did that compare with later
advances that kerouac got
well he jack never got gigantic advances
uh
i mean on the road
was and is his most successful book
and as i
it's it's selling now
so many years after publication and
three hundred thousand cop two hundred
thousand copies a year in the united
states and canada alone
but he never got
huge advances
um i don't think
we got any advance as high as fifty
thousand dollars for any one of these
books but on the road for example
was for a long time in print in three
different editions that is hardcover uh
quality paperback and and mass market
uh so
uh it was out out there and it's been
continually in print ever since then
what was its
impact on kerouac
well
um
jack was essentially a shy man and
the impact was i would say
he wasn't prepared at all to deal with
the accolades or the
public response
to
to the success
[Music]
and
he he drank a lot and to i think
help him deal with all of that
but
he i think he was
basically in terms of he
he was unswayed in other words
he thought he felt certain things about
his work
and uh i don't think those things
changed he uh
during
during the enormous public
reception to that book
in a way
you know there's a very solid
core to jack kerouac
he was quite well read
and
i think he knew exactly who he was
and so
the accolades
really didn't change him
in my experience
how did on the road reflect the times
that kerouac lived in
well
um
it obviously struck a nerve end
with the american people particularly
that generation that was reading it
i remember
all sorts of things happened in response
to that book
one thing i remember a young a young man
called me from denver
and said he wanted to come in and
deliver his manuscript to me i'd never
heard of the man before so he came in in
a
car that was uh i'd say his trip was
very much in imitation of caroux on the
road trip or trips
and
he came in and he came into my office
and he
was
i think
as a as an individual trying to imitate
what he knew about kerouac and of course
the manuscript was terrible
there was nothing to it it had some of
the uh what should i say superficial
aspects of kerouac but none of the the
meat and the heart
so that
that was just one of many people who
approached jack orr approached me
and
i think that
the other thing that happened
i'd say
well most of this happened after jack
died in 16 69
69 but the number of of writers who came
forward
and admitted
uh acknowledged their debt to kerouac
was
really
astounding
uh very prominent writers
and
another thing that developed
a friend of mine
who was writing a pie he's in the art
world
and he was writing i think his phd
thesis and in the course of that he
interviewed
oh
half a dozen of the prominent artists of
that time very well-known names
and every one of them said that kerouac
had been a very strong influence on them
was there something in particular that
that that book tapped into
yes i think it tapped into the
desire for release from the system
and from convention
uh and the so it was a celebration of a
free spirit
and how much of that had to do with the
the decade he lived in
and that decade in america oh i i think
a lot i think that
uh you know timing is so important in
these
uh in things like book publishing
and uh i think
um i think it came out
i mean it was just sort of just the
right time
now you know when um
after the sort of initial
well i guess it was around uh after the
initial
of uh
reaction were off and years past
there were
there were oh i'd say around was it 69
or 70 when the years of the revolts on
the campus
and
all and all of a sudden the sales in
general dropped
and those that was in my view because
there was a different kind of student on
the campus you know it was the
and they regarded kerouac as a comic
figure
and that existed i think for three or
four
five years in the early 70s
and then after that enough there was
enough change and enough distance so
that once again kerouac became
renowned as a romantic figure
which
he is today
so where does kerouac fit into
post-war riders
well i think i mean he has he's unique
uh
i i don't know how to
i don't know how to uh rank him or
answer that question in any detail
uh
but i think he's one of the
certainly one of them a half dozen
most important writers
in the period after the war
did he change much after on the road in
terms of his writing style did he evolve
i don't
i don't think there was a
any substantial growth
after that
there are people who think that his
writing fell off shortly after that
maybe one more book whatever
i'm not i don't i don't go along with
that
but
i think you know it's like um
another writer of mine said
fame interferes with creativity
and
i think that's a little bit what
happened here
i mean it didn't change his head
but
the amount of
of time and energy it took
dealing with fame is substantial
and it can
erupt or erode creativity
you mentioned earlier he came into your
office in 1951 was it yes it was
do you remember that exchange
well it wasn't substantial i mean he's
he is both
uh
i mean he was presenting me with the
manuscript and he mentioned the name of
the person who'd sent him which i
already knew
and he
just didn't make any demands on me he
was a little shy
and
but i don't remember anything
really specifically that was
was said
i guess he we did the
routine things he gave me his address
and phone number and so forth and
i told him
i'd read it and get to him as soon as i
could
uh you know the very prosaic stuff
i didn't make any attempt to try to
sit down with him then as a matter of
fact now that i think about it he was
sort of like he was he was on the way to
some place i mean it wasn't
that he was there to sit down and chat
so when did you really first have an
experience to get to know him and talk
to him about
his writing
um
i don't remember how long it was but it
was
see and don't forget there was this four
or five years when i was
uh
really um
still trying to sell
on the road
and we had a couple of magazine sales
excuse me we had about we had three
different magazine sales
but um
some
as time went along i certainly
spent uh
time with him i mean i can remember
vividly one night we
went out and through the village
together
as i say he was an absolutely charming
guy to be with
and
then
of course after on the road came out he
had a little more freedom of movement
um
i visited him both in uh
i guess two or three times in northport
he you know during the time i knew him
he would
live in northport then he'd move in his
mother would move to florida and then
they'd move back to northport and they'd
move to florida and once he moved to
i think to orlando instead of saint pete
and back to uh north port and then once
he moved
to
cape cod
so i visited him there
so i've seen him in many locales
why do you think it's important to study
jack kerouac or to read him
well first place he's a beautiful writer
in the second place um
the spirit is extraordinary and the
third place
he really
made
a dent in our culture and in in
particular in our literature
influenced writers and as i mentioned a
minute ago influence painters
so
i think you can learn a lot
by reading and studying jack
learn a lot about our culture yeah
sterling lord thank you very much
you're welcome my pleasure
all next week you can join our online
forum on jack kerouac and the beat
generation at americanwriters.org
post your questions for guest gerald
nicosia author of memory babe a critical
biography of jack kerouac to be part of
it go to
americanwriters.org and click on the get
interactive box
you can see c-span's american writers
program on jack kerouac this friday from
lowell massachusetts we examine his
novel on the road and the beat
generation american writers continues
its journey through history with jack
kerouac next friday at 8pm eastern here
on c-span
[Music]
here's what's coming up first lady laura
bush at a white house conference on
school libraries
after that on a men's american writer
series continues to look at our
country's history through the lives and
works of authors who have chronicled or
influenced the course of our nation
this week our selected writer is jack
kerouac
recently a panel discussion took place
at lowell high school in massachusetts
regarding the life and works of the beat
writer
the events about 50 minutes
welcome to lowell high school
my name is brian mcdonough i'm chairman
of the english department of lowell high
school
jack kerouac's alma mater
and for the last several years we've
sponsored a fall
poetry contest
and today we're going to start with some
of the participants from last year's
last falls
contest
students from area high schools we have
a couple of low high students
we have some from
the methuen high school and we have a
student from
the um
what's called the merrimack school in
trump's mass so we're going to start
with each of those participants reading
one of their poems so the first
student want to step forward
i titled this one um the astral planes
of my mind
i wish i could walk through my mind
stop i smell the flowers in my head feed
the pigeons inside myself
walk the street of my thoughts
vandalize my emotions with
graffiti-colored attitude run a marathon
of explosive emotions
kick the [ __ ] out of my inner child
play basketball my soul no expression no
foul have a little talk with my
subconscious blackmail my conscience get
high with my imagination scare the
living daylights out of my nightmares
let my dreams get some sleep tell my
ambition to give it a rest have dinner
with pride and tell her to try
swallowing by hope a card for always
being there deal some lethal doses of
character to myself i wish i could do
all this oh jeez
wait i forgot i can man i forgot to
listen to my memory
stop by the bank of my mind deposit a
little sanity and get back some change
because we could all use a little change
[Applause]
this one's called tonight and today
she writes
given to laughter prone to sunshine
light falling on a darkened sky whose
planet's day delivery lacks in style
yet is almost poignant which is in turn
a sign of power in those words she types
in an effort to simplify simplify
multiply vilify and decide she has
turned to that daylight as an example
she believes in the power of words
decisions revisions drafts and copies
more and more she turns to these things
the bible is on paper paper must show
something something has to show besides
the author's lecture transcript even in
a dissertation on consternation
something has to show damn it else why
would he put it down
intelligence no many are lacking that
she laughs as she writes writes what
writes how now with her husband beside
her she is in thought
what shows what is the driving moving
force why does she open her computer and
begin to question why how and when for
men for women sins lies butterflies she
decides god is in the paper and god is
in the pores
god is in the ceilings and yes god is in
the floors
god is in the air we breathe and listens
when we pray
and when you piss your guard off boy
there's hell to pay
laughing at a rhyme she's moving to the
keys god is in the stars to which we
point and wish and if he made a lemon
pie it'd surely be delish still laughing
now she's crying for lack of better
words her hair tosses in a tumble bobs
and spins and swerves she's crying as
she's typing now for answers still a
void she's struggling in triumph over
girls and toys and boys in rhythm now
she's lost it she's in a fit of pain and
when she stops to look outside
conveniently there's rain
pointing at the clouds whose shadows
cast an endless dark as dark as the
night in which she sleeps dreaming
screaming now she's outside under the
clouds while the rain falls horns
blowing as cars drive by someone stops
and questions is she okay yes she's okay
but it's cold outside she knows and the
rain is pummeling driving she can feel
it she laughs feel it in her pores where
why why is god in the pores of paper yet
she is alone she is porous damn it yet
all she knows is
an emptiness
without a semblance of all the pain that
so many claim to have felt and dealt
who is the pain giver she asks who is
the one responsible creator remake her
she begs screams at the sky he continues
to rain down on her now she's nearing
she's nearing a clearing in their
sunlight again she's tired wired yet
excitement in this situation seems to
have passed her by her lie
underdeveloped under thought and over
exaggerated but he ran so quickly as
though it weren't an issue
quickly decisive in his decision now
she's in a field
forgotten her name her fame why in the
name of the poorest goddess she's so wet
she wonders blunders lasting impressions
in a quiet town so down why the long
face so what if she's a disgrace she's
pretty she'd better damn well smile a
long time coming now she's humming
singing away at her displeasure measures
to reassure insecure and leave a blunt
mark with a sharp object whose time is
this hers damn it
he's quiet now her husband sleeping on
the grass why was he bleeding even after
all the rain sunshine cloud cover and
nudity still he wouldn't wake up
this was his clearing his place away
from the rumors tumors the ones that
grew infested at the country store the
talking walking and talking some more
and some more and some more now he's on
the floor and she wanted to lie with him
in him with him by his side decide and
decided she would
and as she lie on the grass
a shivering heap by a dead man asleep
she lied to herself
herself
she knew she wouldn't forget
wouldn't regret
when they found her forgotten beside him
[Applause]
my poem is entitled
speak to me in tongue-tied rhymes and
stories of carousel majesties
with blooming heavens falling from
golden tipped ribbons with a fairy's
glittering essence
colors fade with the reminiscing of time
hearts pour open with charcoal smoke
whispering gibberish
your voice echoes in the halls of
silence bouncing off my kisses
strangle me with your looks spit on my
burning desire to become one and bury me
with my freedom and an underworld of
innocence
and abstruse comprehension of my liking
to starting all emotions of my being
look away to a daisy's petal let the
salt pour from its tips and yearn for my
sea
steam rises through your brain melts any
recollection of the forbidden touch of
passion we trembled in together
fall quickly to your death and study
your last words let me awaken peace with
the heart and remembrance of your tongue
writing its words of mercy
extract your stakes from my soul and
breathe in new halves meet me at
heaven's doors where our souls made
again
time clicks to hammer [ __ ] a bullet of
tolerance burst through my glass curtain
of forgiveness
greet you master and wear your
everlasting mask that i strip away with
my eyes
erase the forever tattoos from your soul
i do i do
snuffle your pain inhale your anger and
inject your ticket to tomorrow's destiny
now
sweep brushed white counterfeit
obsessions under the carpet i fly on
remember me through your noxious cloud
filled with confrontations and wave your
arm violently to clear
declare a vision path to see me
drift up and out of your black obsession
box which i was born into
forgive me for the remaining wet towers
on your floorboards that once absorbed
my sorrows
sorry for the overflow of distribution
of second servings of my reality to your
bed
the sheets fold and tops the thighs curl
while cringing stomachs freeze hungry
your kiss lost its flavor its heart has
crumbled must not have realized i was
gone
research my love extensively to realize
its faith backstreet lovin shower
washing fantasy and beach sand purity
that was washed up to senseless acts of
filth
kiss me sweetly good night and bandage
up my hair and golden tip ribbons
sing me songs of carousel majesties that
exist in my dreams to wake me to live my
freedom
[Applause]
this is a poem called little boy lost
speak to me of happiness
a tale and love conceived
and i'll tell to you the emptiness that
resides inside of me
dear mother distant tell me please
of what your children pray
i lost my god so long ago
and darkness stole my day
preacher preaching proud and tall
preached to me some way
to overcome this wave of pain
that's slowly killing me
lovers loving free and true
could you spare some happiness for me
i have none left of my own
my heart is closed cannot see
dear father god almighty ghost
please come save me from this pain
i'm so alone
here now
my tears become the rain
oh merriment sweet happiness
please come back to me
all i want is your embrace
and to bathe in your glory
[Applause]
this is called uh spurious is my
excuse me spurious is my new favorite
word besides facetious
foiled attempts to make primates creates
devastates and destroys in a flurry of
stream of consciousness garbage
brilliant manipulations stipulations
ideologies
laid to waste and mine to paper
transitions
raw motion as psychedelic grammatical
principle words as nine millimeter
suicide attempt sentence fragments and
myself is julie andrews
or painting a portrait of unparalleled
stereophonics the sounds of music
senseless sensationalistic
pseudo-rambling a little rational
self-discovery by means of 26 contorted
line segments and counting
out with the innermost falling forward
through phrases and newton will do the
rest
gesticulating procrastinating and
conceive
wordy invitations to an ink cartridge
funeral of deceased fallacies
betray physics betray natural law betray
reality but to thine own self be true
[Applause]
the gentlewind fingers her long black
hair as a little girl oversees the world
ahead of her
fear and anticipation overwhelm her at
the same time
she blinks and turns her head and sees a
gesturing hand motioning his fingers for
her to follow it she grabs the hand and
steps into a world unknown to her
the little girl asks where are you
taking me but she is ignored and left in
a dark place alien to her
she gets up and looks straight ahead
waiting for anything coming her way
the world is a mystery and the future is
in your hands brings out in her ears
she gets on her knees and covers her
ears to silence the words but they dig
into her into her head into her heart
but then she stands tears in her eyes
and sees the hand once more she takes a
hand and closed her eyes when she
finally opens them the little girl
stands still overseeing the world ahead
of her a new voice that goes in her head
everything's going to be all right it
was spread the little girl took a deep
breath looked around and slowly stepped
into the world the world of time and
destiny
[Applause]
thank you very much
we are delighted to have with us today
three kerouac scholars
seated right to my right here is paul
marion
who was one of the developers of the
jack kerouac park the commemorative park
which is just down the street from
lowell high school
and he is an editor of uh some of jack
kerouac's early works for viking and
penguin uh books
in the middle margaret smith the member
of lowell celebrates kerouac
a staff writer for sentinel and
enterprise daily newspapers
and at the end larry carradine who's
president of lowell celebrates kerouac
he is a published poet and he was one of
the judges in the fall uh kerouac poetry
contest and i would say listening to the
students that just read it was a
difficult choice to
select uh who was the winner and
runner-up and whatnot very much so yes
uh they're going to conduct a panel
discussion here and we'll take uh
along the way questions from the
audience if we have any so does anyone
want to kick it off
sure well when i was walking to the
school a little while ago and i saw the
c-span school bus out front i thought uh
i couldn't imagine anything that would
make jack kerouac more happy than seeing
a
national
television
network school bus out front of his high
school
with the words american writers and the
reason they're in lowell is because of
him and his dream was to be an american
author
as improbable as it might have seemed
because he was a young man who came from
a family his parents were born in canada
they were working class family
he was not necessarily on a track to be
a famous uh author but that was his
dream and it was right at about the same
age that you are now
uh in this high school that he
made up his mind that he was going to be
a writer he began writing
by the time he was 10 years old he used
to do handmade newspapers his first
love was sports and he wanted to be a
sports journalist but then as his
reading expanded and he began to think
more about literature he
started to write stories novels
and by the time he was in high school he
was writing
poems and short plays
he
we were talking earlier about the type
of writers that some of you have been
reading kerouac was extremely well read
he had a great background not only from
his schooling here at columbia
university but he used to skip school
and go over to the public library lowell
and read through the whole literature
collection so he was a tremendously
well-read guy
um just stepping back a little bit uh
for those who might not be aware uh jack
kerouac was born in 1922 in lowell
he died in 1969 when he was 47 years old
in florida
in those years he wrote about 30 books
novels
collections of poetry spiritual writings
and
if i could describe him in
simple terms
for those who might not know a lot about
him he wrote about what it was like to
be an american
in the middle of the 20th century
by the time he was a late teenager he
decided that he was going to write
the story of his own experience as a
member of his generation in america and
say what it was like to be an american
and his heroes were american authors
like walt whitman emily dickinson
william saroyan
carl sandberg
hemingway folks like that
and to
see
his career come
around to the point where you have
c-span touring the country and going to
see
the places associated with hemingway and
steinbeck and fitzgerald and kerouac's
on the list i can't imagine anything
would make him happier
i think when people think about the
writer jack carrick probably the most
famous easily recognized book that he
wrote was called on the road
and when some people think of like the
great american novel you know this is
one of the novels that they think of and
for a lot of people that just
represented and the freedom of
just
at that time in in the 1950s being able
to like just get in your car and just
travel around the whole country wherever
you wanted to go and that's what he
wanted to do he was really looking for
that that's experience of like just
total freedom and and no matter what
disaster he and his his pals went with
him got into that they would somehow get
themselves out of it um
so a lot of times people think about
carrock that's the kind of book that
they think about but a lot of his
earlier books are actually about lowell
about the very place that he
talked about leaving so he could go see
bigger and and broader and more
different things but
it's clear from the the so-called lowell
books that he wrote
that he was in fact very much in love
with
this city and the city was ultimately
always
his home um for example uh
well well basically a very well-known
book that he wrote called the town and
the city is about basically that
contrast between living in a small city
like lowell and in a bigger place like
new york
and um a book called maggie cassidy was
really about a girl that he had a crush
on in high school and this this kind of
i think
it's it's not totally clear how much
this is based on what really happened
and how much of this is the novel but um
how this girl just to him envisioned
everything that was that was ideal um in
his life and a book about about his
brother visions of shiraz his older
brother gerard died when he was about
nine years old and kerouac himself would
have been about four
at the time and he was always haunted by
his brother gerard and he even said that
he wrote through the spirit of his
brother gerard that everything he wrote
came directly from gerard and that book
is as much about what it's like to be a
working class french canadian person
in lowell at that time working in the
mills
going to work going to church
going to catholic school speaking french
in the home and speaking it at school
and
so
a lot of those things i think to today
really resonate today in present-day
lowell we are very much a multicultural
city in the truest sense of the word we
truly have people of many different
cultures and many different languages
basically coming here to find their
dream and to find that way their way and
that's how it was with kerouac's family
and that's the lowell that he talks
about in those so-called lowell books as
well
very much
karolak's voice
was a unique american voice in much the
same way that hemingway's was
but these early experiences of jack
having been brought up in a microcosm of
the french canadian
immigrants
and the community that
that he grew up in
perhaps in in a in a very significant
way uh it's a hard to measure
created the filter through which he
interpreted the world
and
it was this community of communities
that
still
keeps kerouac alive in lowell because
today
lowell is still a community of
communities
and
i think that uh
we have a a unique
literary
laboratory here uh because
in many ways lowell of today is is very
much similar to the lull of caroux day
right
lowell
really runs through all of kerouac's
books even beyond the lowell book
so-called lowell books there are five
novels that are largely set in low but
you'll find references to lowell
throughout his work so he might be on
desolation peak
in
washington state in the cascades
and he'll be writing about remembering
something in lowell or he's got this
very strange book called book of dreams
which is a a kind of unique book in the
uh sort of american literature where
it's a collection of his
transcriptions of dreams he used to keep
a notebook by his bed and a pencil or
pen and as soon as he'd wake up he'd
hurry up and write it down because you
know how you forget your dreams uh if
you don't make some notes uh
and um in book of dreams you know all
his life he's dreaming about lol whether
he's in mexico city or in tangier or san
francisco or in lowell
and so
fundamentally this was where he was
formed this is where he became a writer
this is where
he felt most grounded
and
he lived here
pretty much he was 21 years old even
though
after high school he went on to columbia
university he had a football scholarship
well he he said it wasn't a football
scholarship he said it was a scholar
scholarship because columbia university
didn't give football scholarships but it
was because he was a football player at
lowell high school
that he was recruited to go to columbia
he spent a year in prep school in new
york city and then went to columbia
had a kind of a
up and down career at columbia wound up
being there a couple of years but in
between he would come back to lowell his
permanent address in a sense because his
parents were here in lowell up through
1943 when he was 21 years old but then
he always came back to lowell uh and and
of course in later years you know he
sort of recovered his experience uh
through writing about it and that became
the first
uh
set of books in a series that he later
came to call the doulos legend he had a
fictional name for himself uh called
jack doulos with d-u-l-u-o-z
and
he his
big scheme as a writer eventually uh
became to write the story of his life
you know through this sort of cycle of
fiction and and the lower books become
the sort of the first phase of it and
then uh on the road is sort of the
middle phase and then books like big sur
and satori in paris become the end of it
i think it's it's fair to say that
though jack left lull for a period lol
never left jack
and even in his so-called on the road
books
um
as paul indicated you see these
references continually to lowell
and um
i can't think of another american writer
where this is as true that
the the the
environment in which the individual
grew
uh remains with them and and keeps
coming out repeatedly in their work the
way it does with jack kerouac
i think that um
when we think about kerouac and lowell
in particular
the
one of the unifying things about pretty
much everything he writes is that
is that struggle that he had he wanted
to be so much recognized as a writer and
an individual and he
i think
saw a lot of what was going on in in our
country in in the 1950s as
a time when when people seem to have a
great need for conformity
this is when suburbia started to really
really come about
and um and and there was i think always
this this ongoing struggle which which i
think is really part of the whole
literary american experience of the
struggle of an individual person who
really wants those individual freedoms
just to go
where he wants to go
and do what he wants to do
and
and yet
as paul said and as larry said that
lowell never really quite quite leaves
him and
and ultimately
he he ultimately really always seems to
come back full circle
um to that place and and not only
himself as the character in in his
novels but
all of the other characters that he
creates that are really significant
characters in in the book seem to be
engaged in this
also um he has a character called and
some of them are kind of sorted
characters too um like sri stasa who is
a prostitute who's also a drug addict
and um you know there there are people
that he meets at road stops and farms
and at crazy parties out on the west
coast or actually there's a lot of crazy
parties throughout throughout a lot of
the books and and even when when people
are are crazy and partying there's
there's still always this there's still
actually this very serious struggle
going on about
you know who who am i and
what is going to be my place in this
culture and
how can i how can i transcend it even
though i'm a product of it
i think meg's point the
asking the big questions
i think that accounts for
kerouac's lasting importance and the
fact that successive generations of
young people discover him not unlike
henry david thoreau uh kerouac was very
much a spiritual and a philosophical
writer he was
addressing those big questions what is
the meaning of life what am i doing here
how am i best gonna spend my life uh
well kerouac made the decision the best
thing he could do is be a writer when he
was 19 he wrote a piece uh
uh where he was sort of interviewing
himself and he said who was jack kerouac
and he said well jack kerouac is a man
and i'm going to do the most man-like
thing and write for my fellow men and he
thought that was the best way
that he could use his time on earth in
fact he said uh
in another piece he wrote always
considered writing my duty on earth
and so he
took that as his role he never had much
of a job otherwise i mean he was
somebody who worked a little bit you
know as a
on the southern pacific railroad and had
a job here and a job there but he didn't
have any kind of a
a career or professional career he was a
writer he was an artist and
it was a very difficult struggle for him
even though his first book was published
pretty quickly when he was 28 years old
he published his first novel the town in
the city a big new york publisher he had
a kind of a successful homecoming right
down here on merrimack street where the
barnes noble bookstore is that was a
department store called the bauma sherry
department store and he had a book
signing there
and he was a kind of returning hero the
lowell son excerpted the book but then
he went seven years without publishing
anything else and in those seven years
uh his writing changed he became a more
kind of
distinctive authentic
voice as a writer
whereas in his first book he was kind of
influenced by people he had admired
particularly thomas wolfe
but then he began to develop his own way
of of writing and i was listening to the
uh
the readers with the poetry and it was
very much in the spirit of kerouac
because he loved language the
experimentation with language he's known
for his uh quote-unquote spontaneous
prose which was a a very
uh energized fluid prose style
influenced by jazz and larry probably
knows more about jazz than me
well i i think that
it's it's undeniable that he was the
voice of his generation he really was in
much the same way that fitzgerald was
the voice of his generation
um
karowak is associated with that period
the same way james dean is with film
um
and
and
bop was the form uh in jazz at that time
that was emerging it was experimental it
was
um
expansive it was karowak it was it was
it represented
um the same thing that that meg
addressed uh
in musical terms
it was exploring the boundaries it was
it was trying to make sense out of out
of things that uh before
uh seemed to make sense and now had to
be cut up and and put together in a
different way in order to
to make them fit
and the uh kerouac's voice
uh very much represented this this this
new sound this new beat
that was uh a part of daily life at that
time
um
his love of
sound i think again partly comes from
his his early upbringing and and hearing
the the the french canadian particularly
the dialectical the way it was spoken
here in lowell
and uh
anyone who reads kerouac immediately can
pick up on the fact that this is a
writer who writes for the ear
he called the uh
the local brand of french spoken by the
french canadian americans in lowell he
said it was the most languagey language
he had ever heard
yeah yeah i think that's that's
definitely true um
the keralax
relationship to sound as as much as to
writing um let's say i think when most
of us when we think about writing i mean
we we think about writing
writing it on the page reading it on the
page and sometimes
sound doesn't even even enter into the
inter enter into it for us but for
karowak actually sound was was a big
part of that um jazz the the cadence and
and the chaos both of of jazz
music and the sounds of people speaking
french and also greek and some various
other languages that were being spoken
and are still spoken in lowell
and
also i think just the sound of of people
that he would meet in the way that they
would talk when you read his books the
the dialect and the dialogue is pretty
true
has a has a real ring of truth it sounds
like just the way that people talked and
there's a lot of kind of 1950s type
slang and and lingo in there and some of
it sounds almost kind of quaint now when
we read it
um but that was just the normal natural
way that people would would carry on a
conversation and um i wanted to take a
moment to say
that i think it was really great that we
had some students reading some poems
here today because i mean for one thing
the poems were all really great and you
guys read them really well but also
because that's a big part of the of the
process and that was a big part of
keralax writing process the people the
fact that people would get up and read
what they had written and share it with
others
um
a tremendous risk inside but also
the way that that people were won by
those words and by the fact that they
were being shared
and that writing was no longer a
cloistered experience of just a person
writing stuff down but that it was
something meant to be shared and meant
to be heard and meant to be lived
i um
i talked to david amram the jazz
musician
the very wonderful jazz musician who was
kerouac's long time friend and
collaborator who is going to be in
lowell this weekend as as part of this
wonderful special and he's a frequent
guest to the annual lowell celebrates
carol act festival in october
and i did an interview with him about a
year ago
and we talked about that we talked about
the little poetry gatherings they would
have in people's attics and lofts at
these parties and in greenwich village
and how people would just get up and
read what they wrote or sometimes a
musician would accompany them he talked
about how he met kerouac and he was
wearing a
um like like a jack shirt and he he
looked like a like a canadian from
lowell
and he said i want to jam with you i
want to i want to read my poems i want
you to do music and and play
with me and um
and and i said well what did you think
of that experience david
um what was that like and he said that
was
she said i knew this was you know i knew
this was something happening
um and that marriage of of sounds and
making literature alive to people and
keep it alive i think was a big part of
what those guys were trying to do and i
think what what you guys are trying to
do and what we're trying to do here in
lowell today
it's a living experience definitely and
and i think the fact that this year is
going to represent the 15th annual
lowell celebrates kerouac festival here
in lowell uh it
definitely attests to the fact that it
is a living experience it's something
that
uh it's not stagnant it's not something
that was and just belongs on a shelf but
it's it's still vital and it's still
an important part of of uh
rep representing people's emotions the
emotions that jack kerouac spoke about
in his books are the same emotions that
we feel today
and
and and i think that
what what meg was saying uh is a big
part of of that process this community
of artists that
were a part of this and and paul could
probably address that in in in
its significance
yeah well we should probably say a few
words uh before we wrap up about the
beat generation i mean kerouac so
associated with that term the beat
generation you know what is that you
know one of his poetry friends said you
know five guys a generation don't make
uh but uh as i said earlier
kerouac really saw himself as a
spokesman for his generation you have to
remember he was uh
of the world war ii generation some of
you have heard this assume the greatest
generation tom brokaw has this new book
uh well you know kerouac was of the
world war ii generation and
a lot of people came through that
experience of world war ii very changed
i mean kerouac had friends of his who he
was
in school with at this school
who were killed in world war ii his best
friend who
his best sort of literary soul mate uh
who he considered uh the major influence
on him becoming a writer uh becoming a
literary writer i would say uh was
sebastian sampus who was a young guy an
intellectual a poet who graduated from
lowell high school he went on to emerson
college then became a medic
in the united states army and was killed
in in italy
and he had other friends there's a
outside the old building there's a sign
kuminsela square for another one of his
friends i believe he was a pilot uh who
was was killed uh you know um you know
in a plane crash uh so this was a
profound experience for kara karak
himself
uh
served time in the merchant marine that
was his way of participating in the war
effort he uh
did a couple of merchant marine voyages
carrying supplies and ammunition to
england
in the early
mid well beginning of the war 1942-43
and in those days the german submarines
were tracking all the merchant marine
ships so it was very uh dangerous uh
situation so coming out of that world
war ii experience there were a lot of
people who were asking the big questions
as meg was saying you know their lives
had been kind of uh broken apart and
they were wondering you know what is
what is it all about and uh
carrocks fell in with a group of writers
and artists and musicians and painters
in new york city uh some people might
call them kind of bohemian types
and at one point one of his friends said
well you know what's our you know what
would you call our generation he said
well it's a beat generation and what he
meant was you know these were people who
were kind of down to essences and
essentials and uh were
looking you know to find meaning in life
and
to
find you know where joy resided you know
what was it that was going to make uh
you know their life a joyful ecstatic
experience
and they found it through things that
didn't require a lot of money and didn't
require having a big house and and so
forth and a lot of it involved you know
artistic experiences and music and and
writing and um
one one thing that david when david
amram and i were talking about exactly
that
and um and we talked about the fact how
i think because of of the lifestyle that
that a lot of these guys and gals were
living at the time
some people came away with the
impression that
they that this was a this was about a
lack of discipline or a lack of
commitment or uh just kind of dropping
out if you will from what was going on
in the society and
the reality is that um even though a lot
of those those things did happen and
maybe for some of the of the peripheral
folks that that really did become a way
of life
but
there was actually a real struggle going
on for some kind of excellence
david and i talked about the fact that
being being a great artist and by that i
mean whether it's being a poet a
musician
whatever it may be a novelist a dancer
is both about that that spirit that
passion to create things and and to be
fearless about it and say you know i'm
gonna do this this is this is what
belongs to me and i'm gonna do this to
be able to do that requires the
discipline
to be committed to it to make sacrifices
in order to do it and to always be
reaching for a higher standard of
excellence to be
both your own biggest fan and your own
harshest critic
and david amram talked about just you
know the hours and hours and hours of
practicing as a musician just the
grueling life of literally being on the
road wasn't always so glamorous or fun
but that these were the things that he
did and that kerouac did and that allen
ginsberg and all their other friends and
colleagues did joyfully because they
were not just simply in pursuit of
living a kind of a slouchy lifestyle and
sleeping on their friends couches which
you know they did do
but they were ultimately trying to
pursue a level of excellence as
people who were creative
and they were not so much dropping out
of the society as perhaps trying to to
create a society a society in which they
could do this and which they could
attain
that level of excellence in everything
that they tried to do as artists
i um
i don't think i can add any more to that
really might be a good time to open up
the floor for
what book you could questions to 9th
graders to read by jack kerouac besides
tom city
what else i mean
i think um
sure maggie cassidy is i would think an
awesome book to read because well i mean
if nothing else it is about high school
it is about going to high school and
there's a lot about lowell high school
in it um and it's one thing that's kind
of cool about the lowell books is you
read it you say wow you know if you live
in louisiana i know where that is
but it's also about
just a for real experience of of being
in love and that that's you know that's
that's a real experience and and
and a real part of of an everyday
universal experience i think visions of
gerard is
a wonderful book it's a very it's a very
sad book in some ways because it deals
with the death of his brother but it's
by no means a morbid book it is
about it is about life much more than it
is about about death it's just about the
daily rhythm of life of people speaking
both french and english
and um i would i would definitely
recommend that
and um i'm gonna let the other guys
recommend their personal favorites also
um
yeah i'm thinking more in terms of a
place for someone to start another one
that
is a pretty good place to start is
actually one of the last books he wrote
if not the last book uh vanity of
doulawo
and he wrote that when he was living in
lowell so the second time around in 1967
in 1968 and in it he sort of revisits a
lot of the material that occurred that
was sort of the substance of the town in
the city and
in
maggie cassidy but uh he writes about it
in a little bit more straightforward way
uh for someone who is just encountering
kerouac it might be a book easier to
follow but it sort of takes him from
his uh from about i guess 14 years old
or so up through his early years in new
york and it's you know it's uh i'd say
that's a good place to start too
i think anyone who's
had some background backpacking would
really enjoy dharma bums that's a
fantastic book
i know that
it was the first book that i read of
jack kerouac and i spent a good deal of
time backpacking
and when i read it i just felt the
rhythm of of him running down the
mountain when he got to the top of the
mountain and he starts running down i
said i know exactly what he's talking
about you could feel the rhythm in his
words
yeah double bonds is a good choice it's
also one that has a
story that's a little bit easier to
follow than i mean some of carwax work
is kind of challenging because he's
working in this
uh experimental mode of spontaneous pros
wouldn't start with visions of cody no
but no dahmer bums is a good place to
start uh as well yeah how about books of
criticism or biography do you recommend
any particular titles there
i like tom clark's biography of kerouac
mostly because it focuses on kerouac as
a writer
it's a kind of biography of
him in his writing life
there's six or seven biographies that
are out there now uh
all of them flawed because
they were written by people who didn't
have access to the full
uh range of caroux papers
the first biography that is
going to be
published with access is douglas
brinkley's uh biography that he's
writing right now he's going to be in
lowell this weekend um
but i think i like tom clark's and
charters uh as for a sort of summation
of the life which was really the first
one that holds up
and i also like
desolate angel by dennis mcnally
ann charters also was the editor of
collections of correspondence
and it's and those are really fun to
read because those are for one thing
there's first-hand writings by kerouac
himself to his friends to his colleagues
and um it's it really is a it's pretty
neat to just read what people were just
writing you know to each other for each
other um and that's
not a bio
biography first per se certainly but in
a way it's it reads almost kind of like
like an informal autobiography a life in
letters is actually what ann calls it
yeah exactly i think another book of um
local interests in particular would be
uh kerouac's nashua connection
and uh that speaks to the fact that
part of his well good part of his family
actually had settled in nashua and uh
um
from canada correct yeah they were first
in nashville and they then they came to
lowell for the
so there's a lot of interesting uh
anecdotal information in terms of back
and forth uh trips for family gatherings
and things like that that's very
interesting to recognize the author
sure
steve eddington the author it's a little
plug he's right here
he's the author
just a second i want to just add a quick
thing to what paul was saying about
beating where that and where that came
from i think
world war ii even though this country
was spared the uh
sort of real harsh realities of a
horrors of it up close i think it
brought death on a scale that this
planet had never seen before between the
uh the atomic bombs being dropped on
hiroshima nagasaki the death camps plus
just the level of
battlefield casualties it made i think
death was more of a
horrifying reality that had not been
before up until then i think part of
what the beats were saying was
how do we how do we choose life how do
we find meaning in life how do we
celebrate life how do we find joy in
life in the face of the kind of death
that we have seen over the second world
war i think part of what was going on in
the 50s was how you answered that kind
of a question so when you read kerouac
you had this overlay of what you call
what he called joy kicks and darkness
there's a lot of joy and celebration but
there's this undertone of sort of
sadness and tragedy and death and i
think what the beat generation meant was
people how do we how do we celebrate
life how do we choose life in the face
of the level of death that we have seen
over the last four five six years
we have time for a final question
um
it's obvious from like what you guys
have all been talking about that lol has
a lot to do with kerouac as a writer
kerouac as a person
and
i'm told that if you were to go to san
francisco like the uh north beach
sections uh hate ashbury sections that
um
kerouac and lowell is kind of like
unheard of and i mean they really they
believe that they believe that san
francisco is where a lot of his stuff
came out of in that that influenced them
and they kind of
they
they tend not to like you know listen
when people say oh well lol's a big part
of kerouac so i mean
do you think that maybe i mean san
francisco did take a bigger part in his
writings or is i mean you think lol is
the dominant
well he became a writer i mean this is
he's formed as a writer in lowell uh
he didn't meet
people like ginsburg and william
burroughs and others in new york city
until he was 21 and he was well along
the way to being a writer at that time
san francisco is really important in
kerouac's development because it's all
tied in with the san francisco poetry
renaissance and larry was mentioning
dharma bums you know that's where
carowak makes kind of the west coast
connection
and uh
begins uh very early to write about
things like uh americans studying
buddhism uh i mean it's amazing when you
think about today what is twenty
thousand buddhists in lowell you know
and uh i mean i think kerala would have
also found that amazing uh as someone
who really kind of prepared the way for
uh
buddhism to be more mainstream in
america through his writings so i mean
uh i think it's you know maybe you're
hearing a little west coast chauvinism
over there they want to claim karuwak
certainly was an important place for him
you know he's got
works that uh draw on his time in san
francisco he's got a book uh of poems
called san francisco blues
uh you know so clearly california uh as
it was for like a lot of new england
california is kind of like the golden
land you know if you're from from lowell
a lot of people go out there and sort of
see uh you know what it has to offer and
i think kerouac was very much the same
way
and it's you know that
is what contributes to him being you
know an american author because i mean
carol in fact north american because
really kerouac kind of there's this
triangle from uh um
quebec you know to mexico city to the
northeast and new england and and and
over to the west coast and kerouac is
moving all around the continent and so
he's uh he's rare in that sense because
he's a kind of north american voice you
know going down and writing uh you know
out of the mexico mexico city at a time
when not a lot of people were doing that
i just okay i'm sorry i just want to add
real quick to what you were saying yes
it's true there's there's definitely and
has been i think for a long time
sometimes a common perception of kerouac
being so strongly associated with san
francisco that some people actually
sometimes mistakenly think that that's
where he's from
um what's really neat now is that and
i've certainly noticed this within the
festival every october is how many
people now come from the west coast to
lowell
and and it's it's so wonderful that they
would first of all choose to to come
here you know make time in their life to
come and visit where jack was born
and where he grew up and and where his
family was and so forth and i think very
very much in the last i would say in the
last 15 years or so there's been much
more of a realization of lowell as being
kerouac's hometown and
like i said i think what's really great
is we have people coming from all over
the world but it's really neat you know
that they're coming from the west coast
and saying wow this is carol axe lowell
we're out time i want to thank our
panelists very much for the presentation
today and i also thank our student poets
we appreciate all of your participation
today and we are here at the peter
stamis
library media center at lowell high
school i wish you all a good day
[Applause]
this week at
americanwriters.org join in the forum on
jack kerouac and the beep generation
with guest gerald nicosia author of
memory babe a critical biography of jack
kerouac
book club members log on and post your
questions by clicking on the get
interactive box on the american writers
homepage
mr nicosia will answer questions posted
to the forum all week
and this friday at 8 pm eastern catch
the encore presentation of american
writers 2.
join historian doug brinkley who's
writing a biography on jack kerouac
also the conference spoke and members
heard from some of the victims of abuse
we'll show you that tomorrow at 1 pm
eastern
it was just a usual saturday night good
time nothing else
the b-bop winos were wailing away the
working man tennis the cats who worked
and got their horns out of hawk and blue
and had their women troubles
and came on in their horns with a will
saying things a lot to say talkative
horns
you could almost hear the words and
better than that the harmony
made you hear the way to fill up blank
spaces of time with the tune and very
consequence of your hands and breath and
dead soul summer
august 1949
and frisco blowing mad
the dew and the muscat in the interior
fields of joaquin
and down in watsonville the lettuce
blowing
the money flowing for frisco so seasonal
and mad
jack kerouacs on the road brought him to
national prominence in 1957
before this notoriety he lived with his
mother in the college park neighborhood
of orlando florida where they rented the
back room apartment of a small one-floor
home there
today the home serves as the anchor of
the kerwak writers and residence project
of orlando
we visited the site to learn about jack
kerouac's time in central florida before
and after the publication of on the road
and the role of the home today
jack kerouac arrived in orlando in
december of 1956
he came here because his sister and her
family had just moved here
carol and blake's husband wanted to be
part of the burgeoning space race and
the technology explosion
jack's mother wanted to be near her only
daughter and grandson and wherever she
went jack would follow because he needed
a place to crash after all of his
travels so that's how it started jack
and his mother moved into the back porch
apartment here in this home in july of
1957.
at the time he's basically a nobody
nomad writer from lowell massachusetts
he's 35 years old
by the time he moves out of this home in
april of 1958
his seminal work on the road is
published
he becomes a media darling before people
know what that was
in october he comes back to this house
to escape the suffocating fame that he
was not at all ready for
but once he gets back into this home
he's rejuvenated
finally he's vindicated to his family
members they can see a new york times
bestseller list with the name jack
kerouac on it and it's very invigorating
so he gets into this house he writes a
one-act play called the beat generation
he takes phone calls from major
magazines his agent is talking to marlon
brando about perhaps bringing on the
road to the big screen he writes these
energetic letters to his girlfriend
joyce johnson saying i've got this brand
new royal typewriter i've got a roll of
teletype paper
i can just swing and swing like the
improvisational jazz artist
he was very energized
so he's enjoying a very prolific period
here
then by the end of 57 he writes the
dharma bums in this house so it's a very
prolific period
when he's living here
and this house represents the
transformation
of jack kerouac from that nobody nomad
rider to the bard of the beat generation
and just in a relatively short amount of
time
when you go into the back of this tiny
little back porch apartment
it's very moving to see
the hand-to-mouth conditions they must
have been living at the time you know
now it's nicely renovated and it looks
very nice but back then it was very
meager
and he's living in this 10 by 10 room
with a single light bulb hanging from
the ceiling
he has his work table and all of his
notebooks that he would write in
spread out on the table and he has the
roll of tail of type paper
fed into his typewriter so you know he
can type without an eruption
he would work at night because it was so
hot during the day in this tin roof
cottage
and so i imagine the sound of
that rapid fire typing from this manual
typewriter in the middle of the night
spilling out onto the streets here in
college park
he typed under this tree just to my left
that's where he used to come out when it
was so hot it was just hot as heck down
here in the summer and in fact that's
what got him to leave orlando eventually
the heat
and he used to type right here he'd take
oranges from very nice neighbors that
live nearby and different citrus and he
played basketball at a couple of houses
down the street that had basketball
hoops this young man named don jordan at
the time he was a
teenager
and he bumped into a guy at lake adair
just a few blocks from here back in the
early 60s late 50s
and they got to talking and this
gentleman was telling this young boy
how
he was more musician than a writer and
that he was going to new york to work
some more jazz
gigs with his friend david amram and
that was jack kerouac
his writing style was natural
it came from his heart
it came from his feelings of the moment
and he always had that jazz rhythm
he could rap we're out here in lowell in
the usa and just one thing for c spain i
gotta say the spontaneity is always
where it's at and you don't have to be
any type of special cat all you got to
do is look into your soul or whatever
you write and think is going to come out
whole
well that was the kind of thing
that jack and i would do for fun on the
spot not to win the polish surprise for
bad poetry
but
to free yourself as
any improviser would do so that when you
were sitting down to write it down
whether you were writing a symphony
which i would do after playing a jazz
gig all night or you were writing a
novel which jack would do after we've
been out rapping and playing and doing
things ourselves
our minds would be free
to dare to be creative to take what he
called the first thought as the best
thought and dare to put it down on paper
kerouac liked to approach writing like
the athlete he used to be he was a very
accomplished football player
and
he wanted to approach writing with that
same sense of vigor he said he typed
fast because life on the road was fast
so
he was very open about the fact that he
took certain stimulants like benzedrine
he said he needed alcohol to an extent
to achieve an ecstasy of the mind
but he would write in these marathon
sessions for instance the dharma bonds
was written in 11 days and nights here
now granted he had sketched out much of
the work in his little notebooks that he
would keep with him but this was the
actual process of bringing it all into
one work so he would type very quickly
he would type during these marathon
sessions but he felt that's what he
needed to create his spontaneous prose
uh he wanted to to feel like the jazz
musicians where it was this sense of
typing without interruption because what
came first he felt was what needed to go
on paper and stay there
jack lived in many many places during
his lifetime orlando was one of them
and he told me one time he said you know
davey he said
it's good for my mother's health the
weather is good for my
for my mother's health
and it was also peaceful enough where he
could get some writing done
because they
at the time that on the road came out
he was totally unknown
and even afterwards people there
weren't as aware of his celebrity as
they were in other places he had some
peace and he had good memories
jack kerouac had very much a love-hate
relationship with orlando you'll see
some of the passages in his in his early
diaries and it always follows this
pattern when he arrives oh it's great
i'm so glad to be back in america or i'm
so glad to be among the the wonderful
smell of the citrus trees at night and
i'll die here in paradise it's great but
then he starts to get bored
and
then it becomes this heat wave horror i
can't write here he starts to
unfortunately get into the alcoholism
because of because of the boredom very
much a love-hate relationship but what's
interesting about orlando especially is
that
this is where he
incurred many of the personal tragedies
the personal challenges that come from
just everyday life that he never really
wrote about publicly the death of his
sister
being accused of being a deadbeat dad
fighting alcoholism fighting boredom and
that's what's so compelling about his
time in orlando is you have jack kerouac
the american icon and then here in
orlando you have jack the average guy
who's reaching middle age
and he's having a very tough time
dealing with that
when kerouac finally decided he'd had
enough of his hideaway life in orlando
and he was just too bored with it
he bought a house up in northport new
york but that doesn't work out it's a
little too close to the city there's
some gossip mongers and they decide
they're going to get back
they decide to move in on the same
street
and back then this area called kingswood
manor is this exclusive suburb on the
northwest edge of town near the ben
white horse track up here
and for kerouac this is just an amazing
thing because it's a big three bedroom
house
and it has air conditioning and he wrote
his agent sterling lord that it sends
coolness to every room in the house
and the speckled terazzo tile floor
that's just so so florida
and so when you when you go
to the street alfred drive
uh you'll see the larger
subdivision type florida block house
that's pretty typical but for kerouac
this was a big step up in his life
because finally
through his riding he was able to
achieve a kind of
middle class
living and for him that was a big deal
after so many lean years
but it doesn't really work out
because carolyn's husband sees jack
as something of a rival
the kerouac family speaks french around
him and he doesn't speak french and he
doesn't like that
they're just too close
and the experiment does not work out
and as it turns out
the two families really have a wedge
between them by the time jack and his
mother move out in december of 1962 over
issues like that over issues of money
you know this grand experiment of the
blake's and kerouac living is sort of an
extended family never worked out
i think the biggest
tragedy that happened to jack kerouac in
orlando was the death of his sister here
in 1964.
the year before her death
they had argued a lot over money
kerouac had been
giving her family some money to try to
survive basically and it had driven a
wedge between them and the last time he
had talked to his sister he had he had
come off the plane here in orlando he'd
gone to the house he was very
belligerent and he wrote that she called
the cops on him
so
the next time they move to florida they
decide let's put some space between
ourselves and the blakes and they move
to st petersburg
well in that time carolyn's marriage
breaks up
and she takes an apartment
in
the orlando neighborhood of college park
and her life really starts to fall apart
and kerouac and his mother are in st
petersburg and they're not really around
to help
and
one night
he comes home from playing pool and his
mother's standing in the doorway and
she's inconsolable his sister's dead
and what had happened was
she had been talking to her husband on
the phone he said i want a divorce and
she died of a heart attack
and kerouac was so distraught over that
that he locked himself in the bathroom
and wouldn't come to the funeral
and he never wrote about it publicly but
to his friend he said he was he had a
strong sense of guilt because he said
the last time i saw her i gave her hell
and
i did i think that's his sense of guilt
that neither he nor his mother got over
that they weren't around for her when
she needed them
i think jack kerouac's life is a very
cautionary tale
people have to remember that jack
kerouac died of alcoholism long before
the betty ford clinic
long before we realized that alcoholism
was a sickness
back then
people drank and the people who loved
them suffered in silence and that's what
happened with jack kerouac kerouac would
talk about needing alcohol to establish
this ecstasy of the mind to really open
up his creative gates if you will but i
think that was also a rationalization
and his life was a cautionary tale it
destroyed him it destroyed that
wonderful
creative mind that he had
and that's why i think this part of his
legacy during the orlando years the
early years is so important
because he was able to write here he was
able to be prolific
before the cancer of what the critics
thought and and the demons of drink
really got the best of him
but i think it's very important for
young people not to romanticize
the alcohol aspect of his life
he died a miserable
horrific wrenching death in a saint
petersburg hospital far too young at 47
years old
because of the alcoholism
and had he not been
an alcoholic heaven knows what kind of
output we could have seen from this
great rider
the jack heroic project was started by
bob kealing and myself my wife
to try to increase interest in
literature in central florida and put
central florida on the national and even
international arts map by letting people
know that jack kerouac spent his most
productive years in this house behind me
here in college park in an area right
outside downtown orlando florida the
purpose is to do what jack kerouac
wanted to do which was create a writer's
retreat that was always his dream and he
intended to do it in central florida and
he was never able to the story is that
jack kerouac actually purchased land in
orlando
uh there would be a retreat for his
buddies and his friends and young
writers to come down here and just write
and just research rest relax talk chat
and
because of the way his last seven or
eight years were he never got a chance
to do that he sold the property and
ironically the property that he owned is
now under interstate 4 out here that
runs east west north south through
downtown orlando and the second house
that's here on the kerala
we used to be on i-4 not the same
property but it was moved here in the
early 60s and
and that's a
it's a great feeling to know that we're
doing what jack kerouac would have done
had he lived that's a wonderful feeling
jack kerouac's relevance is
that any young person
who dreams of being a writer
or a painter or a musician or a poet or
a computer programmer or a surgeon
or any kind of
dream
that they are told they are not
qualified for that they can
do it because jack
came from a
time in our society and from the
background in american society of the of
the 30s and the 40s
when
he would have been told as he was very
often you can't possibly be a writer the
kind of person you are where you're from
the way you speak the way you dress the
way you write no one is interested in
what you're writing about and of course
jack
as all great artists spoke of his time
he was a reporter
for his time
i think generation to generation jack
kerouac's writing resonates
with each new generation that discovers
his work
like nobody i've ever read
kerouac
captures
the romance for the road
trying to drink in this beautiful
landscape that is america but
yet at the same time
it's imbued with
the sadness that comes
with
the limitations of our lives
but yet
that celebration of america
is so palpable for the people who
discover it for the first time
that celebration
of the ordinary
or what seems ordinary
but when kerouac writes about it for
some reason
it becomes extraordinary
because he seems to be this this
innocent
who is truly
in love with this unfolding landscape he
sees before him
the plains of kansas
the cornfields of nebraska
the abandoned train depots
he says i wonder what denver will be
like
so
it's like he's seeing america with a
fresh set of eyes and i think that
appeals so strongly
to the young people
of of america and that's why
generation to generation his work is
still so relevant and so meaningful
so dean and i raced on to the east coast
one point we drove a 1947 cadillac
limousine across the state in nebraska
110 miles an hour beating hot shot
passenger trains and steel wheel
freights in one nervous shuttering snap
up of the gas
we told stories and zoomed east
they were hobos by the tracks wino
bottles the moon shining on wood fires
there were white-faced cows out in the
plains dim as nuns
there was dawn iowa
mississippi river at davenport chicago
by nightfall
oh man said dean to me we stood in front
of a bar on north clark street in a hot
summer night dig these old
chinamen that cut by chicago what a
weird town
american writers 2 the 20th century
c-span's history series that looks at
the america
and as we mentioned this week c-span's
american writers series is looking at
how jack kerouac and the beat writers
chronicled and influenced the course of
our nation recently we interviewed
congressman marty meehan about growing
up in kerouac's hometown of lowell
massachusetts
congressman martin meehan from the fifth
district from massachusetts could you
please describe the impact jack kerouac
has had on your district and the city of
lowell in general well he's had a
tremendous impact on the city of lowell
we're an immigrant city
and
jack kerouac of course was a french
canadian came from a big family many of
us who grew up in lowell
uh
have come from big families and
jack herrick made a name for himself
as a writer and all of us through lowell
high school
getting around the same areas that jack
eric wrote about the merrimack river
the immigrants
the streets sort of the mentality
he means a great deal to this city and
particularly this region
so
we take time out to uh recognize his uh
his uh accomplishments and also uh he
helped put lowell on the map in many
ways
could you describe that we were standing
in cairock park uh what this uh park
means to the city and uh and why i was
honored for carorac well it's
interesting because not everyone in the
city wanted to honor jack kerouac in
this way there are some that were
concerned about uh jack kerouac's
lifestyle or what he
represented but i think the vast
majority of the people in lowell wanted
to recognize his contributions i wanted
to recognize the fact that he inspired
the whole beat generation and that he
wrote
so much that people in lowell could
identify with
those of us who grew up in lowell so i
think people are
feel proud that a great american writer
grew up and wrote about lowell there
were some famous people from lowell that
in some instances deny they were from
lowell jack kerouac not only was from no
lowell grew up here uh but
he wrote about it
what do you think is the most uh
important aspect of jack kerouac why do
you think he's so popular
well i think he's popular because he
sort of
went to the
drum of a different
beat he he sort of set his own way he
did what he wanted to do
kind of a spur of the moment
yeah this is what i want to do now and
this is what's important i mean he
in many ways i think reflects that the
an attitude that people sometimes
have in in this region or elsewhere um
he just uh
he was his own drummer so to speak
how has care act affected you personally
or can you tell about growing up in this
area and what did carowak mean to you
personally well i think personally
growing up and going to high school and
college here you always wanted to go and
have a drink where jack kerouac had a
drink or
talk to people that jack kerouac had
talked about uh
uh talked to
um
you know the the french canadian
population here is so important to
lowell and he was such an important
contributor from that community and
it made us want to learn more
about our surroundings about the
merrimack river about uh
about the establishments in lowell so i
i think growing up in lowell and i'm not
quite as old as jack kerouac would have
been but
uh it made us want to explore the
different parts of the city in a way
that we probably wouldn't have uh if an
offer jack correct but more than that
it's about reading it's about literary
literature it's about
uh
thinking about issues that affect our
communities and affect our country in a
way that
is different when you grow up here you
say well this is uh
you know this is somebody has something
to say about our generation and what
it's like to grow up here and the
environment the urban environment you
know i'm interested in it and i think in
many respects we have a national park
here in lowell we
uh we have pride in what this city it's
an immigrant city it's a city where
where poor people come to try to strive
for a better life
and
we need to hold on to things here
people that
made something themselves have made a
significant contribution to jack kerouac
is such an important part of that
what is your favorite character book and
why
um i think the whole beat generation
thing
on the road
is something a lot of my friends
sort of paid attention to as we went off
to college or sometimes traveled across
the country and
sometimes it always didn't connect the
way we thought it might but
he was
you know he was our guy from lowell
talking about things that we understood
and things that we had experienced
thomas and martin meehan thank you for
your time today very much i'm glad
you're here i'm glad you're doing it
and a reminder you can see an encore
presentation of c-span's american
writers program on jack kerouac click on
american writers at borders books
borders is the official bookseller for
american writers
also at our website merriam-webster's
dictionary of american writers a book of
the month club selection and companion
to our series and guide to america's
rich literary tradition
[Music]
and now from lowell massachusetts a look
at american history from the late 1940s
through the early 1960s through the life
and writings of beat writer jack kerouac
[Music]
so dean and i raced on to the east coast
one point we drove a 1947 cadillac
limousine across the state of nebraska
110 miles an hour beating hot shot
passenger trains and steel wheel
freights and one nervous shuddering snap
up of the gas
we told stories and zoomed east
they were hobos by the tracks wino
bottles the moon shining on wood fires
there were white faced cows out in the
plains dim as nuns
there was dawn high
mississippi river at davenport in
chicago by nightfall
oh man said dean and me we stood in
front of a bar on north carolina street
in the hot summer night dig these old
chinamen that cut by chicago what a
weird town
those are some of the sounds of the beat
generation of 1950s america that was
jack kerouac reading from his 1957
classic on the road accompanied by
composer david amram
american writers today brings you to
lowell massachusetts for the life and
times of the city's native son jack
kerouac historian and kerouac biographer
douglas brinkley is on board the c-span
school bus
doug before we learn about the 50s
counterculture why don't you spend a
minute or two telling us about
mainstream america in the 1950s
well of course world war ii ended in
1945 with the atomic blast at hiroshima
and nagasaki and april harriman who was
in our government at that time said it's
time to get back to normal in america
what that meant is going back to doing
what you did before the war if you could
all these um soldiers came back and you
had a gi bill so many of them got to go
to college for the first time and that
forever changed america a great deal but
more than that take a company like ford
motor during world war ii at willow run
they were making b-24 bombers after the
war now they're making these automobiles
cars that a jack kerouac and neil
cassidy can kind of go across the
country and and explore america in a new
way you wouldn't have been able to do
that during world war ii uh the cold war
of course begins very quickly in 1947
harry truman's president and we have
starting what's known as our national
security state
there's the cias created then and the
our department of the air force and the
pentagon and the joint chiefs of staff
and the national security council and if
you like from 47 really to 1950 a red
scare starts to ensue we're worried
about global communism both abroad and
at home and you have the korean war
which dominates that original post-war
period but that's a time what people
start thinking of as a new conformity in
american life the concept of madison
avenue starts uh becoming a big one
meaning you're advertising your products
in a kind of new way television starts
coming into people's homes
um the
consumer culture really starts picking
up in a way unprecedented yet we're
paying about three quarters of our tax
dollars for our defense
and the the scare of that red scare
mccarthyism is the backdrop but you have
to understand jack kerouac and the other
beat writers they are voices if you'd
like of um similar to walt whitman and
throw
their their
individual voices saying we there we
know no restraints we're going to say
and write what we feel like because
we're artists um and i think what
happens it's a little confusing during
this period if you'd like from 1945 to
1960 when truman and ice and our
president cause there's a feeling of
that some ways you're unamerican if you
don't buy the company line during the
eisenhower era if you don't buy the
fortune 500 you know the former
secretary of defense um
engine charlie wilson once said what's
good for general motors is good for
america well jack kerouac didn't believe
that he believed what's good for america
was finding its soul
finding its poetic essence and he went
out to explore america and celebrate it
but he was seen as a dissident writer
now with the perspective of time we
realize much of his prose is very apple
pie and all-american but his idea of the
beat generation was not politics it was
not a political statement as much it was
the celebration of art and celebration
of walt whitman's america i am standing
outdoors right uh by the c-span school
bus in the jack kerouac park in lowell
massachusetts right in the center of the
city and in a few minutes we're going to
take your telephone calls to talk about
his work on the road and how it
described this period in american
history 1950s america we tell you the
telephone numbers so you can take part
in our conversation about this period of
history if you live in the eastern half
of the united states our number here is
eight nine zero 202-585-3890 those of
you watching us in the western half of
the united states two zero two five
eight five three eight nine one doug
brinkley how
prevalent how well known among most of
america were the beat generation writers
well very much so
by the late 1950s kerouac came to this
town lowell where he grew up and we'll
be talking about that somebody came back
in 54 and kind of had a a vision in a
church if you like the notion of the
beatitude of christ that you have in the
bible there's a religious aspect to
kerouac's works uh both his heavy
catholic background and also his um his
adaptations of buddhism which um which
permeate um you know his work a great
deal and the um he became a celebrity
when on the road was published now as
written keep in mind with the journals
and his road trips across america began
in 47 he started typing up a version of
on the road in 48 he had a famous
marathon typing of on the road which
they were pulling the manuscript
together in in 1950 but the book did not
get published till 1957
with the publication of on the road jack
kerouac became an overnight sensation
he went on television shows to promote
it he became
famous with his his collaborations and
music with people like david amram and
steve allen and from and then the next
year 58 he wrote his other two what i
consider classic books the dharma bums
and the subterraneans that was followed
in 1959 by dr sax his face was
recognizable he became like james dean
or elvis presley or marlon brando a kind
of a good bad boy in many ways and he
was uh if you some people used to call
the thinking women like jack kerouac a
lot because of his looks and they call
him the thinking woman's marlon brando
or or
james dean so he became very very famous
and if you study kerouac by biographies
you'll quickly learn that fame destroyed
jack kerouac he wasn't ready for it
are the beat writers especially kerouac
a good snapshot in time or is there
something that transcends the period in
which they lived and wrote
jack kerouac's work clearly transcends
the 1950s and 60s he's become of a first
tier american writer who's 30 books you
can get her in print and he's read and
studied all over the world
but there's also a lot to learn about
looking at kerouac in the 50s if you
look at the art scene
think about jazz in the 1950s which jack
kerouac loved and it's a big part of so
much of his work he had people like
charlie parker dizzy gillespie
performing kerouac fought gillespie and
parker were really as great as uh or in
the same league as a bach and beethoven
and many critics in the 50s laughed at
him for making that kind of comment a
commentary about the power of jazz uh as
a musical and intellectual force well
today people um take that seriously we
look at charlie parker as a classical
musician carol had a great ear for those
musicians and also painting look what
happened in the in the painting world of
the 1950s carrock was friends with
jackson pollock and france klein and
that the whole abstract expressionist
movement and and then jack's you know
pollock's great um you know um
paintings of uh which you know kind of
broke things up so much in the art world
they were all interacting at places like
the cedar tavern in new york so kerouac
was part of the milieu of the great jazz
cats disney gillespie even has a
composition called kerouac and he was
also great friends with all that that
group of painters so it was a kind of
bohemian avant-garde um but i think in
the tradition of whitman and thoreau
revolt against the boring um
essays of what karaoke's and would you
know t.s eliot said books of quiet
desperation that people would write or
or pieces that were meant for the new
yorker about kind of a suburban nature
carop wanted to blow all those out of
the water just as pollock did an art and
and charlie parker did with his horn
let's start mixing our audience in first
call is going to be from goshen new york
welcome to our discussion of 1950s
america oh thank you c-span i you know
every time i want to unplug my cable i
always say to myself what am i going to
do without c-span i love it
my name is tom deegan i actually called
about
two months ago during the hemingway
broadcast and i made this point at the
time regarding hemingway
um that he is as interesting as anything
he ever wrote about and the only other
writer i could say this about
is that i really know of is jack kerouac
i mean his writing changed my life
uh know i just love reading everything
about him and everything he's ever
written but particularly the biographies
i've read several karowak biographies
i'm definitely going to read your sir i
haven't read it yet but i'm definitely
going to pick it up
uh the anne charters biography comes to
mind immediately but uh what in your
opinion
uh are are the best kerouac bios written
and uh one more point i have to make if
anyone ever gets a chance pick up the 10
000 maniac song hey jack kerouac it's
absolutely gorgeous it's beautiful song
and again thank you c-span thank you
thank you
well um a couple things first off my
book's not out yet i'm working on a
biography of jack kerouac and working to
edit his on the road journals both will
be with viking press and will be coming
both will be coming out in a next couple
years so you can be on the lookout for
those there's been a lot of good work on
jack kerouac you mentioned anne charters
she knew jackson and wrote her book came
out in 1973 and it was really broke uh
new ground later between 73 in the 80s
you had dennis mcnally did a book called
desolate angel
which is a wonderful portrait of kerouac
and i'd recommend it in the b generation
and finally 1983 gerald nicosia wrote
memory babe which is a very detailed
footnoted landmark publication in
kerouac study so it was charter i was i
think in followed by mcnally followed by
nicosia of remain the standards but i
also have to say joyce um johnson has
written two marvelous portraits she was
a um a lover and a close friend of jack
kerouac and she did a book called minor
characters which i highly recommend as i
do all the books i'm mentioning and
also she recently published her
correspondence with jack kerouac and ann
charters has edited kerouac's letters in
two volumes that viking press has done
there's a lot of good books and things
to study on jack kerouac i'm going to
try to just build on those and say some
new things due to access i have to some
of caroux journals and other um primary
material and as for your point of
persona writers like hemingway you're
absolutely right jack kerouac and
hemingway are similar in that regard
there are others i think jack london's
persona is so great to read and um you
know so and hunter s thompson is the
persona writer people are more
interested in almost their their
biography and what they're doing
sometimes as they are in their work
brenham texas as we talk about the 50s
and jack kerouac hey thank you for uh
putting me on and uh mr brinkley uh i'm
looking forward to your biography when
it comes out i i really recommend the
ann charters i've read that countless
times since my college days nonetheless
uh he wrote a novel i believe in 48 or
published one the town in the city
that
is a very beautiful novel yet it is
quite uncharacteristic
of his other writings
what happened around 1948 that started
producing the dharma bums and on the
road and
all these other things visions of cody
et cetera what happened to him was it uh
neil cassidy or his travels uh
town city very
it is a very um
conventional novel beautiful novel but
quite conventional something really
happened to him could you talk about
that and if i may uh is there anything
very quickly please call her
posthumously awarded the nobel prize for
literature
all right thanks doug brinkley i'm going
to ask you and i know that because
you're a historian your bent is this way
but obviously it's got a lot of literary
fans who are going to be calling in but
help us as you answer their specific
questions to also understand the country
and this movement when you answer well
um town the city got published in 1950 i
recently wrote an introduction to it for
its 50th anniversary in a penguin
paperback british edition um and kind of
the city was very much modeled on his
great boyhood hero thomas wolfe the
great north carolina writer from
asheville who wrote you know so many
classic books like look homeward angel
and
and um you know you can't go home again
many others so it's a it's the story of
town the city takes place here where i'm
at right now lowell massachusetts and
also new york city and it's a marvelous
first book effort um he was called john
kerouac then not jack but he wanted to
tell further to maze the too many ways
the book was too similar to what thomas
wolf did nobody wants to be considered
the the follower you want to break new
grounds shatter
new um you know mole create new molds
for of writing for yourself and what did
happen and you touched on it i think
it's a couple things one is caroux
connected
with allen ginsberg and william burrows
and both of them had unusual views on
literature burrows with science fiction
and um the and um your certain
avant-garde european writing allen
ginsberg with the great epic bard-like
uh poetry which would become his classic
howl those were influences um cassidy he
was kind of looking for that sort of
character when i'm reading all of jack's
journals one of the things that struck
out
struck me a great deal is how he likes
to mythologize particularly male
american figures he talks in his
journals about babe ruth's feats both in
yankee stadium but also in bar rooms or
he liked zane grey pulp westerns you
know with with those sort of heroes and
mel uh melville had a big influence on
uh carouck and to his credit i think he
put the consumer marketplace away and
said i want to i want to be an artist i
want to write important american
literature and i want to find my
authentic voice and what is so important
to know about care whack is he found
that voice you can read him and you know
it's jack kerouac and he constantly
throughout his life fault with editors
whether it was using dashes instead of
periods whether it was having what he'd
call spontaneous prose whether
conflicts he had over and over again
there they've become legends with
editors trying to to in his mind screw
up his pure work um and so one of the
things i've learned with meyer writing
about carouck and thinking about him is
the courage he had not just to make a
buck at art or to become a paid writer
but to write out of his heart and um and
to be an inspired writer and the fact
that he achieved that is one of his
reasons for greatness let me bring
another voice into our conversation here
paul marion is right by me in the uh
jack kerouac park and he is a local
historian of lowell massachusetts lore
and history and
first of all let's start with this park
hi how did this park get built uh well
we're standing in what's called jack
kerouac park and this area is the jack
kerouac commemorative in 1988 this was
dedicated
it is part of the lowell public art
collection and the design was selected
as a result of a competition in 1987 and
it was designed by a sculptor from texas
named ben white tennant but how did the
idea come about well the idea came about
uh because
very soon after kerwig's death people in
law began saying ought to be a way to
sort of mark his contribution as an
american writer
at the time i was working
for the low historic preservation
commission which was a department of
interior agency and we were doing
cultural programs uh that were tied to
the development of the new national
historical park in lowell and so uh
being a writer being someone who knew
about kerouac i was in the right place
at the right time and we were able to
propose creating a memorial to kerouac
in a memorial that would be text based
and then we did a design competition and
so this uh inscription that we're
standing from is like others here which
all are parts of his work represented on
on granite exactly it's a sense it's a
portrait in language you notice there's
no figuration and one of the reasons we
wanted to do that was as doug mentioned
earlier uh kerouac was someone who uh in
a sense suffered from a kind of culture
personality complex uh that was applied
toward him and so we saw this
commemorative as a way to kind of act as
an antidote where we get people back to
concentrating on the writing which i
believe he would really have preferred
did everybody in lowell think this was a
good idea in other words what's this
city's relationship with jack kerouac
well it's been a mixed relationship over
the years uh one of the callers earlier
mentioned the town in the city which was
published in 1950
at that time lowell
welcomed kerouac back as a kind of
returning hero he did a
book signing in the department store on
the main street which is merrimack
street book was serialized in the lowell
sun newspaper
but then as he began to write the uh
sort of chronicles of the beat life some
of those works were
you know less familiar to the people who
were living lowell he was writing about
kind of avant-garde bohemian life and
those were not uh welcomed as as readily
as thomas city let me get to some more
calls cochran georgia next on the 1950s
beat generation
uh yes
thank you for putting me on uh i'm 22
years old and i'm a painter and
i wanted to sort of get a younger
person's perspective who have you know
just gotten into kerouac i've read on
the road i've read dharma bombs and i'm
in the middle of the subterraneans right
now
and i just wanted to sort of make a
comment that on the road in particular
is sort of
heart-wrenching in the fact that um
i see in that an america
that has a soul you know that has a
sort of purpose and a very beautiful
you know it's a beautiful soul and
but as i look now
in today's world um and as i prepared
you know like to move to new york and
all that
i look through the um the underground
and all that i see a sort of
frightening cultural impotence
um
of you know some of the riders some of
the the art forms that are going on now
and uh i guess my question is
do you see parallels in the world that
kerouac was riding in sort of like you
said against the mainstream against the
uh
sort of suburban values um
and today's world you know especially in
the post-9 11 uh terrorism scare
with um where we have seemed to have hit
a time warp and headed back to sort of
that post-world war to um american
identity and military and
that uh sort of thing or
american idealism
we understand thanks uh cochran georgia
doug brinkley is there anything similar
in today's culture
well um i think you find it in the music
world in rock and roll or in jazz more
than you do in literature because there
was a romanticism to kerouac's work and
dealing with kind of um he was always a
great fan of things there was a lot of
sentiment um suddenly due to i think our
age of cynicism we're in now the notion
of cinnamon and romanticism are
considered too much like hallmark cards
or something people the critics the art
critics don't like it we're supposed to
be much more jaded um and kerouac didn't
have shared that kind of jadedness he
was about joy and exuberance and
celebration and humanity and love and i
think those the people still have all of
those uh
those needs in their lives if you go
anywhere that love and enjoy or are big
parts of our lives and also you know
darkness and death which kerouac wrote
about a lot he was a great writer of the
of the mayor of the human um tragic
comic
um reality and that will always be i
think in in a ways but i think too often
now writers feel they have to be put
people down jack kerouac didn't put
people down he brought people up and
it's that reason why people read them
and they say gosh i love this because
it's it's optimistic it's hopeful um and
yet it's so intensely personal intensely
sad it's the autobiographical side of
kerouac but that influence i think comes
out more in memoirs today um than it
does in fiction i think kerouac's
influences on people writing these first
person narratives about their own lives
in many ways kerouac's entire body of
work was about himself and what he was
going through so i think you'll find it
in the proliferation of memoirs than
than you will and kerouac's influence on
fiction although he had a big influence
on ken keezy and one floor of the
cuckoo's nest and um thomas penshun and
gravity's rainbow and the like
paul marion
before we leave you i want to understand
a little bit more about lowell he was
born in the city in 1922.
what are the important things to know
about the culture that gave birth to him
well kerouac is a product of the
industrial multi-ethnic urban life that
was so familiar to
millions and millions of americans
and uh he was he was formed in in lowell
and this was his place this is where uh
he was brought up as a catholic this is
where you know he went to high school he
was a football star he was very much a
product of the american popular culture
one block away it was a movie house
where he spent a lot of times people
comment on the fact that his
writing is very cinematic uh kerouac
loves cartoons he loved comics he loved
sports he was a real american kid
and he went on he wrote about america he
was french-canadian how large was the
french-canadian community in this city
at the time that kerwick was growing up
lowell had a population of over 100 000
about 25 percent were franco-americans
uh his uh family had come down to lowell
from nashua new hampshire just up the
river uh his father was a printer and
he's working for a french language
newspaper uh and um
he
would french have been spoken in his
house yeah as a matter of fact he says
he didn't speak english until he started
going to school uh so he was very much a
bilingual uh creature he spoke french
all his life and in fact uh it shows up
in a lot of his books what is his given
name we call him jack yeah is jean dewey
kerouac so you really can see the french
uh john lewis
right and today what is the city like
today uh lowell is a
diverse community of more than 50
different ethnic groups it's a city that
has a revitalized economy uh we're the
site of a national park uh lowell
national historical park commemorates
the industrial revolution well let's see
how the low is the uh sort of first
significant plan industrial city and
that's what the park is about
i want to let people see your book
because you've worked on a history let's
let's show it to them so they've people
are interested in reading more it's
called the pop and underwood early
stories and other writings was published
in 1999 it's available in penguin
paperback now and i was interested by
the 22 year old caller because the
picture on the front is carouck at 21
years old all the writings in this book
are compositions that were done by
kerouac before he turned 22
it's a wonderful place for people to
start you know and see
kerouac as a peer
and another caller was asking what had
happened in the early 50s after town in
the city came out to change kerouac's
writings in a way he went back to what
he began writing there's a piece in here
called a play i want to write and he
says i'm going to wait for a spontaneous
burst of passion and rush to my
typewriter and write about life as life
is he was 18 years old when he said that
he already had his aesthetic nail down
and that's pretty much what he did for
the next 30 years
uh he was i think robbie crealey said
kerouac was a writer he wrote
on the panel over there
from an excerpt from lonesome traveler
there's an autobiographical piece and he
says uh always considered writing my
duty on in life heroic essentially was a
writer he reported on his own life and
you know he told us what it was like to
be an american in the uh 20th century
the mid-20th century well marian thanks
so much for helping us understand mr
kerouac and also this town appreciate
your time i'm going to walk over to the
c-span school bus and as i do let's
listen to our next phone call engelwood
california go ahead hi thank you for
taking my call my name is nicholas smith
and i'm the president and founder of
netflixonline.com
and i'm only 17 and i'm learning
different things about jack kerouac uh
just recently um i haven't read any of
his voice currently but i will be doing
so
thanks to c-span i know that he was a
beat movement or actually he led the
beat movement of the 50s
and i learned that uh he tailored this
to a young people maybe my age or 22 or
21 by the people's caller um my question
is this what was his impact on young
people throughout the country or
throughout his uh uh territory and how
did they take to his
philosophy um thank you very much
all right thanks very much douglas
sprinkly how did young people respond to
the beat movement in general in the
1950s well kerouac kind of launched the
uh i think it was william burrows said
the levi revolution now the wearing of
blue jeans and the idea that i'm going
to put on a backpack and a rucksack in
hitchhike across the country he's seen
in some ways as a father of if you like
the counterculture there's a great uh
direct connection this notion of roaming
america a sense of freedom of
existential joy of
marijuana
of listening to having music is this
integral part of your life of kind of
celebrating a moving bohemianism if
you'd like
joyce johnson once wrote um something to
the effect that kerouac thought a home
could be
set up like a like pitching a tent um i
mean there was a great rootlessness in
carolina homelessness and you see that
in the 60s with a lot of the kind of
wanderings and it's a that that a whole
generation did so kerouac if you're just
studying him forget the character's
great literary spokesperson for the beat
generation and an incredible novelist
and poet his uh influence on our society
is immense it became the bible of the
counterculture the book on the road and
so did the subterraneans and dharma bums
and many of his other works
and um so he he's always talked about
when you write read histories textbooks
about the 50s and 60s you won't find one
without the name jack kerouac there well
that's a good segue into what we want to
do next which is listen to his voice
again
reading some of the text of on the road
this is jack kerouac in his own words
when you see me next i'll be with doug
brinkley on the bus
when dean and i went over to talk to him
we invited him out to the car in the car
he suddenly yelled yeah
ain't nothing i like better than good
kicks
where did we go
dean jumping up and down the seat and
giggling maniacally later later said
freddie i'll get my boy to drive us down
the
jackson's nook i got to sing man i live
to sing been singing close your eyes for
months i don't want to say nothing else
what you two boys up to
we told them we're going to new york
tomorrow
lord ain't never been there and they
tell me it's a real jumping tom
but i ain't got no cause complaining
where i am i'm married you know oh yes
said dean lighting up
and where is the little darling tonight
and i bet she's got lots of nice friends
man what do you mean said freddie
looking at him half smiling out of the
corner i told you i was married to her
didn't i
oh yes oh yes bless dean
doug brinkley you just talked about
marijuana how talk a little bit about
the
drug
sex
uh alcohol how much apart music how much
apart were all of those things
and the kind of life that these writers
and artists fermented
um it was very important uh at different
times and in different degrees for
different ones of course william
burroughs probably most well known for
naked lunch uh and talked to burroughs
used to have a thing called the algebra
of need and he was dealing with the idea
of what it meant to be a junkie and he
would come up with the concept that that
all of us tend to be junkies of some
sort somebody might be addicted to
heroin but somebody on wall street might
be addicted to the stock market and
somebody in hollywood may be addicted to
the television camera and that um this
is this his concept of an algebra need
and naked lunch was an incredibly
important book um alan ginsberg did all
sorts of experiments with drugs looking
with dealing with lsd for a period of
time peyote
he shied away from alcoholism later in
his life due to buddhism and was
essentially drug free i think except for
smoking a little bit of weed jack
kerouac had a period of time when he
wrote a lot using benzedrine or speed
and of course neil cassidy one of the
whose name keeps coming up who he's dean
moriarty and on the road he later
becomes the bus driver for ken kesey and
the merry pranksters which tom wolf made
famous an electric kool-aid acid test
and cassidy was a bit of a speed freak
and this is part of the aspect that made
the mainstream american culture so
allergic to burrows in kerouac and
ginsburg drugs coming into the
mainstream drugs being part of college
campuses
and particularly they were looking for
new highs with drugs places to go uh
aldous huxley wrote the famous book
doors of perception where the doors got
their their their name and it was this
this notion that you could find a higher
being through experimenting with drugs
and it permeates many of their works not
all of kerouac works many of his works
are non-drug related like maggie cassidy
about growing up here in lowell or town
in the city and many others north
andover massachusetts you are on our
american writers discussion of jack
kerouac well good afternoon and susan i
hope you're enjoying this beautiful new
england spring day
and thanks so much for pinch-hitting
i heard about that story
mr brinkley i wondered
we had a wonderful program in the end of
april
and we had a tour of
four different towns in the merrimack
valley
with the basis being the four poets and
bradstreet robert frost john greenleaf
whittier and jack kerouac
now many people don't even really know
much about his poetry
i wonder do you feel
his entire body of work could be called
a prose poem with the way it flows
and the beauty of the way he melds
the love of music
with the love of writing and just the
world in general
that's a wonderful question generally i
would say yes i think you could say it's
up it's it's it's really a hymn
to being alive and being alive in
america or prose poetry but i would
recommend for people if they wanted to
look at carrock as poet which is an
underappreciated aspect of him an
incredible book um that came out called
mexico city blues published by grove
press there have been other ones but
mexico city blues kerouac had 242 jazz
courses and you can see the influence of
buddhism in the book but also of of his
struggles with kind of an aesthetic
christianity and it is really i think
one of the most underappreciated books
of of post-war american poetry so if
anybody listening watching this program
uh take a look at mexico city blues
cairock also of course loved writing
haikus and there are many of them and
regina weinrich is about to bring out a
book of um caroux haikus a collection of
them and some of them are great fun and
he always encouraged kerouac people to
um to write them and one last point
kerouac in his later years became much
more conservative in fact he became a
admirer of william buckley in a in the
national review he was um i went out
home for the vietnam war but he
certainly was behind the soldiers in
vietnam but he became a great lover of
robert frost poetry and towards the end
of his life in one of his journal
entries i've read he said i just want to
be considered like robert frost a great
new england poet uh somebody who really
cared about nature and people and um in
his admiration for frost is an aspect i
think of carol acts
a legacy or life that i think sometimes
is missed you suggested his politics
became more conservative at the end of
his life was he a political person
earlier on no
the beat generation of jack kerouac is
about art not about politics and i think
it's a mistake to sometimes look at what
our jack kerouac's politics
because sometimes he would say things in
a burst of outrageousness um the same
way many writers or artists do
it is true however that he at times
seemed to take to a conservative bent i
once did a piece uh wrote a piece for
the new york times on writers during the
vietnam period that that had a lot of
stake in america that refused to be
anti-american during the 60s the allen
ginsberg became a great anti-war
activist but writers like john steinbeck
was for the vietnam war john dos pasos
james t farrell ralph ellison kerouac
was part of that group and a lot of it
you can find the answer why he was that
way as here at lowell he came back to
this working class town and he wasn't
going to denounce vietnam war because
friends of his kids were fighting over
there in the rice paddies and losing a
limb or dying and i think kerouac did
not want to come out denouncing
these young americans that were
defending
you know his country oh we're talking
about lowell let's show you that map
again that gives you some perspective if
you were to land at logan airport today
how long would it take you to get here
oh it's about an hour i would say you
can get here although with the
construction going around around logan
an hour could become two hours quickly
and it is and it used to be an
industrial city now um very much also
industrial but the high-tech influences
are around here and not very far from
the new hampshire border uh this city
new york city and san francisco the
three main places that he spent his life
yes um and and other places um but of
course lol is the center of jack kerouac
it's what he loved i would divide his
all of his work into two basic
categories books about lol
and books are really about the beat
generation and for the beat generation
itself was it mostly a new york based
movement um new york san francisco in
particular where city lights books is in
this gravitation to the west coast but
there are other beat cities if you like
new orleans being one of them and on the
road kerouac journeys to new orleans to
meet william burroughs who's living in
algiers across the mississippi river and
kerouac takes the ferry over and spends
time there but even though there were
just cities the pervasiveness was felt
across the country as they've suggested
because of the rise of television
absolutely and the in the automobile
which made taking off and as a freedom
mechanism using your car to go anywhere
you wanted at any moment and the
easiness of hitchhiking back then too
westminster california you're next on
this conversation on the 50s
hello go ahead
hello it's very nice to talk to you
i thought perhaps maybe after the show
you could get in touch with me and i'll
give you some information about a party
i attended
many years ago that was given in honor
of jack kerouac
i was given by bill dana who he was very
good friends with who was a comedian who
did
my name jose jimenez who was from lowell
massachusetts and he was also very good
friends with kennedy and i think there
might be some connection
with why he was
for the vietnam war
and if you're interested in knowing the
nature of the party you might want to
use
some of that information in your book
and you can verify this with mr dana
who's living in maui hawaii
well please leave us your number with
when you don't get off the phone without
it and i'll get uh give you a ring i
just add that the other famous person
from lowell is the great painter
whistler on this house here is an art
museum and it's one of the other great
artists from lowell
let's listen to a call from a town you
know well new orleans go ahead
hi i've been waiting months for this
particular show to come on i had notes
all over my place reminding me um i just
finished reading an article that you
wrote mr brinkley for rolling stone and
in the article um you book you debunked
the legend about
how he had written uh on the road in a
burst of uh of energy in a very short
period of time i understand that you
have really unprecedented access from
the carawaka estate
with his journals and diaries i was
wondering if you could give me just a or
give us just a short example
of one of the other types of legends or
myths around caraway thanks very much
well thanks for the question before you
answer the specific question tell our
audience the story of how you got access
to this material um well i became i did
a program my publishers viking press
which was the same one was jack kerouac
and i did a program on the charlie rose
show with charles kuralt before he died
and krult and i were talking about the
american road uh andrei kradersky was on
it also and uh some of the people the
sampus family i saw that show and
sterling lord jack kerouac's longtime
agent saw it and the people at viking
knew i had a great interest in carouck
because i wrote a book called the magic
bus
and that has a connection to c-span um
buses and which is a whole different
story but the magic bus was sort of
kerouac inspired in the sense of getting
young people out of the college
classroom and going to see america we
weren't looking for kicks but we were
looking to study american history and
literature
on the road with that book so
opportunity came because stella sampus
had died and john sampus will be with us
later today became the executive of the
estate to um turn over
if you'd like letters and journals
unpublished material of caroux which is
now all located at the new york public
library
in new york where bulk of my research
for my biography has to take place and
um it was
it allows this biography that i'm
working on to be different than the
other ones because of looking at at
exactly what kerouac was thinking on a
regular basis he started keeping a
journal loosely at age 14
and kept it all the way up until his
death at age 47 in 1969. of course
there's whole periods where he's not
writing in them but they're quite
extensive and it allows us to see a new
side of kerouac later on in the program
you're going to meet john sampus who is
the
executor curator of the estate of jack
kerouac but the caller specific question
was another story that dispels a myth
boy there are many of them um i think
the big the biggest one which comes up
over and over well i
i don't know if they dispel them at
quite what he's talking about is peace
and rolling stone on on the road just
being written in three weeks and uh you
know ben's a dream coffee frenzy or or
what what have you while that happened
he had drafts and plot lines and things
long before i think the
the in his journals the constant
catholicism that even when he's going
through his buddhism is never leaves him
he's constantly drawing crucifixes and
writing
prayers and psalms and talking directly
to god and i think at the end of his
life the thought of jack kerouac as a
religious writer sometimes might
surprise people and particularly the way
that catholicism both the guilt that
catholicism gave him but also the the
great inspiration he found in the
catholic church and in the spiritual um
if you like this aspects of saints
kerouac kind of felt that as you read
the journals that he was very fascinated
with catholic saints but he thought he
can make saints out of people i think so
if you find a homeless person instead of
looking them oh there's a homeless
person walking by jack kerouac would
talk to that person and say there's a
soul there and god loves that person and
not i'm not going to treat them as just
a homeless person but i might give them
heroic qualities because they're heroic
for being human and trying to struggle
and survive in many ways it's like
william kennedy's pulitzer prize winning
book iron weed
if any of you are familiar with that but
um
i think that's the mo the thing that
surprises me the most how god infuses
kerouac's thinking constantly greenwich
village in new york city an important
locus for the beat generation we're
going to show you a little bit of what
greenwich village looks like today along
with times square and columbia
university the alma mater of jack
kerouac as we listen to our next call it
is from prescott arkansas
go ahead
uh doug uh i'd just like you to
to
to comment on
the far reaching juxtaposition you have
in your career
all right thank you so we're going to
let you go for future callers put that
mute button on when you get on the air
so we don't have the feedback and just
uh why how did you get interested in
this really i run an american studies
program called the eisenhower center for
american studies and when you do
american studies you look at american
life decade by decade so when i look at
the 1950s i look at a lot of things
which by training i did diplomatic
history and i've written on dean
atchison in the 1950s john foster dulles
khrushchev eisenhower the cold war but
also i want to look at the 50s i wrote a
book on rosa parks who in 1955
was you know the seminal civil rights
figure in the montgomery bus boycott
where jack kerouac whose book on the
road had a had a great impact
unfortunately sometimes in the academy
people want to pigeonhole you have to
only do it things you know if you're a
foreign policy person you only think
about foreign policy i like to be more
holistic in a sense the way david
halverstein wrote his book the 50s book
i admire a great deal it's a great read
that people really want to know about it
and good context for this conversation
today because it spends a chapter each
on some of the places and things you
talked about television levittown and
other trends in the
period by the way doug brinkley uh
talked a little bit about the c-span
school bus and i have to tell you the
story it's good to have him on board
because he is in some ways the father of
the traveling c-span school buses it was
his teaching aboard what he called the
magic bus that led us to get the idea to
put two school buses on the road and now
we've learned that really the
grandfather of the c-span school buses
is jack kerouac so for anybody who
thinks this network is stayed and boring
our
roots are jack kerouac let's go to our
next cell phone call stormville new york
uh thank you mr brinker for taking my
call jack carrock obviously had very
intense relationships with men in his
life uh alan ginsberg for example
gregory corso what was it about kerouac
that that drew him so closely to his
mother throughout his life at the at the
risk of losing his daughter jan and and
joan haverty and many other women in his
life just what was that compelling thing
that kept him to his mother
um well
that's a good question um his father leo
died and he had terrible he was
with a stomach you know cancer problem
um and throwing up in a in ozone park in
queens and young you know jack kerouac
was there now he's trying to be a writer
and his father said i got one if you
like death bed wish take care of your
mother no matter what you must take care
of your mother and kerouac who felt that
was a sacred obligation for his family
that no matter what he would have to
take care of his mother on gabrielle and
he did and in some ways at considerable
cost
after he became famous he retreated with
her lived with her he died with her in
the same you know home in st petersburg
florida but i think i used to think it
was stranger that here's this big writer
traveling around now holding up with his
mother but i think he took that uh to
his credit that obligation seriously and
it was just that the 60s were going on
all these counterculture figures were
saying come on jack get out of the house
your mother's keeping you hemmed in and
i think he felt that he he needed that
uh it's a very unusual mother-son
relationship that the two of them have
and i think it's an um but one of honor
on jack kerouac's part and obviously he
loved his mother and they had a very
funny relationship which included
drinking together watching tv together
and also sometimes shouting insults at
each other
next telephone call is boulder colorado
and we'll look at times square in new
york city with the beat generation
connection over the call boulder go
ahead
thank you for taking my call my name is
amiel alkalai and i'm a writer and i'm
just visiting the jack kerouac school of
disembodied poetics in boulder colorado
and i found it very moving to turn on
c-span and see this wonderful tribute to
kerouac who's always been a writer of
mine
uh and i wanted to ask something that
relates to my experience of carol act
which was i grew up in an artistic
household and i began reading him maybe
around the age of 13. but throughout
most of my life most of carol x books
out of print and i don't think a lot of
the younger people listening or watching
will will know that
and i know it's a cliche but we seem to
like our writers more dead than alive
so i'd like to ask doug brinkley
to what he attributes the great kerouac
revival to
well that's an interesting question of
course as i said by 69 as he gained
weight jack kerrick died in 1969 he had
gained
47 and he had gained weight he'd become
more conservative he was living with his
mother in many ways his last home here
in lowell looked like a typical suburban
house he lived in st petersburg florida
in a very suburban house it was not the
sort of wild manic energy that people
would would imagine
and the 60s think about 69 what was
going on and all the big fights over
vietnam and coming up in 70 would be
kent state and cairo waxor was out of
the cultural um you know
vortex if you like at that period of
time i think the young people
rediscovered him in the 80s during the
reagan period when i think the reagan
administration seemed to have a
different kind of view of what america
was about and a patriotism and a turning
away from the 60s and as our young
caller from georgia had discovered
kerouac recently i think there's a
feeling of i want more out of america
what about the poetic spiritual america
i'm not seeing the soul or the caring of
poor people during the reagan period i'm
not making a judgment about reagan
administration i and myself but i'm just
saying i think that was what the the the
feeling was so by the the late 80s and
early 90s there became a kerouac revival
to the point now where his name is
virtually everywhere there's a volvo tv
commercial about jack kerwig there's a
gap at selling khakis using jack kerouac
and he's hit the point where he's almost
a mainstream figure but particularly on
college campuses i re-read in
preparation for this parts of on the
road
just to get myself back in the feel of
it and i was struck by this sort of
feeling carawak has which a lot of
younger viewers right now might have
when you're just about leaving college
and it's this time of year in june well
there's a scene there what do i do next
do i take more courses do i leave campus
maybe i'll take a year off maybe i'll go
to europe it's that funny period of 21
let's say 22 and i think caroline
perfectly hits those people in a way of
an excitement about being 21-22 and the
possibilities that await you and unlike
another coming-of-age book like catcher
in the rye by j.d salinger which was all
about the phonies and this much much
more there's a greater cynicism in
salinger so i think kerouac will be
discovered by each generation anew you
know while we were getting ready for
this a young woman walked up in to this
park and left a note to jack kerouac and
we'll uh hear later from
his relative
relatives who take care of his grave
which is here in lowell that people come
by and leave little tributes to him this
woman says she was 17. so i won
17 and there's a woman here that gave
this was uh put on the gravesite jack
kerouac wrote a book called book of
dreams and it got
published in i believe 61. so is this
the reaching across the generations of
his work absolutely that people young
people feel the need to
lead tribute they leave tributes at his
gravesite it could be guitar picks a
wine bottle um
all sorts of items because the people
when they discover his work and they he
inspires them to such a degree they want
to kind of express what kerouac means to
their lives there's a mysticism a
mystical aspect to kerouac and that was
conscious on his part i believe
because i mentioned the saints and this
sort of everything holy i one of the
great things i learned by all these beat
writers is anybody can make paris
special you and i can go to paris and my
gosh it's but but ginsburg and kerala
would say we can make topeka holy or lol
holy meaning that you can find this sort
of beautiful essence in any town it
doesn't have to be just the the flashy
place of the moment got a caller next
from new york city you're on the air
welcome
yes uh my question was about
jack kerouac and alan ginsberg
the the vietnam issue and later on in
kerouac's life was there um i seem to
remember reading that there was some
sort of resentment from the other beat
writers could you comment on that
well
after jack kerouac got very famous and
became a celebrity in all the the
horrible
context that that means to be a
celebrity in american culture he turned
alcohol more and more and became a bit
more reclusive and stayed with his
mother as i commented on and became a
little more reactionary more right
wingish if you like or more that's not
the right term more he became a bit of a
nativist
about america and of course that was not
alan ginsberg's
bag at all ginsburg was a progressive on
the cutting edge of the environmental
movement on on women's rights gay rights
so you can see them kind of pulling
apart yet they
ginsburg always to his credit gave jack
kerouac
so much credit for what he did alan
ginsberg loved jack kerouac promoted his
works i don't think he would have had
all of these books in print today if
ginsburg didn't constantly up until his
death recently promote that jack kerouac
is a great american writer nothing would
make allen ginsburg happier than to see
c-span doing a program on jack kerouac
and
alan was a great teacher of young people
and a great a great person and he's
sorely missed by so many but um the i
think that that relationship is a very
very important one they are the core of
what's known as the beat generation but
but as kerouac gone on he didn't want to
be seen ghettoized as part of the beats
he'd say give it what i viewed as beats
as the spiritual move in the 50s and the
60s has turned into political nonsense
and he very clearly in his diaries makes
it clear i want to be viewed as an
american writer on my own i don't want
to be ghettoized as a beat writer i want
to be seen as like john steinbeck or um
as william styron who he admired i want
to be viewed on my own merits not put
into this sort of um group but yet so
many of his novels are about the beat
generation it was it's a kind of a hard
to separate the two i want you to give
some thought to this and we'll come back
to to ask to have you answer it
think of expressions that are
commonplace american expressions that
were given birth to during the beat
generation okay like beat and beat nicks
and the like i'm sure there are others
you'll think of now you have heard the
music earlier on of david amram let me
introduce you to him next he's out in
the jack kerouac park in lowell
massachusetts and our goal david airman
as you know is to understand this period
in american history so looking back on
it through the lens of 40 50 years why
do you think it's important to study
the reason it's important to study
the history
of
america through the writings of jack
kerouac is because he was our reporter
jack was a reporter for a whole era
after the post-world war ii euphoria and
the energy
he wanted to see that all of those good
feelings that took place
in the actor's studio with a new way of
doing theater
the painters who were celebrating like
jackson pollock american indian sand
painting our interest in native american
music 50 years ago
when he went to morocco our interest in
what they now call multiculturalism
when we got together
and we played music together and did the
first ever jazz poetry readings in new
york we were celebrating the commonality
of all the world being in america and
the beauties of the european classics
and the beauties of all the cultures
that surrounded us right here in the
united states that were overlooked by
the artistic establishment so jack was a
reporter and a historian
for a whole way of thinking that wasn't
about any beat generation because when
we met in 1956 there was no such term
really except among a handful of people
it was about america itself and that
part of america that had no voice and
jack kerouac was our voice and in the
year 2002 he's everyone's voice let's
take some calls again next is san jose
california
yes um douglas i just had a couple brief
questions um my name is john cassidy and
uh as you probably know my father was a
good friend of jax
and uh jack would come and visit us my
only memories of him i was so young that
he'd read his stories and stuff me and
my two sisters here in los gatos at the
house
that
he came to visit often when he was on
the west coast later and
my question was i came in late uh in the
program here i wondered um you're
writing a a biography of them and when
is that coming out or has that already
been uh published
mr cassidy before you go so our audience
understands it was your father who took
the road trips with jack kerouac
dean moriarty and uh you know later uh
cody pomeray and all that
and uh
jack would come and visit us um we had a
house in san jose in the uh 50s uh neil
was transferred from the southern
pacific railroad from san francisco down
to san jose
so we moved down here i was like two
years old and then uh they got a house
in los gatos which was out toward the
coast a little more and jackie visited
us even more then
whenever he would come through like
when he wrote the book big sir in 1960
he um he's he came through there and we
followed him down to throwing daddy's
cabin
in 1960. i'm called timmy in that book
and uh it's kind of funny to read about
yourself but the uh the other pretty
funny story about my name was that uh
neil originally named me jack allen
cassidy and alan for ginsburg and it was
for his two best pals right
and at the last minute he changed it to
john and
this was like in the delivery room my
mother saw well whatever but she asked
him later why she changed it from jack
to john and he said well
if you say it too fast it sounds like
jackassedy and we don't want our son
being called a jacket i thought that was
a pretty funny story because
people have come up to me and said well
the whole beat generation is kind of
embodied in your name with those three
names you know
so when he changed it to john it kind of
that's what's on my birth certificate so
i can't argue with him you know what i
mean
anyway thanks how interesting
it was very interesting to get your
phone call thank you for participating
and giving us some personal experience
as well doug brinkley oh it's great
having you call in john thank you so
much and i'm working on a biography
which will be out here in a couple of
years and i'm editing the journals of
jack kerouac on the road journals for
viking press and of course neil
cassidy's obviously really the other
main figure in my biography and also in
in jack's journals
but just let's say something about neil
cassidy for a second uh you know he did
a book his own book called the first
third the first third you can get from
city lights books in san francisco but
cassidy was an incredible inspiration he
was the not only the the person that
really gave kerouac his breakthrough
character and what i personally consider
kerouac's two best books on the road and
visions of cody cody both
the the stars of those two books are
neil cassidy
next i mentioned um ken kesey will kee
the famous further bust of ken keezy in
the 60s when he went to unsettle america
after writing a sometimes great notion
and one for the cuckoo's nest the driver
of the bus was neil cassidy throughout
the 1960s and he's really one of the key
people in tom wolf's electric cooled
acid test then the secret hero of allen
ginsberg's howl is neil cassidy so um
well well cassie didn't produce the
literature that a burroughs or ginsburg
or kerouac did he really was one of
their great inspirations and that's
because he could talk kind of in a
non-stop brilliant fashion he
represented the west as kerouac said
with his gene autry sideburns and he was
comfortable in the pool rooms of denver
and in the um and in the uh rail yards
of uh the bay area where john's uh lives
so um it's
cassie is just a fascinating american
character and of course the grateful
dead has a song called cassidy which is
one of their more popular ones as a
tribute to him and a factoid that i read
confirmed this if you will is that jack
kerouac didn't like automobiles himself
and that it was actually mr cassidy who
did most of the driving right i would
say he didn't like automobiles as much
as he didn't drive um yeah he was he was
not the behind the wheel man which is
again how everybody thinks kerouac is
doing this manic driving and as david
amram so
um beautifully said he was a great
recorder jack he was a great observer
and wrote so often about other peoples
and then put it through his own uh
particular lens david amram would you uh
get ready to play for us again after
this next call i'm going to have you
play a little bit more as we listen to
some more of jack kerouac's writing but
let's listen but i
could i also mention that i have a book
out i i know offbeat collaborating with
kirowak because i knew him and was his
first collaborator we know that show it
to the audience also also carolyn
cassidy who also knew jack has an
extraordinary book out
called
off the road and i wanted to mention
that to the readers because i think
primary sources as i learned as a
history major are almost the best way
to study people and it's wonderful to
see spanish approaching jack as a great
american writer and as someone who
deserves to be appreciated on his own
terms along with steinbeck at falco and
walt whitman and dostoyevsky and other
non-american giants of literature
[Music]
this is the song jack and i wrote
together in 1959 with neil cassidy and
allen called told my daisy i'll pull my
daisy tip my cup
all my doors are open
i play for coconuts
all my eggs are broken
hop my hearts on heart my lights
serums hope is steady
hip my angel heart my light
lay it on the needy
hop
[Music]
[Music]
and it goes on and on in an improvised
style but when we did that
as a piece of music
it was improvised but i just completed a
concerto for james galway which the
uh louisiana philharmonic's premiering
this september 14th
and giants of the night has a second
movement dedicated to jack kerouac using
old french canadian folk songs he sang
me 50 years ago which are in the piece
so jack like myself was a classicist who
loved jazz and an improviser who was
also a formalist
[Music]
well if we're going to give it an
example of what they used to call back
then spontaneous pros
well if jack were here in lowell park
today he'd say that he finally knows
that c-span and america caught up with
him and sometimes it takes 50 years but
that's the way life goes because you can
make it up on the spot like i'm doing
now
and eventually somehow
you'll end up with doug brinkley on your
side taking you on a true america
historical ride so for c-span all of us
who knew him then say thank you c-span
in america i'm in big heart the beauty
of spontaneity thank you too
and let's listen to our next telephone
call from dallas texas
hello
um
i i had to kid with you with a little
bit and i don't mean to be the devil's
advocate i went to school in lowell so i
know the area yeah
it's not paris by any stretch of the
imagination and your
your individual who is with you is
correct um
i'm not going to hide where i stand
i'm far right wing and
i've never read kerouac i guess
i look at it and sir you can help me
with this
i don't understand when i look at it and
never having read it and ignorance is
bliss sorry in that in that point but
how do i um
come to the point where i understand uh
kerouac to be
helping of like productivity and just
things in in our society i and and you
know him better than i and the other
question i had was who were um kearwax
um critics or
contemporaries who were on the far other
side that didn't want to be on the road
didn't want to do drugs who who are you
know what i mean like who were his
contemporaries who who answered him and
said no you're often left in the left
field and this is you know let's let's
go back to work and do whatever and i'll
listen thank you
good questions appreciate it well
read on the road and realize that it's a
beautiful prose poem to america and it's
if you want to read something that
celebrates pi alamo and montana and
cowboys and
the the great trains that used to
crisscross our country if you have any
sense of of love of america reading on
the road is it's a classic book that
celebrates it people from all the world
come to discover america through reading
jack kerouac the problem and and i would
also say if you are of a more
conservative bent and that kind of
crisscrossing the country without a end
of commerce is i think you were you put
it read something like maggie cassidy by
jack kerouac about his girlfriend here
in lowell it's a beautiful
straightforward novel to read about
growing up in a main street american
town
i can't talk about them as much as
somebody has to read jack kerouac that's
hopefully the point of all of this
but i would say that kerouac maybe
shared more values than you thought he
never put people down he had empathy for
everybody so you could read a jack
kerouac poem where he looks at a wall
streeter in a suit with a briefcase
walking across the brooklyn bridge and
that person falls and slips and carrots
the eye the reporter seeing that fall
he's not making fun of that business
person he's seeing the humanity and how
even that person with money and power
gets embarrassed and has to be human
like all of us and i think if you
approach him in that way that he's
somebody um that's not pointing fingers
as much as celebrating life in america
and around the world
and then you'll you'll find a richer
jack kerouac than the i think i think
conservatives have missed the boat on
understanding at least kerouac's works
uh ginsburg was was attacking them all
the time
during vietnam and it was an anti-war
was a politician on the left kerouac was
not part of that you need to read his
books and see them see the celebratory
side of america um which are there it's
there to be found santa barbara
california
yes hi i'd like to ask
jack kerouac has
often been compared
to marcel proust he's been called the
great rememberer
and in visions of cody
uh that his his style
was different than on the road in that
he
apparently
used spontaneous prose he used sketching
and i what i'd like to know
is
did he in fact
not
rewrite
in other words he would just get behind
a typewriter and let his mind go
and and the first word was the best is
that the kind of way he wrote
that's an excellent question and the big
thing that caroline keeps talking about
spontaneity that's why david amram is
singing in the spontaneous fashion and
this notion of first thought best
thought meaning what comes to your mind
right now and you get it down is somehow
more real it's not artificial
but that's i think done a disservice for
kerouac and his editor malcolm cowley
viking press said jack always wanted to
people think his prose came out like
squeezing toothpaste just kind of came
out of him when truth when you study him
carefully you see what a word smithy was
what an incredible craftsperson what a
background he had not just in proust but
in james joyce who he cared about
greatly in all of melville's works he
had shakespeare memorized you know in a
fashion being a great remember he can
recite entire sonnets who he loves
shakespeare's sonnets
he was not afraid kerouac to use
everyday american life as a theme and as
paul marion said he'd bring in in his
prose the three stooges
you know the shadow from the radio
yankee baseball players or red sox
players anything that was out there in
american life kerouac was unafraid of
there's a poetry movement called the new
formalist to kind of do the same thing
yet they're considered a conservative
poetry movement but i mean kerouac would
would put all of that in there um but i
think
the
concept was look at those jazz players
when they're blowing their horn you're
not coming to hear charlie parker play
the exact thing in rote fashion every
night like you would with a pop song or
you would if you'd like with andy warhol
you know mass producing portraits what
you'd get with kerouac
it would say when i hear parker play one
night he may be mellow so it'll be this
mellow sound out of his horn the next
mighty might be ecstatic and it's an
ecstatic sound and he was hoping in his
prose to have something that seemed
fresh and authentic that does not mean
he didn't constantly edit that does not
mean that he wasn't somebody who worked
great deal on his craftsmanship and it's
a great bit of kerala mythology that he
sort of scribbled on cocktail napkins
and and and notebooks and then went to
publish it there was an incredible
amount of work done to to produce his
his um 30 books that are in print today
this uh american writers series is
working its way through the 20th century
through the works of american writers
who either chronicled the time in which
they live or helped to affect it i think
jack kerouac would probably fall in both
of those categories to understand the
50s a little bit better we're going to
listen again to david amram's music and
look at some of the statistics of our
country in the 1950s
[Music]
hmm
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Music]
oh
[Applause]
um
[Music]
[Music]
boom
food
[Music]
up
[Music]
[Music]
music by david amram and the jack
kerouac park in lowell massachusetts
c-span is on the road today to learn
about the 1950s america through our
american writers series with jack
kerouac and the beat generation altamont
new york you're next go ahead how you
doing
uh doing well what's your question in
the 60s growing up my grandmother said
that jack was a distant cousin
and i never knew how much truth of it
was and i've got a picture hanging in my
den here it's uh
at right outside greenwich village
kettle of fish
at the time of mcdonald's street on the
evening of october 15 1958 just before
his publication of the party for durian
thumbs
blues
and uh
you know
i'm from new england and i moved to new
york
and
growing up i
they always said you know
my grandmother's maiden name was caravax
she married bushy
and uh my mother's maiden name was bushy
and then she married my dad which is
burst brch but it's interesting because
i've just took an interest in
of jack and i've got books of his and
i try to trace everything and we kind of
you know it's just interesting
thanks very much and for a biographer
and with someone who's so contemporary
you're probably finding kerouac
connections all over the place oh gosh
if you find a nickel for everybody who
drank a beer with jack kerouac
and probably
more challenging than some of the the
subjects you've done in the past it does
and i just would add that kirwack was
very interested in his ancestry both
from the the french canadian ancestry
but also over from brittany and it's a
nice little book one of the last ones he
wrote called satori in paris where he
went and made a journey over to france
to try to find um the the history of the
name kerouac and its roots and the you
know his interest in the his celtic
origins and the likes so uh um good luck
in trying to um track down the family
connection san francisco you are on our
program what's your question hi thanks
for having me this is a great series
um
i had two quick questions about the
relationships that he had one was
actually within the novel and on the
road at the end of the novel um
it ends with
jack carrocks with a his girlfriend and
another couple i think they're on the
way to a broadway play
and um
the character of dean marty kind of
comes out from the night and it ends
with him going off into the night sort
of this lonely figure
going into the darkness of the night and
i just wanted to know what was what was
it meant or what kerala may have meant
by that dean is going off by himself and
someone in his party kind of comments
that he is this sort of lonely figure
and i just wanted to know what your
thoughts were kind of reminded me of
joyce's character stephen dallas who
also goes off into the darkness of the
night alone
and what um
kerouac may have felt or may have
been his connection with that character
just going off by himself
and they kind of part ways
and also i read
doug
well his um alter ego of course kerouac
is um you know sal paradise is the name
who represents kerouac in the novel on
the road but you're absolutely right
jack kerouac is a poet of of of lostness
of loneliness um that allen ginsberg
once said we're all just hairy bags of
water meaning or but people are just
hair on them and there's fluids in us
and at the end there's the soul and also
we come into the world born alone and we
die alone and that's just sort of a
reality there are many people in
literature who play on those things but
kerala felt it very much the sense of
after all these exciting adventures we
have in the end somebody may die in a
hospital by themselves with some nurse
holding their hands or we might be dead
in a moment in an automobile accident or
something and just how fragile life is
and that at all these moments of great
exuberance and joy sometimes we then end
up with the loneliness and the sense of
despair and that's a great part of his
his work so
to understand kerouac it's a celebration
of life but also of death and that the
ultimate demise of all of us is death
hence his interest in religion so much
and looking for how some way to
transcend on the the shackles of earthly
earthly reality in a way and a spiritual
quest and uh
that's what turns people on to jack is
he's constantly looking for
spiritual highs for moments which he
would call it you know those great
moments when somehow you feel something
whether it's looking in the sky or in
nature and uh in the book dharma bombs
is about you know kind of zen moments or
hiking with the poet gary snyder who's
um jeffrey ryder in the novel looking
for these great epiphanies and great
moments while we're here on earth for
those who are joining us in progress
here douglas brinkley is with us a
historian of american culture especially
and it seems focusing a lot on the 20th
century and he's working on a
multi-volume biography and also editing
the papers of jack kerouac over the next
few years there's a big centennial
coming up an anniversary coming up
will be the 50th anniversary of the
publication of on the road in 2007 um
and of course the new york public
library now that they've acquired all of
kerouac's papers and then the most
famous thing occurred recently was that
christie's auction house when on the
road kerouac had typed it all out and
it's called in the scroll of on the road
where he did continually typing on this
tracing paper and had it all together
and that scroll um has went up for
auction i think was 2.4 million i was
there that day uh jim irsay who owns the
indianapolis colts football team
purchased it and uh it's one of the
really important and uh literary
artifacts and people love to look at it
kerouac put all the real names of real
people in that so if you look at you'll
see in al ginsberger neil cassidy
and then later publishers lawyers made
him change those names so not to have
legal suits you know and so he changed
them in the book but it's fascinating to
look at that as a primary source the the
so-called scroll were you
at all surprised at the price that that
manuscript went from it was the highest
i believe at least
ever paid for a literary manuscript for
20 20 i think it's about 2.4 million no
i'm not surprised because it's unique i
mean most writers of course today
turning your manuscript off a word
processor and here it is here's the disc
there's something about this that you
can really feel the the rhythms of
kerouac's typing he was a great typist
and that became a criticism truman
capote instead of character you're not
writing you're that's just typing on the
other hand it's a great art one of the
reasons he could do that spontaneous um
prose sometimes was because he could go
so quickly with the keys and there so
it's it's a it's a i wasn't too
surprised but i think jim irsay would
have paid as he told me when he bought
it he would have paid a lot more for it
i think it could have he would have gone
up further what's he going to do with it
um for time being it's repairing it and
it has you know some tears in and things
so he's making sure he does the right
thing on getting it so it can last for
the ages will the public see it
eventually it will be and he's dealing
with the university of indiana
bloomington and also new york public
library to try to make sure that it gets
seen by the public in time for that 50th
anniversary covington louisiana go ahead
hi this is patricia thompson from
louisiana i had a question about
what jack kerouac thought about another
massachusetts writer henry thoreau if we
know
well kerouac used to say about the the
so-called beats in san francisco north
beach area i mean we're all we were a
group of urban throws
meaning the very notion of some you know
thoreau's great maximum simplicity
simplicity simplicity to live a simple
life to you don't have to have material
belongings to find happiness that uh
influenced jack kerouaco a lot and not
just his time of solitude that he spent
at walden's pond thoreau and also it's
very much like kerouac's times of
solitude and um you know when he was um
going up into the pacific northwest and
working as a fire lookout person in the
cascade mountains that sense of
isolating herself in nature meant a
great deal to kerouac and i think
there's a great connection a sort of a
straight shot between throwing and
kerouac in the spiritual and the sense
of appreciation of nature a few weeks
ago we were in
california john steinbeck center to
learn about his book travels with
charlie someone in the same tradition
what would you say would be the
differences between the kind of america
steinbeck captured in his traveling
novel and the one we're talking about
today
well in jack kerouac it was true
ruthlessness of wandering um you know
hitchhiking not knowing where you're
going to sleep putting up a little pup
tent on the side of the road or in a
ditch interacting with hobos and the
like and travels with charlie by john
steinbeck and i have to say steinbeck's
my favorite american writer i just love
all of steinbeck's works and grapes of
wrath in particular but um i think that
um he was in that case having sort of a
bringing his poodle along with them he
was living with some comfort steinbeck
and sag harbor and was taking this
journey kind of to take the pulse of
america both are road books but on the
road is really a novel travels with
charlie is a travel memoir and most
recently in the travels with charlie
memoir tradition larry mcmurtry wrote a
book called rhodes which i recommend to
people too it's about being mercury
getting in a car by himself and taking
the interstates which we just showed on
the statistics there eisenhower's
interstate act made interstate travel um
so much easier and and mercury sticks to
the interstates where kerouac was just
doing a much more bohemian
travel experience maybe this reaches all
the way back to alexis to tocco and he
discovered america in 1831 and 32
traveling around let's go next to
hermosa beach california for our next
question you're on the air yes thank you
c-span for all you've done for us out
here
uh when i was growing up in the 50s and
60s in topanga canyon
i was surrounded by beatniks
and uh every other you know
word i would hear would be blah blah
blah blah blah blah kerouac he was you
know in the culture there
and my mother was an artist and she was
very bohemian herself
and uh so i really haven't read much uh
of him i've glanced at on the road and i
thought it was very interesting i'm
going to get deeper into him now
my question uh was i noticed that it
appears that
all his
kerwak and all of his buddies
were not in the service during world war
ii
so i was wondering what's the story
behind that it looks like they're kind
of like
conscientious objectors or what was the
deal
good question first off um kerouac's
closest boyhood friend uh sebastian
sampus and we'll have john sampus is
here later but uh sebastian was killed
at anzio and there's a correspondence of
course um between you know his letters
i've been able to see writing um jack
kerouac from there they were very very
close and then kerouac did go into the
merchant marine and u.s navy on 4243
but he was given a discharge due to
psychiatric or psychological reasons he
was as you put it a conscientious
objector not for the motives of the war
but that his refusal to pick up a gun to
kill um if he'd like a pacifist
later in life he would disdain hunting a
great deal kerouac and would used to
get into some get beat up even by going
into bars and and seeing hunters with
guns and saying how dare you kill you
know poor uh deer so the notion of
weapons to jack kerouac
was anathem um but he generally
supported the vietnam war later in life
well it wasn't he wrote a piece he said
i'm somewhere in the middle he wasn't
into this notion what what he got turned
off on was by the anti-war movement kind
of the long hair i think the hippie
lifestyle which many people said you
were the ones who turned it on
asana that carouse said no i'm not i'm
about a lot more mainstream values um so
i would not call him an active
pro-vietnam war person it was as simple
as a identification with the soldiers i
think there's some guilt on kerouac's
part of not doing more for his country
there's a scene that occurs when and
when the mary pranksters and ken kesey
came to see kerouac in the 60s up in
northport new york where kerouac lived
for a while um and kerouac they were
sitting on the american flag it was used
as clothing in the counter culture and
60s and kerala folded it in a military
fashion it was a symbolic moment that he
was he had a different view of what
america was than this 60s generation so
to understand the beat generation or at
least jack kerouac they were counter
culture at the time but very distinctly
american very distinctly american and i
would pull kerouac away from burroughs
and ginsburg in this regard i always see
jack kerouac in black and white last
night was watching the tyson um fight
and um at um a friend of great friend of
jack kerouacs here in townster live he
used to be a boxer and uh you know it
dawned on me just talking to him just
this there's a bunch it's
i saw colored pictures in this house of
jack kerouac but i always think of
carolink in black and white television
was black and white in the 50s the 60s
were technicolor and you don't see
kerouac in that technicolor
kind of era let's take some more calls
new york city next and as we uh look at
uh listen to new york city let's look at
columbia university's campus which is
the place where kerouac went to school
for a while new york city go ahead thank
you very much my name is steve i
actually went to columbia funny you
should mention it um but two things i'd
like to touch on if he could
one that i find interesting and and uh i
love carowick by the way and definitely
was a big life changer for me but um
he i i got to hang out about a decade
ago with herbert hunky uh before he died
and and uh you know it's clear that he
had an effect as being a very new york
kind of underground figure horrible drug
addict etc etc but one whom
the entire group of these guys kind of
emulated in their you know desire to
find out more about the underbelly of
new york if you'll
pardon the expression um
my other quick question is that even
though i love uh kirwack
and ginsburg and and all those guys i
find a kind of i just wonder if you
agree with this a kind of almost
i don't know uh
claustrophobia or a kind of
incestuousness to
the constant
circle of a couple of people over and
over and over and over again if you
could just talk about those two things
real quick that was a great thing
well that was one of the reasons why
they're called a beat generation is that
they would write about each other so
much dedicated poems they became their
own
circle of people and you were kind of
either beat or you were not be in the in
the parlance of that 50s you were square
or cool and you were talking about words
that come out of all of this uh somebody
earlier mentioned the word beat nick
that was sort of a a negative media term
placed on these people like uh because
of sputnik that went up in 57 that i
think was herbert um kane at the san
francisco who you know first coined it
but it was this notion that you know
he's a beatnik they're no good that's a
good for enough that nothing beat nick
well hunky provided some of the the i
think there's an african-american um
hipster
um
language and in the way carrock had a
great ear and he'd hear the way that
these sort of times square um hipsters
like herbert hunky would talk with terms
like hey man and you know that's cool
they're blow all night long and these
sorts of jazz underground times square
um
you know terms and you know they they
took all that that listening and then i
think combined it with like dostoevsky's
notes for the underground or um some of
the french existentialist writers uh
surrealism all these things are stirring
around and they're they're picking a lot
of them but there's i think what's
interesting is there's a look at
criminality bob dylan once had a line to
live outside the law he must be honest
uh it's a very unusual line to think
about but i think that's he was
reflecting dylan a kind of beat attitude
on that sometimes looking and writing
about people that are aren't um falling
into eisenhower conformity we saw that
thing there of television's coming up in
in the 50s in the 60s in these levittown
houses kerouac is saying look everybody
now is watching the six o'clock news at
the exact same time in their prefab home
wasn't it better i'm out here i might be
alone i might be friendless but i
feeling sense of freedom kind of
existential freedom
by
by being different by being a having not
falling into the automatic conformity of
the era lompoc california
hello to you good afternoon
um
my question is um
did
kerouac ever marry
and have a family and as an aside
i met
alan ginsberg in
about 1967
in italy
and
when i met him i
kidded him and said i'd seen pictures of
him burning his draft card
and he said oh that wasn't me that was
joan baez
and the further assigned
i discovered 30
some years later that
one of the reasons that
ginsburg was in northern italy at that
particular time was he was going to
meet with
ezra pound
in venice
i thought it was interesting the
fascist
pound and the
kind of left wing ginsburg were
getting together poet to poet
thank you
it's a very interesting point i mean
ezra powell one of the great poets in
ginsberg simply admired him as a poet
and yes pound was working doing radio
work for
once he wrote called satori in paris
where he went and made a journey over to
france to try to find um the the history
of the name kerouac and its roots and
the you know his his interest in the his
celtic origins and and the likes so uh
um good luck in in trying to um track
down the family connection san francisco
you are on our program what's your
question hi thanks for having me this is
a great series
um
i had two quick questions about the
relationships um that he had
one was actually within the novel and on
the road at the end of the novel um
it ends with uh jack carrocks with a his
girlfriend and another couple i think
they're on the way to a broadway play
and um
the character of dean marty kind of
comes out from the night and it ends
with him going off into the night sort
of this lonely figure
going into the darkness of the night and
i just wanted to know what was what was
it meant or what carolac may have met by
that dean is going off by himself and
someone in his party kind of comments
that he is this sort of lonely figure
and i just wanted to know what your
thoughts were it kind of reminded me of
joyce's character stephen douglas who
also goes off into the darkness of the
night alone and what um
kerouac may have felt or may have has
been his connection with that character
just going off by himself
and they kind of part ways and also i
read
douglas well his um alter ego of course
kerouac is um you know sal paradise is
the name who represents kerouac and the
novel on the road but you're absolutely
right jack kerouac is a poet of of of
lostness of loneliness um that allen
ginsberg once said we're all just hairy
bags of water meaning or but people are
just hair on them and there's fluids in
us and at the end there's the soul and
also we come into the world born alone
and we die alone and that's just sort of
a reality there are many people in
literature who play on those things but
kerala felt it very much the sense of
after all these exciting adventures we
have in the end somebody may die in a
hospital by themselves with some nurse
holding their hands or we might be dead
in a moment in an automobile accident or
something and just how fragile life is
and that at all these moments of great
exuberance and joy sometimes we then end
up with the loneliness and the sense of
despair and that's a great part of his
his work so it to understand kerouac
it's not a celebration of life but also
of death and that the ultimate demise of
all of us is death hence his interest in
religion so much and looking for how
some way to transcend on the the
shackles of earthly earthly reality in a
way and a spiritual quest and uh
that's what turns people on to jack
kerouac is he's constantly looking for
spiritual highs for moments which he
would call it you know those great
moments when somehow you feel something
whether it's looking in the sky or in
nature and uh in the book dharma bombs
is about you know kind of zen moments or
hiking with the poet gary snyder who's
jeffrey writer in the novel looking for
these great epiphanies and great moments
while we're here on earth for those who
are joining us in progress here douglas
sprinkley is with us a historian of
american culture especially and it seems
focusing a lot on the 20th century and
he's working on a multi-volume biography
and also editing the papers of jack
kerouac over the next few years there's
a big centennial coming up an
anniversary coming up will be the 50th
anniversary of the publication of on the
road in 2007 um and of course the new
york public library now that they've
acquired all of kerouac's papers and
then the most famous thing occurred
recently was that christie's auction
house went on the road kerouac had typed
it all out and it's called in the scroll
of on the road where he did continually
typing on this tracing paper and had it
all together and that scroll um has went
up for auction i think was 2.4 million i
was there that day jim irsay who owns
the indianapolis colts football team
purchased it and
it's one of the really important and uh
literary artifacts and people love to
look at it carouck put all the real
names of real people in that so if you
look at you'll see in allen ginsberger
neil cassidy and then later publishers
lawyers made him change those names so
not to have legal suits um you know and
so he changed them in the book but it's
fascinating to look at that as a primary
source the the so-called scroll were you
at all surprised at the price that that
manuscript went for it was the highest i
believe at least
ever paid for a literary manuscript for
20 20 i think it's about 2.4 million no
i'm not surprised because it's unique i
mean most writers of course today
turning your manuscript off a word
processor and here it is here's the disc
there's something about this that you
can really feel the the rhythms of
kerouac's typing he was a great typist
and that became a criticism truman
capote instead of character you're not
writing you're that's just typing on the
other hand it's a great art one of the
reasons he could do that spontaneous um
prose sometimes was because he could go
so quickly with the keys and there so
it's it's a it's a i wasn't too
surprised but i think jim irsay would
have paid as he told me when he bought
it he would have paid a lot more for it
i think it could have he would have gone
up further what's he gonna do with it
um for time being he's repairing it and
it has you know some tears in and things
so he's making sure he does the right
thing on getting it so it can
last for the ages will the public see it
eventually it will be and he's dealing
with the university of indiana
bloomington and also new york public
library to try to make sure that it gets
seen by the public in time for that 50th
anniversary covington louisiana go ahead
hi this is patricia thompson from
louisiana i had a question about
what jack kerouac thought about another
massachusetts writer henry thoreau if we
know
well caroline used to say about the the
so-called beats in san francisco north
beach area i mean we're all we were a
group of urban throws
meaning the very notion of some you know
thoreau's great maximum simplicity
simplicity simplicity to live a simple
life to you don't have to have material
belongings to find happiness that uh
influenced jack kiriwako a lot and not
just his time of solitude that he spent
at walden's pond thoreau and also it's
very much like care wax times of
solitude and um you know when he was um
going up into the pacific northwest and
working as a fire lookout person in the
cascade mountains that sense of
isolating herself in nature meant a
great deal to kerouac and i think
there's a great connection a sort of a
straight shot between throw in and
kerouac in the spiritual and the sense
of appreciation of nature a few weeks
ago we were in
california john steinbeck center to
learn about his book travels with
charlie someone in the same tradition
what would you say would be the
differences between the kind of america
steinbeck captured in his traveling
novel and the one we're talking about
today
well in jack kerouac it was true
ruthlessness of wandering um you know
hitchhiking not knowing we're gonna
sleep putting up a little pup tent on
the side of the road or in a ditch
interacting with hobos and the like and
travels with charlie by john steinbeck
and i have to say steinbeck's my
favorite american writer i just love all
of steinbeck's works and grapes of wrath
in particular but um i think that um he
was in that case having sort of a
bringing his poodle along with them he
was living with some comfort steinbeck
and sag harbor and was taking this
journey kind of to take the pulse of
america
both are road books but on the road is
really a novel travels with charlie is a
travel memoir and most recently in the
travels with charlie memoir tradition
larry mcmurtry wrote a book called
rhodes which i recommend to people too
it's about being mercury getting in a
car by himself and taking the
interstates which we just showed on the
statistics there eisenhower's interstate
act made interstate travel um so much
easier and um and make mercury sticks to
the interstates where kerouac was um
just
doing a much more bohemian travel
experience maybe this reaches all the
way back to alexis to tocco and he
discovered america in 1831-32 traveling
around let's go next to hermosa beach
california for our next question you're
on the air yes thank you c-span for all
you've done for us out here uh when i
was growing up in the 50s and 60s into
panga canyon
i was surrounded by phoenix
and uh every other you know
word i would hear would be blah blah
blah blah blah blah kerouac though he
was you know in the culture there
and my mother was an artist and she was
very bohemian herself
and so i really haven't read much
of him i've glanced at on the road and i
thought it was very interesting i'm
going to get deeper into him now
my question uh was i noticed that it
appears that
um all his
carouck and all of his buddies were not
in the service during world war ii
so i was wondering what's the story
behind that it looks like they're kind
of like
conscientious objectors or what was the
deal
good question first off um kerouac's
closest boyhood friend uh sebastian
sampus and we'll have john sampus is
here later but uh sebastian was killed
at anzio and there's a correspondence of
course um between you know his letters
i've been able to see writing jack
kerouac from there they were very very
close and then kerouac did go into the
merchant marine and u.s navy on 4243
but he was given a discharge due to
psychiatric or psychological reasons he
was as you put it a conscientious
objector not for the motives of the war
but that his refusal to pick up a gun to
kill um if he'd like a pacifist um later
in life he would disdain hunting a great
deal care whack and when used to get
into some get beat up even by going into
bars and and seeing hunters with guns
and saying how dare you kill you know
poor uh deer so the notion of weapons to
jack kerouac
was anathem um but he generally
supported the vietnam war later in life
well it wasn't he wrote a piece he said
i'm somewhere in the middle he wasn't
into this notion what what he got turned
off on was by the anti-war movement kind
of the the long hair i think the hippie
lifestyle which many people said you
were the ones who turned it on asana
that carousel said no i'm not i'm about
a lot more mainstream values um so i
would not call him an active pro-vietnam
war person it was as simple as a
identification with the soldiers i think
there's some guilt on kerouac's part of
not doing more for his country there's a
scene that occurs when and when the
married pranksters in ken kesey came to
see kerouac in the 60s up in north port
new york where kerouac lived for a while
and kerouac they were sitting on the
american flag as was used as clothing in
the counter culture and 60s and kerala
folded it in a military fashion it was a
symbolic moment that he was he had a
different view of what america was than
this 60s generation so to understand the
beat generation or at least jack kerouac
they were counter culture at the time
but very distinctly american very
distinctly american and i would pull
kerouac away from burroughs and ginsburg
in this regard i would see jack kerouac
in black and white last night he was
watching the tyson um fight and um at um
a friend of a great friend of jack
caroux here in town still live used to
be a boxer and you know it dawned on me
just talking to him just this there's a
much it's
i saw color pictures in this house of
jack kerouac but i always think of
caroline in black and white television
was black and when the 50s the 60s were
technicolor and you don't see kerouac in
that technicolor um kind of era let's
take some more calls new york city next
and as we uh look at uh listen to new
york city let's look at columbia
university's campus which is the place
where kerouac went to school for a while
new york city go ahead thank you very
much my name is steve i actually went to
columbia funny you should mention it um
but two things i'd like to touch on if
he could
one that i find interesting and uh i
love kerouac by the way and definitely
was a big life changer for me but um
he i i got to hang out about a decade
ago with herbert hunky
before he died and and
you know it's clear that he had an
effect as being a very new york
kind of underground figure horrible drug
addict etc etc but one whom
the entire group of these guys kind of
emulated in their you know desire to
find out more about the underbelly of
new york if you'll
pardon the expression um
my other quick question is that
even though i love uh kirwack and
ginsburg and and all those guys i find a
kind of i just wonder if you agree with
this a kind of almost
i don't know uh
claustrophobia or a kind of
incestuousness to
the constant
circle of a couple of people over and
over and over and over again if you
could just talk about those two things
real quick that was a great thing
well that was one of the reasons why
they're called a beat generation is that
they would write about each other so
much dedicated poems they became their
own
circle of people and you were kind of
either beat or you were not be in the in
the parlance of that 50s you were square
or cool and you were talking about words
that come out of all of this uh somebody
earlier mentioned the word beat nick
that was sort of a a negative media term
placed on these people like because of
sputnik that went up in 57 that i think
was herbert um kane at the san francisco
who you know first coined it but it was
this notion that the you know he's a
beatnik they're no good that's not good
for enough that nothing beat nick well
hunky provided some of the the i think
there's a african-american um hipster um
language and in the way carrock had a
great ear and he'd hear the way that
these sort of time square um hipsters
like herbert hunky would talk with terms
like hey man and you know that's cool or
blow all night long and these sorts of
jazz
underground times square um
you know terms and you know they they
took all that listening and then i think
combined it with like dostoevsky's notes
for the underground or um some of the
french existentialist writers
surrealism all these things are stirring
around and they're they're picking a lot
of them but there's i think what's
interesting is there's a look at
criminality bob dylan once had a line to
live outside the law he must be honest
it's a very unusual line to think about
but i think that's he was reflecting
dylan a kind of beat attitude uh that's
sometimes looking and writing about
people that are aren't um falling into
eisenhower era conformity we saw that
thing there of televisions coming up in
in the 50s in the 60s in these levittown
houses kerouac is saying look everybody
now is watching the six o'clock news at
the exact same time in their prefab home
wasn't it better i'm out here i might be
alone i might be friendless but i
feeling sense of freedom kind of
existential freedom by by by being
different by being a having not falling
into the automatic conformity of the era
lompoc california
hello to you good afternoon
um my question is um
did
kerouac ever marry
and have a family and as an aside
i met
alan ginsberg in
about
1967. in italy
and
when i met him i
kidded him and said i'd seen pictures of
him burning his draft card
and he said oh that wasn't me that was
john
baez and the furthest died
i discovered 30
some years later that
one of the reasons that
ginsburg was in northern italy at that
particular time was he was going to
meet with
ezra pound
in venice
and i thought it was interesting the
fascist
pound and the
kind of left wing ginsburg were
thank you
it's a very interesting point i mean
ezra powell one of the great poets in
ginsberg simply admired him as a poet
and yes pound was working doing radio
work for the mussolini's fascist
government
uh and was of course spent some of his
later years pounding uh in a hospital in
washington dc on ginsburg though a
respected pound and also kerak loved the
um the french writer um
um celine who was also had a sense of
fascism attached to him but they looked
looked beyond that pound was a god if
you like of poetry just as uh and they
wanted to um
ginsberg wanted to meet him and i
thought it was courageous for alan
ginsberg to do that that's your point
though gets to a large one i think since
we do so much politics on and
particularly on c-span other programs we
have to realize that these people are
about art and what art means and
ginsburg would and caroux shared i
believe that art was much higher form
than politics and it would transcend
change the world they they believed art
was the way to make make changes many
viewers may not believe in that but they
certainly did
we want to uh have you listen to a
little bit more of jack kerouac and
after you hear his voice then the next
person that you'll hear is sterling lord
he's been referred to in the program he
was kerouac's agent he was his agent and
i must also say yes jack kerouac was
married a few times thank you and his
last wife was um stella um stella sampus
um and we'll be with john sampus later
and not very long time as a matter of
fact so let's listen to more of kerouac
and his own words and then hear his
agent talking about what it was like to
try and sell this work to publishers
freddie's boy showed up that moment
and he was a little taught negro with a
great big cadillac
we all jumped in he hunched over the
wheel and blew the car
clear across san francisco without
stopping once 70 miles per hour he was
fulfilling his mission with a fixed
smile
his destiny with expected of the rumors
and songs of him right through traffic
and nobody even noticed he was so good
dean was next to these mazes dig this
guy man
dig the way he sits right in the seat
with the feel of the car under his both
haunches see and a little bit forward to
the left against the gut of the car and
he don't make any outward indication
and just balls that jack and can talk
all night while doing it the only thing
is he doesn't bother with life listen to
them man of things the things he lets
freddie do that and freddie's his boy
and tells him about life listen to those
two cats man the things i could tell you
the things i wish
let's not stop man
we've got to keep going
well uh when i read on the road it was
obviously
something new and different it was a
fresh voice
and it had a wonderful
policy to it a rhythm
that was extraordinary
and
that and you knew that you were
you were dealing with a very strong
voice
and all those things interested me
enormously
uh it didn't interest editors right away
it did it took me five years to sell the
book
what what seemed to be publishers
biggest
rejection of it well it was
i have some
rather
vivid
rejection letters in my files
um
one i remember one said discipline
discipline when will kerouac ever learn
discipline
and
i think apart from that it was something
that it was a form
and a voice that was just so
unconventional that a lot of publishers
couldn't
accept it
one
two editors in town who were very highly
regarded and were
about kerouac's age
so from a generational point of view
they
you might say they were as well equipped
as anybody to to read and accept and
understand it and both of them turned it
down
and now joining us on board the c-span
school bus at the jack kerouac
commemorative park in lowell
massachusetts is
john sampus and john tapas your
relationship to jack kerouac is what
i'm his brother-in-law and the
brother of his uh third wife stella
santos and we just heard sterling lord
talk about publishers reactions
what's your take on why it was difficult
for on the road to through
well that's a very interesting
question
i think it was the style of jack's
writing
obviously it was not
the style that uh most writers were
right it wasn't a hemingway style
it was a very spontaneous way it was a
conversational style
and jack
would uh just rattle on as it were in
his uh
in his writing on the road he sat down
and you know
he had been thinking about writing on
the road for many many years and he had
done drafts
and finally
listening to conversations with neil
cassidy
at least jack states this is on the
right
this book the way neil talks
and he sat down at the typewriter and
put together an outline
that he had already uh you know uh
drawn up from his previous straps of uh
on the road
and then uh
made a scroll
put his typewriter
get some coffee
and sat down for three weeks
and type this whole scroll 120 some odd
feet
112 feet i think or accurately
and uh single spaced
uh type the scroll
and uh many people think he wrote it on
drugs he did not it was strictly
caffeine
and it was the unconventional nature of
it that made it hard for the publishing
world to accept
uh
yes
it was
yes but you know there's much more to it
than that here was a group of young uh
he was a
two people two young men
who were adventurous
here's kerouac writing about his
spiritual venture
writing about neil cassidy's sexual
adventure
and
it was also a an appreciation
of neil's
enthusiasm his lust life
and a a closeness a bond that he had
created between himself and
neil for some time
and i think that it was quite a radical
book
to uh start including
sexual innuendo
sleeping around frequently
doing drugs
uh meals stealing cars
getting gasoline illegally you know to
fill up the tank
uh it was just the 50s
a very what we would call now a very
square type of mentality
and uh
the uh
established editors
were really
quite offended by
a working-class author coming in
disturbing the private school
editors who have these positions in the
uh
the newspapers the magazines
so there's it was more than
a style of writing that they were
against they were very much afraid of
the the gi coming out of world war two
and replacing them
kids who ordinarily would not have gone
to college or now supply the funds to go
to college
let me take some calls we have half an
hour left in our conversation about the
50s the beat generation and jack kerouac
as one of the chief writers of that time
period douglas brinkley the historian is
our guest david amram the composer with
us throughout this two-hour conversation
and uh we will have john sampus with us
until the top of the hour next call is
plymouth massachusetts go ahead please
hi bob stewart in plymouth i want to
thank john sampus for making kerouac's
work available to the world
i really appreciate that now a question
for both douglas sprinkle and john
sampus
i
have seen the dr saks comic strip
in carolyn cassidy's book
and i'm just curious to know that seems
to have been done when he was an adult
correct
and are there existing comics that he
drew
as a child
thank you there are existing comics of
the same style
and they are at the berg collection now
in new york the new york public library
they were placed there last year with
all of carolax archive how extensive is
the archive
right now it's excessive to uh doug
brinkley exclusively but how many how
big is it oh how big of the archive uh
well it's got thousands of uh
manuscript pages
uh holographs
it's got thousands of separate little
essays
uh short stories
working out
plus it has well over
anywhere from two to three hundred
journals and notebooks
thousands of letters correspondence
between himself
and
his correspondence you know many many of
them
and this does not include certainly many
that he threw away
doug brinkley by the time you are
finished going through this in
preparation for the publishing the
edited collection do you think
we as a country will understand more
about this time period through that body
of work
well i think we are all the time i think
the key is keeping jack kerouac's books
in print and uh you can get so many of
them now which is what's exciting and
it's one of the reasons there's been
this kerouac renaissance also he's
become just an icon
and a mythological writer in each
generation if you go to any college
campus jack kerouac is a very relevant
name so i think there's a whole
rediscovering process and and then we're
starting to get further away from the
50s and look at it and we're starting to
see which writers survive after a period
of time and certainly you start seeing
the beginnings of a james baldwin who's
so important coming out in the 1950s but
definitely kerouac has to be on the
short list of of writers that will be
studied and talked about for generations
to come james baldwin by the way our
next american writer in the series white
fish montana welcome to the beat
generation conversation hey thank you my
name is jack paladin i was reading a lot
i like kerouac and i've read a lot of
jack london's works and essays and see a
very strong similarity between the
rhythm style of london and kerouac but
then i read jack london's book the road
about his days writing the rail as a
hobo and i was wondering if that's just
a coincidence or did london have an
influence on kerouac thank you
okay
well um yes jacqueline had a gigantic
influence there's a photograph you could
see of him even trying you know he used
to kind of carry the the um rucksack
over his back and in in london's the
road he gets arrested i believe in new
york state for um vagrancy and and uh he
was his way london who was an orphan he
was a used to rob oyster beds in around
oakland um it was
london we used to travel the country and
then of course went up to alaska and
wrote those great stories so he was an
adventure writer and kerouac greatly
admired and
loved jack london so there's a direct
line there as for the road being a road
book what you start seeing i've in my
investigation is you start seeing a
whole group of automobile books theodore
driver wrote one called a who's your
holiday uh if you look in the works of
sinclair lewis and and whether it's main
street or a book called free air which
is all about a an auto trip the car
starts playing a major role in american
fiction um you can't we really read um
certain writers without look at
steinbeck with the route 66 and the
joads going down to california or uh um
you know the model t appearing in in so
much of the fiction of of the the period
and i think kerouac was very well aware
of some of those traditions next phone
call washington d.c
yes hi i was wondering if there was any
um
influence of d.h lawrence on carolecker
or some of the others
uh any parallels in their lives
thanks very much chuck
david emery do you have any sense of
whether d.h lawrence was a factor in in
your creative process as a group
well d.h lawrence had
a wonderful appreciation
of america
from an immigrant sensibility
in terms of not being born here and
seeing our country
what he wrote about america from a
different point of view jack's first
language was french and jack saw
america in the same way d.h lawrence
halls so had a deep love
of women and difficulty in
relating that love and those
relationships with women which jack and
many of us did at that time because we
were all on the outside
of the white picket fence
america when you would get together as a
group you those of you who were the
creative forces of the period what were
the conversations generally about
well jack and ice always spoke about
music
about french
about the english language about jazz
about sports
about friendships
and about the fact that we hope someday
people would appreciate the beauties
that surrounded all of us in the
american continent the beauties of
native american religion and music the
beauties of african-american culture
asian american culture country music all
the things that were not considered by
the establishment because we were
classicists as well
as improvisers that could be included we
wanted to see things more inclusive we
were inclusive rather than exclusive and
we wanted to celebrate the relationship
of spontaneity and formality as being
part of the whole
our next phone call el paso texas good
afternoon yes i'm matthew rothblatt and
for a few years i've been hearing about
a movie that's going to be coming out or
supposed to be coming out about
on the road and is that just rumors or
is there actually movie talks in the
works
about putting jack kerouac story on the
big screen
thanks john sampus uh it's
well we thought it was quite substantive
at the time that the uh
about a year ago
but it turns out that uh nothing's
really been uh going on with the movie
at all
and uh hopefully uh mr kovalev will make
the movie
but uh
as of right now
as far as i know i haven't been in touch
with him lately but in the movie there's
nothing going on doug brinkley talked
earlier about how jack kerouac has
become an advertising icon in recent
months and years when people use him to
sell cars for example today do they have
to talk to you as a
state trustee yes i do
how do you make decisions about what's
appropriate and what's not in his image
uh it's very difficult
because we don't want to seem commercial
but at the same time we have to
manage an estate
we have to pay fees to lawyers
to agents
so it's a very fine line
when you think about the
the image of him you would like to
preserve in making those decisions would
you explain what your thought is about
that
well the image i would like to preserve
off jack is the image that jack himself
would like to preserve
and that is of a great american author
he always aspired to be
a writer
he always wanted to succeed being a
writer he was pregnant with writing
and he succeeded and that's the image i
want to and the also the image of a very
good strikingly good-looking american
writer
who was very successful next call is
from wilmington north carolina welcome
hello my name is thomas schumacher from
wilmington and uh
this would be directed towards uh
professor blink brinkley a few minutes
ago one of the callers asked about
soma keralax critics and as i recall
from my own
studies of kerouac
he actually met william f buckley
in new york in the 40s
when he was a student at either columbia
or horace mann
and later there was the famous
appearance on a crossfire
or not a firing line
and it didn't go so well
and then as i recall there was a there
was an interview in the new york times
book review by a richard hill
and in that interview
richard hill noticed that on kerouac's
reading table
at his home in florida just prior to his
death there was a copy of
national review
can you tell us more about that
relationship
well it's not a
close one but you're absolutely right
kerouac knew william buckley that i
think i believe went out on a double
date at at one point back in new york in
that period
as years went on they weren't intimate
but kerouac um
had some respect for buckley and as
we've said a couple times in the show by
64 when the um the national review
kerouac was an admirer of that magazine
and of the buckley show he i think
enjoyed watching it now his visit in 68
to the buckley um show
was a disaster in many ways he came
there allen ginsberg was in the audience
uh and carrock was trying to distance
himself from the anti-war movement but
buckley had him kind of pigeonholed and
um and jack had drank quite a bit and so
it was not probably his finest
performance but there's some lines that
came out of that
that show with buckley that are very
famous when
kerouac would start talking in kind of
spontaneous prose and in a bebop uh
fashion and
and then you know so there's some great
moments in that interview but they were
not particularly close i don't think
william buckley's done anything in
recent years to talk about his
admiration for kerouac's writings but i
think he he liked jack kerouac in the
when he knew him as an individual back
during their college days
throughout this program you have been
hearing jack kerouac in his own words
we've been showing you books and other
materials you can get if you're
interested in learning more if you'd
like to hear more jack kerouac this is
available in just about any
store where you buy cds around the
country or the online services this is
jack kerouac reading on the road in his
own words part of the collection of the
sampus estate we were talking about
earlier that they are trustees of jack
kerouac's work next hollywood california
uh hi um i'm a big fan of allen ginsburg
and
i was wondering if anybody on your panel
could address the subject of the
sexuality
a couple of years back these these
rumors of pedophilia start to crop up
with with regards to ginsburg and he
appeared in a documentary seemingly
supporting enambler um
the documentaries called chickenhawk
is there any truth at all to these
horrible horrible rumors about
ginsburg and child sexuality
thanks david amram
well
senator mccarthy
specialized in in defaming and insulting
people at the 1950s none of us really
cared about that
jack gregory corso myself loved women
alan was attracted to men that wasn't
anything that we cared about and we
never really questioned
all of that and i respect people's first
amendment rights to say
what they feel and what they are and
what alan
felt and what he did
was the way alan was that was certainly
something that had no interest to me i
have a parent of three children and jack
and gregory and most of us
had different predilections but for
those people who were gay
we accepted that as they accepted us we
felt that loving another person
was about loving another person and i
think there's a was a problem back then
during the mccarthy period
when
j edgar hoover
and others tried to nail people to a
cross for their sexual preference or
their politics we tried to think of
people in terms of what they were like
as people so i would have no idea about
that and
if it were the case then that's
something that was alan himself would
have to speak about and he's not here
many of the photographs that you've seen
in the program today come from the
carowac estate and we thank the sampras
family for their help in in providing
them to you
also a number of other photographs came
from the allen ginsberg trust and
special thanks to them including peter
hall there next telephone call is from
o'gray michigan
hi there thanks for the work you do
i had a couple of questions the first
one was i recently read and greatly
admired a chunk of work by gary snyder
and wondered if you'd comment on the
relationship between jack kerouac and
gary snyder and the influence that jack
kerouac may have had
over gary snyder and the second one is i
wonder if mr brinkley would want to
speculate on
what
the the recent well-deserved attention
that jack kerouac has been getting says
about what we as americans sort of since
we've lost and would like somehow or
other to get back again thanks very
much well um gary snyder is the hero of
kerouac's book the dharma bums which is
a wonderful read and he is the character
jaffee rider and it takes place up in
northern california in the bay area and
snyder is a great nature a pulitzer
prize-winning poet and somebody a very
serious scholar of um of buddhism um and
i think a lot of karex understanding of
buddhism and his potential as a religion
and in his life comes from gary snyder
and philip whalen and others in the in
the bay area and snyder today still is
there i think he's um he's you know up
teaches periodically at university of
california davis and he just loved gary
snyder he loved everything about him
there was a little bit when i think gary
snyder had to first read the dharma
bombs he was very taken aback he didn't
realize he was being a a character for
another kerouac novel and there was a
sharp letter gary snyder wrote to
karowaki you know
kind of denouncing him for using me as a
character in her in his fiction but um i
think that gary snyder is really one of
my favorite poets and he's somebody who
meant is part of that so-called beat
grouping when it's done we haven't
talked enough about gary snyder gregory
corso and lawrence berlin getty but
those are three of the important poets
and today people like ann waldman out at
boulder um colorado is a continual uh
continuing in the kind of beat poetry
tradition and uh with that our time
running out how about his theory that
there's something lost in american
society that the kerouac fans are
reaching back to
i think absolutely today in particular
when you read caroline there is
nostalgia and jack kerouac was very
nostalgic for the days when he was a boy
playing football here at lowell and we
read
reading on the road today it's hard to
feel the subversiveness in the text it
seems like this a book so much has
happened since then that seems to be
very celebratory of america but as john
accurately said at that time keep in
mind your mccarthy area in the 1950s
indiana textbook
refused to have robin hood mentioned
because he was communist 500 books were
banned in san antonio texas from chaucer
to you know faulkner
you had the state of alabama meaning
anybody writing anything on history in
alabama had to say in writing and what
they wrote i am not a communist this is
the climate where kerouacs being so this
freewheeling um you know buddhist
catholic exuberant romantic
existentialist poet and it's only
natural that i think the culture would
turn on and today when we read kerouac
we find a lot of the kind of main street
joys the sense of community and things
that in the old tv shows or black and
white movies and the shadow comic strip
and radio late at night and and those
things which are vanishing more and more
if you come to lowell massachusetts to
visit uh some of the national park
service
sites which include the
industrialization of america don't
forget to stop by this park the jack
kerouac commemorative park it is uh
organized and overseen by the lowell
city parks commission and we thank them
for letting us be here today los angeles
california
uh yeah hi
sorry i have call waiting um i was
wondering if any of the panelists think
that it would be possible for a writer
uh
comparable to kerouac to be spawned in
today's social and political society um
because i'm i'm a young man born in the
70s and so i don't remember
any of the united states being you know
some place where you could freewheel
so i'm just wondering if they're like
john sabbas you have some thoughts on
that i bet could this society spawn a
jack kerouac today
well i don't know
i'm so over the hill that i'm not a
young man anymore
so it's very difficult but i think so
i think so because you know
when jack wrote on the road
and when he was inspired to write on the
road he was a very young man
and
and he became aware
of the of the land
and of the mountains and of the roads to
conquer and travel
and i think we were all very young
adventurous
and
handsome
and we had the world the world was our
oyster and there are young men today who
finally come to this realization that
the world is their oyster
they have their youth
and they have their adventure spirit yes
we have more jack heroics to come along
and they might be women um something we
haven't talked about the women of that
period but exactly but there's a great
poet diane de prima who is part of this
sort of energy we mentioned joyce
johnson earlier well they're they've had
a great influence on feminist studies
and the next jack kerouac very well may
be uh be a woman traveling the country
or looking for if you like the essence
of either america or elsewhere just five
minutes left in our conversation next is
coming georgia
hi this question is uh for mr brinkley
earlier he had uh touched on jack
kerouac's father's illness and death and
i remember reading somewhere that
kerouac had a brother who died very
young
and i was wondering if he could comment
on the impact that had on kerouac and on
his work
thanks as you answer we have visited the
jack kerouac's gravesite here in lowell
massachusetts let's look at that as you
talk about his family well his his
brother was named gerard and he was born
in 1916. jack kerouac was born in 1922
so you can see the difference and like
any big brothers jack kerouac worshipped
his younger brother looked up to him a
great deal and then gerard died and that
death in a catholic home and the death
of his older brother his role model had
an incredible psychological emotional
spiritual impact on jack kerouac and he
wrote a book called visions of gerard
which i highly recommend to people to
read and it's a really a meditation on
the death of his brother and how much he
loved his brother and the loss that he
felt and again he's giving his brother a
kind of heroic
stature the books almost written from
his mother's point of view what it's
like for a mother to lose a son but it
comes out as as a brother losing a
brother and so he loved his brother
gerard a great deal and you can read it
and feel how much so if you pick up that
book which is in print as we wrap up
here in addition to thanking all four of
our guests for their time and their
knowledge of carol wack and the beat
generation today two other thank yous
james irsay who allowed us to videotape
the on the road scroll that he just paid
2.4 million dollars for and the folks at
at t broadband who helped us with our
live production here at the kerouac park
paradise california go ahead yeah hi i
have two questions one is uh mr brinkley
uh sees a influence on bob dylan and two
can he comment on a meeting that jack
kerouac had with henry miller and big
sur
at one point
well the bob dylan is on record of
saying how much jack kerouac meant to
him he gobbled up kerouac's books and
was inspired by them but more than that
if you listen to blood on the tracks
album by bob dylan the song tangled up
in blue as a direct tribute to jack
kerouac then in 1976 dylan got a bus
back to the buses again and it was
called the rolling thunder review and
dylan brought a bunch of his musical
cronies joan baez mick ronson rambling
jack elliott the playwright sam shepard
allen ginsberg and they traveled the
east coast for the bicentennial on a bus
doing concerts and they came here to
lowell and their jack kerouac played at
um at the gravesite that you've just
seen jack kerouac sat there and sang
some of mexico city blues some of
kerouac's poems at the gravesite henry
miller i'm so glad you mentioned him
there's a connection because henry
miller once wrote a biography of d h
lawrence then henry miller went on to
write the introduction to the paperback
of subterraneans henry miller really
enjoyed jack kerouac and was one of his
biggest boosters and supporters and
henry miller is a great american writer
who also used that autobiographical form
and the famous tropic of cancer tropic
of um you know capricorn group and nexus
plexus and some of his other books so i
would put henry miller in this
conversation we've had all day as one of
the americans that had a big influence
on kerouac and burroughs as you can hear
from that answer there is so much more
to talk about and many more writers that
we haven't even skimmed the surface but
our time has run out so as we close here
i'm going to do a round robin of the
three guests who are with me to ask them
in 30 seconds if you would talk about
our topic the beat generation as we
close why is it important in 2002 to
look back on it and start with doug
brinkley
well because if you look at what life
was like in the 50s you had a jim crow
south blacks didn't have their there
were no voting rights act there was a
segregated apartheid system south of the
mason-dixon line women who got the right
to vote in 1920 still didn't fully have
wrote a vote the sense of
environmentalism was kind of laughed at
where the beats were one of the first
ones to kind of talk about ecology and
gary snyder deserves a great deal of
credit for that and also the publishing
of people the first amendment of saying
what we want to say of not feeling you
need to be censored and not being afraid
of the censors of the 50s i think all of
those are a living legacy to the beat
generation
douglas sprinkle as always we appreciate
what you contribute to our understanding
of america here thanks for being at the
table and we will look for lots more
about jack kerouac from you over the
next four or five years thank you david
amram your thoughts on as we close why
is it important to look back at the beat
generation
because when we look back we see a
mirror of ourselves in 2002 or for the
young people that i see at the age of 71
all over the world when i conduct
symphonies when i play jazz folk music
programs when i do seminars whether i
read from my book offbeat collaborating
with kerouac i encourage them to be pure
to work hard
to dare to dream never to give up as we
did never to take rejection personally
to strive for beauty for spirituality
for excellence to be inclusive and
compassionate for other people and if
you're told no you can't
respect those derogatory opinions but
hang out with somebody else
well thank you for being with us and
john sampus you've talked about why you
want uh jack and how you want jack
kerouac's legacy to live on so do you
have a final word on that well i uh
try to uh see that it
does live on putting out some new books
of his that have not been published how
many more do you think we've got a book
of haiku
i've got the book of sketches which is
uh called jack himself calls neither uh
poems no pros but what just what is but
it's a good thick volume of prose
actually
uh putting out a book of letters uh
between allen ginsberg and jack kerouac
a book of letters between john cullen
helms and jack kerouac
and i think getting all these letters
out and all these books
will
uh the world will see what a genius jack
kerouac is and wise we appreciate you
being here with us today and your
family's help and telling the story
thank you thank you
and david amber let's let's close as we
began we're going to
listen to some more of jack kerouac in
his own words reading from on the road
you're going to play for us once again
once again what's your final piece and
what will you be playing on
i'll be playing the native american
flute
uh she ho carti flute the floyd red crow
westerman taught me 40 years ago a great
traditional melody that i used for the
piece i wrote for the philadelphia
orchestra but which came from the roots
of america called mustinchela watchipe
and it's jack search for his indian
heritage and all of us in america that
appreciate our own heritage is more when
we realize the beauties of native
american culture this was something we
loved and cared about and that jack
cared about it all of us as old friends
who were here thank you susan and thanks
c-span for honoring a great american
writer
along with hemingway and falter and
those great writers that jack felt he
should be associated with it's a
beautiful beautiful day finally to have
this happen and we thank you from the
bottom of our hearts let's listen in
there is no end to the night great roar
of chicago dawn we all staggered out and
shuddered in the raggedness
it would start all over tomorrow night
so we rushed on to new york
ain't nothing left after that's a d
he said
yeah we seek to find new phrases we try
hard
i said we rise
and twist and blow every now and then a
clear harmonic cry gives new suggestions
of a tune
a thought
will someday be the only tune and
thought in the world and which will
raise men's soul to joy
we find it we lose
we wrestle for it we find it again we
laugh we moan
go moan for man
it's the pathos of people that gets us
down
all the lovers in this dream
[Music]
oh
[Music]
[Music]
this friday at 8 pm eastern you can see
an encore presentation of this american
writers program on the beat generation
and jack kerouac right here on invasion
mourning in america rounds out the list
the official memorial cd and dvd of
president reagan's funeral services was
produced by the ronald reagan
presidential library and foundation to
learn more about the conservative book
club visit their website at
conservativebookclub.com
in palimpsest gore vidal writes about
the first 40 years of his life including
friendships with robert and jacqueline
kennedy jack kerouac and tennessee
williams
now join the gay men's reading group at
left bank books in st louis for a
discussion this is an hour
good evening uh i'm harold ellis we are
at the gay men's reading group here in
st louis missouri we're here tonight to
talk about gore vidal's memoir
palimpsest
vidal is a distinguished man of letters
um
and political intellectual he's been
active since the late 1940s
the writer of a number of celebrated
novels such as the city and the pillar
julian 1876 lincoln creation
some of his writings have been recently
collected in an anthology
called the gore of a doll reader but
again tonight's book is palimpsest a
memoir
the book itself is like anyone's life
multi-dimensional have many themes run
through it
and like the book i suppose our
discussion will be multi-dimensional and
range widely two themes i think are
salient
for a gay men's reading group one is the
love story that runs through the book
another is the book's continued
reflections on sexuality or what gore
vidal calls same sexualism and perhaps
we might start there
with his reflections on same sexualism
i think even before we started talking
tonight
the subject came up
in private conversation about how this
book is dated or generational the book
written by a man who came of age in the
40s
does that have anything to do with his
reflections on same sexualism as he
calls it
is he 80 now
did i figure that out right yeah almost
just about right because his birthday is
actually in early october
like october third i wanted
and he said i'm 69
and it was
20 years plus
21 years ago
i guess it does that issue certainly
makes a difference
well it seems like he's with it
alien you know he would have a different
perspective anyone who had actually gone
through the
been present at the
sexual revolution as it were or after i
mean his attitude is
is based on a certain it just
it's sort of
without i mean without him necessarily
recognizing that sort of macho
that he feels the need to retain this
yeah he does i think at one point or
more than one point use the word gay um
not disparagingly but he um
he seems to describe it as a misnomer or
misleading term well in fact i think he
would in fact think this gathering would
be patently ridiculous
it's also interesting when
this group
discussed the gay beats
and we talked and he came up as having
an encounter with kerouac
uh it seemed so important to gore that
he be
the top that he be
always seen as the more aggressive one
and that came through in the kerouac
book
or that collection as well as here
it's also kind of interesting when you
said the love story that runs through
this it seemed to me there's jimmy
trimble
who's the great love of his life
then there's howard
who you actually learn very very little
about
which i found sort of interesting
except that they never have sex right i
mean that's the first thing that jumped
out at me when he was
not that i could follow my own um
relationship pattern but yeah exactly
it's the secret of the to a relationship
is just not having sex together
but he really
you know i lived in this town and
howard was with me
right we rented a house and
howard was with me
given the
details he tosses off about so many
other people
i didn't really feel i got a great sense
of someone that he spent what 40 plus
years with yeah
which may have been
what howard wanted
or may have been hey when i can talk
about the kennedys and i can talk about
all the fascinating people
maybe i don't need to come as close to
home as my partner i don't know he's not
negative about him it's just
he seemed peripheral which is neither
here nor there
struck me
yeah and when you say the love of his
you know his love affair
i almost don't know which one the the
fantasy that
he holds from
those brief encounters as a teenager
with
jimmy who dies
therefore allowing a huge fantasy to go
on for the next
many decades or the reality of the great
love of his life well actually he's
the relationship becomes non-sexual
although he doesn't become non-sexual
but the relationship seems to you think
that howard is the great love of his
life
so i really don't pick that up i just
thought this was someone to live with
you know but 40 plus years well
it happens
except that at the end of this book he
does describe the book as a love story
and he uses the term basically to
describe
the theme of jimmy running through the
book not the theme of howard yeah
i sort of suspect
and i hate to put word thoughts in
garvidel's mind
as you did saying a group like this
would be
the concept of the love of one's life
that's not
sort of iconic and archetypal
like jimmy i don't know if he'd have
much store with
you know the down-to-earth reality of
that day in day out
since he's so
he gets his intellectual stimulation in
one place he gets his
physical needs met other places he likes
certain groups for certain people he
seems just a great deal of contempt for
him for most of his lovers
most of the people in his life
actually yes he has made that point how
long did he not speak to his mother
before she died like two years or what
ten i thought more yeah yeah but his
mother really did seem like a piece of
work yeah she did well only
you know he calls it polimpsist
he defines that as
i write and then i erase and i write
again
and i
i'm not going to quote extensively but
a memoir is is how one remembers one's
own life
while an autobiography is history
requiring research dates facts facts
double checked
so he's
given himself permission
to
have a memoir
and view his life
the way he remembers it which is fine
that's why he calls it a memoir
but can we always trust
when he's so hard on so many people
and so
i cut
can i say kind of [ __ ] about people
is that a problem i mean
i mean he sort of tosses off these like
that if you really think about him he's
really
saying some pretty
outrageous things about fairly prominent
people that he just says and by the way
it may be just the way he remembers it i
mean do we always trust
what he's saying family he's seeing it
from his perspective
he certainly paints his family is
dysfunctional
and they might well be um
but he's it's his lens i think someone's
oftentimes part of what the purpose of
his insults his insults against all
these people in his life has been to
puff up their importance therefore his
own importance
that seems like part of what's the real
imports
key in this book is that he
he is important which i mean yeah right
i don't i don't know that um it is
necessarily rash or um
um
wrong of him to be aware of his own
importance
in order to try to remember you
insofar as this is a memoir and i'm i'm
not a reader of memoirs
much
um but you know there seems to be an
awful lot of score settling in this one
you know in
his memoir he said about this encounter
with me
x now here's the real story why
and so the memoir is
claiming
making a claim to truth
at the same time you know this is a guy
who writes not history but historical
novels
after this memoir ends
and he's also a guy especially towards
the end of the book who's making
arguments against history as a
discipline he makes statements about
history uh
as um
a fabrication of agreed-upon facts that
really are not um reliable
as if
historical fiction or maybe even by
extension a memoir is a much it much
comes closer to some kind of essential
truth than
what uh certainly what a scholar would
write certainly what
how he remembers it but his he opens the
book
a tissue of lies
could there be a more persuasively apt
title for a memoir
so
i i believe he is writing down things
the way he remembers them
but he seems to also by giving it a
title like palimpsest which means
i can
erase erase it and start over again
or
rethink it or
calling it a memoir not an autobiography
and then saying no fact checking
no
no facts necessarily
it doesn't invalidate this is how you
know
given the work i do with holocaust
survivors
they have their memories
and they give their testimony
it's how they remember things happening
would you want to go back and say no it
was on september 8th not september 7th
not not important
so by calling it a memoir i think he as
i say gives himself permission to
let it be how he remembers it and if
it's not exactly right
so be it
although there is a certain
strain on what it's only what kind of
pronouncing he makes in general that
he's a little bit skeptical of facts in
general i mean some of his recent
political stances certainly have
where he
is he's very easy he's in conspiracy
theory certainly and that's
it's part of who he is that he
he
said i think certain things are true and
then
he doesn't worry about he doesn't worry
about facts i guess in this connection
it's interesting to remember though that
at several points he mentions that he
has a researcher
you know who is is going into archives
whether it be
in italy or someplace in the united
states doing research as well
the other thing though that he says is
more like what you said dan which and he
makes an admiring comment about proust
and he said proust got it right when he
said that
experience remembered is
truer
than experienced
lived
in a nutshell yes
and so maybe
this this is not just rewriting his life
but somehow reliving and intensifying it
and he's wanting to
to convince us that somehow the act of
recapturing
his own
pre-novelist life
is is really a a a a valid historical
enterprise
you said you loved the book i really did
but i really looked at you know the
whole i thought that really his use of
the term pollen says he was just being
accurate maybe even humble
um about the nature of memory and the
nature of fact although there repeatedly
as i remember correctly
there are times when he says no in this
argument this is what i said you know or
this is what happened and this is how i
did jack kerouac or whatever
but i just because i re i read kennedy
yeah oh my gosh
opened up my
mommy's so slow to see the really closet
cases i guess but
um
i really enjoy uh memoirs and i've read
a bunch of them and this
i don't know i was thinking you know i
would want if i were gonna be uh
marooned and abandoned on an island this
is one of maybe five books but mostly
just like i'd want my favorite issue and
i don't ever i don't have a favorite
issue of us magazine
or people because along with just all
the juicy bits i came to enjoy jaclyn
bouvier kennedy oh so much more knowing
all this trash about her
than i did before and i already liked
her you know having been
old enough to remember eisenhower when
he was in the white house
but
yeah
a lot a lot even with the the greed that
generally
she is an icon isn't known for at least
i didn't he said some rather what was it
about
about her greediness about her
self-image and about how
her image during you know her political
years
was so so much a facade
but being
i guess i'll be 50 i was born in 53. so
when he talks about those early years or
the kennedy years the camelot period
whatever
i'm not saying as a school kid i would
know the inner workings of politics but
there seemed to be so much rot going on
that he talks about
coming so close to
disaster not just in with cuba but this
sort of cavalier attitude
it's like how could
maybe i wouldn't have known as a you
know fifth sixth grader did my parents
like
why didn't anyone know and he sort of
says i didn't he seems to be like in the
room you know
that's when these legs seem like
critical times that the world almost
came to an end yeah yeah
your belief is stretched
i don't know nowadays i sort of believe
it but i'm more jaundiced now i guess
then i thought it was just completely
credible
but you know part of it and ironically
of course this may be part of why the
book scene
or caught my intro i actually i lived
for a little while in madison south
dakota where his father came from and so
dates were suddenly
you know sending off sort of like living
the
negative his life so very insignificant
and
and not prominent life but
living in south dakota and i wondered if
this it's almost poetic that his father
came from that tiny little state in that
tiny little town
which
i mean is
so unembattled
it was the place not that he makes any
reference to it but the only claim to
fame before this book i thought madison
had was that after kent the killings at
kent state
nixon chose madison as the spot for his
first foray outside of washington
because it was so distinctly unembattled
and his old friend carl mont from the
old huok days lived out there but in
south dakota
there's so few people in that entire
state that you can
it's not impossible to conceive of
knowing everyone in the state on a
first name basis and and you know the
political people uh
are really readily accessible that i
thought it was interesting that of
course he's living
by historical accident or maybe i don't
know genetic predestiny among all these
very important people certainly
nationally in my lifetime
it was also
interesting and again
it wasn't like overt i'm going to topple
this idol with say kennedy
but
how many times in it did he say
jack kennedy
ally of
senator of joe mccarthy
and then a chapter later if you didn't
get that yeah
ally of joe mccarthy
and by the way bobby mentor to you know
who had been mentored by
so don't think these people were so
you know that camelot was so
perfect
when they were associated with
pure evil or you know
it's one of those
one of those times where i feel this
begins because it perhaps a little
generational that i
you know i was
born in the 70s and i
i'd say i never i mean i i also spent a
lot of time thinking about history over
the years but i
in a visceral level never really
cared at all about camelot never had any
image of it positively
i just it was just something which
i had obsession with my father's that i
just didn't understand
and
the fact that he's toppling all these
people people always figure that he
and it's a memoir so his memories are
very much based on who he knew
but that he
it was part of what made me sometimes
difficult to engage with the book is
that it was so much based on
the reader
believing these people to be
important you know in their lives in
their lives not just important because i
can look at me and say whatever
was
going on that this was a
person who was important
but the other people which which
perhaps were important important because
of lived experience not because of
anything else
like jack you know
like
he is aware of that um that generational
dimension though i think he or some of
the people he
quotes
talk about
will
all of us be remembered 20 years 30
years from now well the people who read
this now know the people i'm talking
about
from my past
he's he's uh that's true i'm talking
about auden and
woah and
earlier people
he kind of makes that point very clearly
yeah that's a good point yeah so he's
he's um i guess the first to admit that
in a way this this book is the uh a
generational book it's a book about a a
time past
that may or may not be of interest to
the time in which he's writing and being
read i mean you know
be anything otherwise
yeah i mean yeah maybe he could but
it's
top order what i've
you know i i really like the book
i was interested in all the
people and the events and the history
and the memories he had
from the writers tennessee williams
i thought i'll like it less when he gets
to the politics but that was fine and i
did like it
and being behind the scenes in hollywood
and the best man in the theater and all
that
but i have to say i didn't find it an
easy read
but one thing that i kept being amazed
by is
you know there's certain seem to be
certain periods you know new york at a
certain moment in the world of the arts
paris and
you know the 1880s
whatever it may be cultural centers
it seems like wherever he goes
that's that's it somehow
oh and tennessee will you know these
people will be around me and i think
i'll be back in the states and you know
i'll be invited to
intimate dinners at the white house
and you know jackie sneaking off to to
was it palm springs palm beach palm
springs
wherever
no key west key west key west
then i'm going to go to hollywood and by
the way here's
you know i'm going to know that i'm
going to know
capra and i'm going to know
and then i'm going to be on broadway and
surround myself with
marlon wherever he goes he seems to be
at one of those
really important coming together
of the most interesting people and i
kept thinking
why didn't that happen
right no you know
where can i go like and i guess you can
never
it's sort of like the beats you know
i guess you have to
be at the right place at the right time
be born at the right time
or simply just show up or show up i
think you know and here again that's why
i keep
jimmy harkening back to to madison which
was the smart part it wouldn't have
happened except that he really yeah yeah
well actually though i might tell you
what wouldn't happen the thing which i
just i'd go back especially for that
page when if you realize that jaclyn
uh lee bourier might never have become
first lady but for that one
very critical
non-functioning erection
in the family tree
every time i think of her now i'm
thinking yes you know but for huey's
problem
in this it had to be in the 70s i was
trying to remember i was living in
maybe could it have been the early 80s
truman capote in
the washington post there had been
little
one thing there seemed to be a gap from
like 64 to 94 in this book
never never
in the 80s there seemed to have been
some i i don't remember the details
there was a lawsuit
between truman capote and gorby dalton i
don't remember who sued who for libel
it happened to be a situation that lee
radziwell witnessed
and she said
oh it's just a fight between two gay men
and they were both furious at her for
not
siding with either one or the other
and truman capote wrote this two-part
feature in the
style section of the
of the washington post
that was the most vicious the most catty
about garvey doll about lee radziwell
about
jackie kennedy saying
horrible things about lee radziwill but
at least but between the sisters she's
the one that had decent taste or
really nasty
and it had had to do with some lawsuit
between them
and he's so dismissive you get the sense
that truman capote is sort of a an
insect
kind of to be sort of swatted away
not to be taken seriously and
certainly not in terms of honesty
oh really yeah
it was it's almost even with him being
dead saying remember he was a great liar
liar i mean that certainly seems to be a
score that he's trying to sell yeah
after i thought it was just that he won
that lawsuit so handily it seemed like
what or at least he portrays it was just
that well okay i'm sorry wasn't that
about what the resolution
was it ended up in a settlement yeah he
dismissed uh uh with the uh
uh upon receiving a statement and
writing from truman capote that uh what
he said had been untrue
and then
but really his fingers are crossed you
know yeah
it just seemed
i don't know
you know you started with this idea of
the great love of his life
same war
um
well i think that's the strand that runs
through the book and frank with respect
i guess i'll come back to that but
two other things that i think are worth
i'd like to say in that connection
that strand runs through the book it
comes up to the surface of the text and
then goes underneath and then comes up
again and i think the whole book is um
is is a
a weave of of lines that surface and
then are submerged
and i think part of that is to part of
that reiteration is to
i think it functions in in our in making
us a as we go through the book remember
with him
what he's remembering as he writes
where where we're undergoing the
experience of memory because
we come back to themes that he raised
and that he returns to
um certainly the theme of jimmy trimble
is there and the thing that is uh and
this the and that in turn this um
this use of themes that come to the
surface then get submerged and then
re-emerge i think made the book a
compelling read
not necessarily a fast one
but one that nonetheless commanded
attention and uh didn't make it easy for
me to put it down
you know i would sometimes find myself
staying up rather late
to see the pace yeah yeah well it's
interesting how he talks about jimmy and
then quite a bit later
talks about
having the meal with jimmy's mother and
getting that perspective
and then quite a bit later
sitting down with christine the
female love yeah and
you know
that i guess he proposed to and had he
lived survived the war
et cetera getting a third perspective
so certainly that that thread
but then getting back to
the the love story element of this it
really
it really is
i guess an experience uh you know a
personal experience of his that is in
some ways alien to
that to me
and probably to most of his readers to
have
a fantastic devotion to
a memory
a memory of one you other human being
who is the the pole around which his
whole effective life
revolves for the rest of his life
and then the exclusion of others yeah
and then and then everything else is um
uh gets into two other boxes i mean
friendships which may
be quite serious and devoted and warm
but are not
sexual or affectionate and would
certainly say so and then yeah and then
on the other hand
casual
casual sex you know right
and the the the compartmentalized life
that he lives is um
um
foreign
it's it's the one thing that somehow
rises to the surface of this this book
and i don't know if it i'm disturbed by
it but i am i'm at a distance from it
personally
you know
oh gosh
without going into too much detail it's
maybe less foreign certainly not
similar
but i did understand that
compartmentalization
and actually sort of got that
i mean it's
it works for him yeah i mean yeah
it makes life simpler right right
right
makes life simpler but
and that lack of complication that
refusal to allow
something so central to you to be too
complicated can give you a kind of
serenity but also a kind of um
emptiness i'm
i am guessing i don't know maybe i'm
just being uncharitable because
certainly this he has a this powerful
this powerful
attraction or or attachment
to jimmy he had it as a child a memory
it was a memory now and he didn't even
know him for very long
and jimmy seemed to have moved on at
some level which he acknowledges
um
you know there's nothing there's not
like a sentimental
line in the book yeah
there is
is there passion
is their passion
well yeah i was going to say for jimmy
there is although i'm thinking you know
he started out reading everything
because he wanted to know the history of
everything and to me that's a little bit
of the ex just the you know permanent
and eternal
inquisitiveness about this one mystery
about
a really beautiful young man
his his whole isn't this
he went through like the whole plato and
there are the three balls you know and
they break in
two and and he and jimmy happen i i
don't know how
often that happened certainly that's not
been my experience
you know to find somebody you know at
any point where it's like oh well this
is it you know we were meant for each
other and it seems like that's who jimmy
was
and i mean it's amazing well not amazi
i think it's kind of awesome to me to
contemplate that i mean he's chosen his
burial place to be between
to be so near adam and reflect jimmy is
is howard going there too yes
they might guess
that's right
part of the way he writes about people
i don't think garvidil cares whether i
like him or not
i do respect him a lot
he's brilliant
there were times where i had such
admiration
but found him not a very likable person
person because of how he
wrote about other people
and it colored how i
as i would keep turning the pages
or just be looking at what horror shows
can come next right yeah sort of uh
right there seemed to be a
i don't know just like a
a reserve
i don't know
well i don't know he's so influenced by
his history i mean the grandfather was
so wild and crazy i guess i can sort of
i don't know that he would have been
that he would be an easy person to be
around if he weren't the least bit
interested in you although i remember at
one point where he's referring to
someone who he portrays as being pretty
stupid is kind of
worthy of his affection i thought oh god
maybe i'd have a chance
but um i wondered if that was where he
was from or the family
you know because i know coming being
from i was like well you wouldn't talk
like that you know unless you were a
real
um
self-assured
i think that's another dimension of him
that i think
comes from his coming from a political
family i think at one place in the in
the book
um
i mean throughout the book he is
describing himself as from a political
family and at one place in the book
particularly he describes himself as
from power people
and he makes that observation in
connection with
how he responded to a question someone
asked him about i think whether he feels
guilt or apolog feels apologetic or
guilty about
positions he takes
or the way he is
and he
he says no i'm for one thing no one in
my family feels that way we're power
people
actually was kind of kind of
alan ginsberg now that i think of it
because he'd be such an easy target and
he's kind of kind i didn't mean to
interrupt
just struck me yeah
but i i think that that dimension of of
who he is is an important
one for me and thinking about somebody
with the enormous
reserve of self-confidence and um and
and ease that he has i think some of it
just comes from the world he came from
and he describes himself as like jackie
penniless you know he's but
yeah
you know i mean they all owed an awful
lot of of whatever wealth or entree they
had to the alliance with the arkhan
class family but but still
the um
the sense that he
came from a political clan
uh and grandfather was yeah well senator
yeah and
i mean such a personality the
grandmother too
and getting shifted out of his and after
he does after the way he describes his
mother yeah being with the grandparents
who are there this these
but there's nothing self-pitying in it
but it's a very
kind of weird
upbringing
reading to the blind grandfather and
loving it yes having that love of
reading et cetera i'm sorry you were
going to say something no no it was it
seemed like this part of what we were
thinking before that is reserved that
was based on being this
from this
uniquely sort of privileged class of
people where he didn't i'm just thinking
the whole idea of not going to
not going to college and not really
worrying about it it reminded me of all
these sort of british aristocrats who
you
who do whatever they want and they land
on their feet and they don't necessarily
value
structure or other people's
credentials or other people's approval
and that's yeah but you know
i i will
i will argue the other side of the the
the case as well
um
it struck me
as wonderful and enviable that when he
was in high school
he knew he wanted to be a writer
he knew his vocation he knew
what mattered to him
and therefore he could say this [ __ ]
doesn't matter to me you know like the
assigned readings of his uh of the
classes he was taking he had that sense
of that powerful sense of direction
which i think is a um
a wonderful thing for a human being to
have if he can have it and i don't know
that that is something that we can as uh
i would assign to his being power people
i think that is something else there's
really something special that he can
shine shine
fairly ridiculous word but
achieve a claim as a writer and as a
playwright and as a
you know film person and
in so many areas and
he certainly feels had he chosen
politics
he he implies that people kept asking
him will he run
etc
that it really was
that's not what i'm going to do now i'm
going in a different direction
but you get the sense had he chosen to
and that had been what he really wanted
certainly it was in the blood yeah um
and he could have achieved great success
at it although he sort of what does he
say i think it's a caption
one of his slogans is you'll get more
with gore and it says i never figured
out what more meant but
but he thought that he had chosen
politics and realized he wasn't going to
be in i mean it wasn't where he was
going writing like at the beginning he
indicates that both he and jimmy
knew what they wanted to be it was two
different things jimmy was going to be
the ball ball player but i thought that
he had chosen politics and just
who was it like who had the 20 he got 20
000
votes more than kennedy did and still
lost in that county of new york right
or whatever but given that you say
wanted to be a writer it's interesting
how he describes
the
he's kind of down on the fate of the
novel
for a whole chunk of the time
novel isn't really where it's at i think
i'll
pursue these essays oh i'm really good
at writing essays
and then going back to the fictionalized
history
but he sort of is dismissive of that
whole middle period of
writers of novels
not necessarily the writers but of the
the form
where where um
when you say the middle period the
middle period
oh okay yeah well part of his
um
part of his absence from the activity of
writing novels had to do with the
reception of the city and the pillar and
the what he calls the blacklist
and that's when he went to write for
television for hollywood
and then started to write plays and then
went into politics and then
he those last chapters titled getting
out going back
it was a return to what he really meant
to be as a young man and that's when the
memoir ends this is a book about his
hiatus
in some ways so when i think the middle
period
i think this is a novel about his middle
period when for circumstances relating
to
american cultural politics and his debut
novel
um
sort of pushed him out into a literary
wilderness which everyone said would
happen
and then whether it was
self-fulfilling or
or in fact what did happen it was the
reality now the dismissiveness of the
novel
are are you saying he's dismissive
of the genre i thought well
i'm not sure if just in terms of what
you mean by dismissive because he was
saying you know
there are so few people who are
following there that it hasn't it was
almost as if and i'm not well read at
all
but i thought okay well as i envision as
i'm crawling into the grave and i'm
taking some novels but to finally read
what it is yeah he said that's it you
know it's it's not going to have that
much information i think he throws a
little coal we'll read them and he says
that also
what the comment you made earlier
who will remember such and such in 20
years yeah will
you know
he's mixed things about james but
dickens right but then when he talks
about it only 2 000 people read james
right
but then he says some of the people
writing today in 20 years will they
matter at all
josh is it john it's just right
what did dad
say to you at all when he was talking
about the novel and i'm interested in
knowing that you came onto the planet in
the 70s oh and i i think i
admit that i actually miss i my reading
of this not of this number was a bit uh
episodic at times uh
i did sure occasionally
well i was also wondering if
there were any parts that really grabbed
you at all
because knowing that you know i only
part of the reason i like this sort of a
tell-all thing is the period and it's
a little bit ahead and then right when i
showed up in the scene so i'm always
interested to hear more of what we
didn't hear on the farm oh well yeah i
i'd say i i
these are all you know these he's
talking about people
whom i
i mean i i i had reference to because
you know i had heard of these people i
you knew i knew someone somewhat about
these people but i
it just yeah i mean
at times it
i'm trying to think about this i i guess
i i did miss the part with the novel
um
although i have to say i can't i'm
trying to think of how many novels from
the period between
1940s and
1970s that i
pulled cling to cling to i'm not trying
to get any novels at all i think but um
but that's another question you know
he talks about other people's novels uh
at great length for that period anyway
yeah um that's right
and it's for me a part of what really
would what i would go it was going into
this book hoping
well hoping thinking about finding was
what what
you know what was it the status of what
was american culture in this period like
from from the
perspective of a participant
and someone who was in a very good
position to
you know who was a a very intelligent
observer who was in the thick of things
and
you know what because i because my big
images of this time were
just this very
much at this time very
sort of embattled as that it
sort of sultified an embattled
place
with these all this sort of
underground energy that welled up at
these very creative places but that was
and that that and i was just trying to
get a sense of what and i don't know if
i got a very good sense of what that was
do you think that's why i think it
provided much of a sense do you think
that's why even when he complements
other authors
who i guess you may see as competitors
like norman mailer truman capote
hill he can say positive things but
there's always a little edge
look what he does to anais nin
he doesn't see her as a competitor but
i mean when he talks about other writers
another liar
right
emphasizing how much older
yeah he's 80 now so he catches up with
you yeah i still that's the thing i said
originally he's just this very
macho
guy
i think that
he goes back to what he maybe he
he imbibed
his time you know i don't know you know
time period yeah i know where you're
going but you know he made another he
made two other statements that resonated
for me being
older
and
one he
was the statement and it was made in the
context of discussing his relationship
with jimmy and projecting what the
future might be like or even describing
the absences the periods of time when he
and jimmy were not together they were at
separate schools and then they went to
the service
and
he
remarks that well we didn't write to
each other
but
men don't don't
but he then in that place goes further
and he says
but the great
freeze had not yet fallen over american
manhood
um the great freeze being the
allergy to any kind of of um
non-standard
any kind of demonstration of of
affection of
of feeling you know this absolutely
stiff upper lip un
lack of affect that is supposed to be
the
the baseline or the model for man-man
relationship
and he describes that as a deep freeze
which is interesting given
this macho posture that he's always
taking in the book
so there seems to be
despite
he's like he's lamenting that he freeze
he's lamenting the deep freeze and he's
separating his experience well he lived
through it you know he sort of broke the
rules but then he kept he kept to the
rules
in some ways i'm not sure i'm not sure i
can't
i'm not sure he survived despite the
rules i mean the city and the pillar was
the great breach with them
but then in some ways he he had kept his
own rules yeah yeah exactly
i mean
that's
thinking about when you were talking
about the whole
idea of the compartmental departmental
compartmentalization of his life is that
maybe that made it that that
compartmentalization allowed it allowed
him to
negotiate this kind of identity issue
much easier much more easily because in
some ways you
if you're gonna if you compartmentalize
the sex part
to this
underground thing and yeah yeah then it
would make it much easier and i think
that's something that makes the book
generational too
the
and this resonated with me for other
reasons
he
i think is a man of the the great world
he comes from a political family he
circulates in highly visible elites
whether they're political or cultural
and
at certain points in the book he refers
disparagingly to a gay ghetto he doesn't
want to be enclosed by an identity and
he in fact
i think his sympathy for kinsey is
uh based on kinsey's insistence that
this is a continuum
not
just uh
these are not discrete identities that
exclude each other there is a continuum
of of of of sexual experience and
feeling that embraces all of us and we
shouldn't compartmentalize ourselves
even as he is carpenter
compartmentalizing his own sexual
activity but he's i think
passionately concerned to remain engaged
in the world at large rather than to
enclose himself in a little in a littler
world
well in some ways then you know you know
this or that community
even though he has meant he as he
describes it his his social life you
know there are many gay people with whom
he socializes
um
and and he describes
um
lesbian worlds and hollywood when he
lived there
and he's aware of those worlds but he's
not really
he
wants he wants to be in a bigger a
bigger or bigger world or participate in
many different worlds
and he certainly does yes he does and i
mean i i can't you can't blame him for
that i don't know and sometimes i think
it might in fact he share something with
a lot of
perhaps people
younger than myself uh who
you know who who don't
have any interest in the pieties of
the
gay liberation who
don't want to be limited to don't want
to be enclosed either captioning not
impulse of available general i mean i
mean it's certainly not the world gore
vidal comes from but think of the
immigrant experience of the early 20th
century with people like my own parents
who come i never knew grandparents
didn't speak with accents
but my own parents married outside their
ethnic groups they spoke english to
their parents when their parents
addressed them in foreign languages he
traces his ancestry fact i know
but but the world he lives in is really
southern populist i mean it is
interesting to find the jewish dimension
and family at the end yes but uh
someone said i you know i should have
been
and then oh wait i am vidal according to
someone maybe i am i'm like reading this
very hair he's such a you know wasp icon
yeah
and it's like
who
at one point is even accused of having
made anti-semitic
comments which seem peripheral mm-hmm
well howard austin is american america
for the whole america for america first
right
would get in trouble with some people
but then
uh but then there's the strain that
maybe back there vidal
would be just the kind of a name that uh
someone sort of a murano someone hiding
their jewish identity might take i don't
know if it was that convincing but
that he even included it i thought it
was kind of it yeah
it did make me want to read julian
oh i have read city in the pillar and
liked it
but it's what's interesting is that like
sort of a
icon of its time
and a good story but really like how
would someone describe that and
does
the character have to get beat up you
know there were certain conventions that
it's like
a gay love story of its period it was
good but i haven't read that much i've
read essays me too i really want to read
julian
uh
i don't know there were a couple that he
the way he described them
made me want to come to left bank books
and pick it up
or maybe would it be another
uh
you know book for this group or i don't
know
you don't want to make it a gore vidal
reading group but sometimes you want to
go on to read the next yeah i i
you know like toy bin was like that i
read a fiction book by him
and in this case certainly on my own
i pick up julian or lincoln or
bruce
you know historian colleagues told me
that brewer was the best of luck
really yeah okay the historical
that she was really actually respectable
oh in some ways and
brought the uh brought the topic to uh
people who want to get into it
yeah you know what's interesting
and i i know more about his politics
from his essays than from his fictional
his fictionalized histories because i
haven't read those i've read only essays
but he does there's something about the
views he takes even going back to the
demonization of lincoln
that is
continuous with
other very strangely right-wing
circles in the united states right-wing
populist circles and yet he he describes
himself as increasingly radical and on
the left
he's certainly he's all over the map he
is all over what he i thought he was
unnecessarily
can i say too unnecessarily cruelty like
bobby kennedy
really like
yeah he's insulting to ethel he's
insulting to bobby he's insulting to his
having been mentored by mccarthy he's
living in his brother's shadow he's
petty he's
uh
he even questions his sexuality
in a way that seemed you know well i
don't think he documented the basis for
those judgments very well but i sort of
took them for granted because i keep
hearing references and i've never read
that much
well the few that robbie was just really
the guy to watch out for
uh back then certainly more than
uh
jack but uh
i i i didn't get the sense that he was
being unnecessarily cruel you know i
mean the fight at the white house when
she went for his exact shoulder yeah
buddy boy yeah that's right i never
heard that expression used outside of a
40s hollywood movie
and then it sort of escalates on into
a conversation between two people that a
whole lot of other people seem to have
felt they could comment on
so why did you think it was unfair to
bother me just that he kept picking on
him i don't know
like we get it he
didn't respect this person i don't know
i don't know in that case the book would
have been much shorter if you're taking
that policy with people into everything
[Laughter]
i don't respect this person next story
that's true right and and to the extent
that this is a memoir which settles
scores with memories and other memoirs i
i do think he had to go there battling
memoirs right
yeah
now in so-and-so's memoir they attribute
this action to me
and as you said
this is how that conversation really
went or
i remember not even being there and
coming later or something like you know
so he in his
but i guess one thing i read was if
you're gonna cast doubt on all those
other memoirs doesn't some of that
reflect back right
on
well you know you're seeing this from
your perspective too which
is the way you saw it and true to you
but going back to proust
you know
the truth and how you remember
i don't know it was a pretty rich book
would love to talk about
yeah and uh
many all the the strands running through
it uh it's really many books that at
once and i i i think i think it could
support another conversation but i
wonder if it'll support another memoir
from 64 to 94. i was wondering if he's
thinking of anything of the kind but he
really wasn't a
there really are no fallow years
in his
in his right
i'd read it
yeah yeah i have no idea if anything of
the kind is
in the works he
i think there's only the slightest hint
that something like that might be he
really is closing the book down and
closing the circle of this book at the
end
by with with the going back to what he
was and that's the story he's telling
it's really the story of a detour
as a novelist and now he's a novelist
again and we don't have to
write a memoir
i was thinking of some of his hollywood
period and how dominic dunn writes about
those same
uh
sort of things the things he said about
greta garbo for example
and charlton heston and chuck
and
in some ways i found this
yeah more interesting
than going for the obvious you know
okay well
i think uh
we can look forward to reading more gore
vidal i hope but i think we've got many
other things that we may want to be
doing in the future but
thanks for this eve
we're at the 2009 book expo america
booksellers convention at the javits
center in new york city i'm here with
stacey lewis publicity director from
city life's books out of san francisco
stacey what do you have coming out this
fall um well
this fall we actually have a couple
books coming out from angela davis
we have a collection of essays it's her
first book that's actually been
published in about four years
that covers themes that she's
particularly interested in racism sexism
the prison industrial complex and then a
particularly interesting book that we're
publishing with angela is
a new edition of the narrative of the
life of frederick douglass and american
slave which contains
douglas's narrative as well as essays by
davis
that were part of a course that she
taught at
ucla in the 70s
so it really
brings to life that essay and will also
include a new essay written by her this
year so we're hoping that
people who have read the narrative
before take a look at this book as it's
going to be enriched by the new
and the old work
we're also publishing the awakener it's
a long-awaited memoir by helen weaver
it's about her life with jack kerouac
lenny bruce allen ginsburg in greenwich
village in the 50s she was also involved
in the publishing scene in the 50s so it
more than just focusing on kerouac and
the beats it really presents a bigger
picture of literary life in new york in
the 50s in greenwich village which
continues to
always seem to be of interest so we're
excited about that one
and then our latest book that just came
out is called the peep diaries how we're
learning to love watching ourselves and
our neighbors by hal needs vicky and
what hal is talking about
is at one time everyone was interested
in pop culture because everyone's
fascinated by celebrities but he's
coined this term peep culture in that
the focus has gone from
celebrities to the focus on yourself
that you actually can be the celebrity
and you
um you can do that by blogs and websites
and youtube videos and so it's a
commentary on what that change in
technology
um has created for social
and cultural life in the us and it's
very entertaining and he actually
inserts himself in in lots of scenarios
he blogs all the time he's actually was
at bea today twittering people's uh
secrets people were asked to uh if they
wanted to get a copy of this book today
we asked them to tell us a secret and
then hal went ahead and went on his
twitter account and and twitted i guess
twitted tweeted those secrets so
so they have some of the new non-fiction
that we've got so regular book tv
viewers know city lights as a bookstore
and your publishing offices are on the
second floor of that bookstore how did
city lights start and who founded city
lights um city lights publishing was
actually started
in 1955 by lawrence ferlingetti and
many people know who lawrence for
lingerie is he's actually one of the
most renowned poets in the world
he began the publishing company with a
collection of his own poems
called pictures of the gone world that
was the first book in the city lights
pocket poet series which has gone on to
continue publishing we have about 60
books in print right now
uh in the series
so tell me a little bit about the
bookstore and the publishing house how
does it work do you
is it is it is there synergy between the
bookstore and the publishing house or
yeah i would say that
um at one time most of the people that
worked in the publishing company had
worked in the bookstore um the person
that is now the editorial director
elaine katzenberger worked for over 15
years in the bookstore
uh and is now leading the way
uh publishing excellent books for city
lights we're in the same building it's
quite symbiotic
the books that we publish
very much reflect the types of books
that we carry in the store the
commitment to progressive politics
literature and translation uh new voices
gay and lesbian literature poetry
poetry and translation
you if one were to look at the city
lights list or kind of think about the
books that i was just talking about and
then walk through the store you you
would get the same sort of
uh sense that it's the selection there
is being curated for you and that's a
very specific intentional thing that's
done by uh bookstore buyer paul yamazaki
andy bellows his assistant buyer and
store manager peter maravelis and a
whole host of other people
working in the bookstore so i think that
the mission is one and the same that
continues through the bookstore to the
books that we publish
now how old is mr fairlangetti and is he
still involved with the bookstore and
we're the publisher
lawrence is 90 years old and he just we
just celebrated his 90th birthday
with him
um at this point i would say that
any poetry that we're publishing is
vetted by
lawrence that it has to have his
approval but
the great thing that he's done is that
he hasn't
um
kept the company to himself he's
delegated work to lots of people like
myself
and and let us kind of continue his
vision in our own way so
um
at this point we we hope to see him you
know he comes into the office maybe a
couple times a week to check mail and
whatnot
but he's busy painting he's still
writing
he's kind of pursuing his own stuff when
i first started at city lights i he
would come into the office every day so
that was i'm glad to have had that
privilege to to see him and work with
him
stacy lewis thanks policy director
marketing director city lights bookstore
in san francisco thank you
ellen johnson sirleaf president of
liberia is interviewed about her memoir
this child will be great
this event hosted at the ronald reagan
building in washington dc is 50 minutes
up next we visit the san luis obispo
county history center and learn about
writer jack kerouac's time in the town
the coastal awakening
was this cultural movement that
was set up when jack kerouac's
scroll of on the road was coming to our
local library
well i'd known from
research we did that
jack kerouac
lived in san luis obispo for a while and
worked in san luis
and of course
his literary style was outside the box
and some of his characters like neil
cassidy were on a different
level so we thought well
let's name
five or six people
in our history that thought that went
against the grain or thought outside the
box
for instance
art beal
and he was known as captain nitwit or dr
tinkerpaw
he was working on hearst castle when
they first started and he decided he
would do an anti-hurst castle and build
it all out of driftwood and seashells
and that kind of thing
he also acted in vaudeville he was a
merchant marine
he ended up being a poet
and
songwriter
but he was just a
tremendous guy
who invented his own vernacular
and that did all this artwork in his
home and around
and he became a real legend in the
cambria area which is on the north coast
this is jack kerouac now jack kirwack
lived
in san luis obispo in 52 and 53.
he was the breakman on the southern
pacific railroad
he wrote about it
he wrote letters about it and you know
if you know anything about jack kirwack
he was always concerned about his mother
and he always wanted to make sure his
mother had a nice home
well he really thought about buying a
trailer in san luis obispo even had it
picked out in the trailer park and
moving her to san luis obispo we know
that he would like to
walk
where the river went by the mission
that's now mission plaza and score
marijuana he talks that about that in
his book
he also talks about going to avila beach
and listening to the breakers and
listening to the chevron tankers anchor
go down
and uh
basically he was just in this period
where he was trying to publish on the
road but the same time had to make a
living and in those days you know you
could be a break man on the southern
pacific and
support yourself that's for sure
his job was taking
the engines pulling the train over to
the top of quest to grade
and then
once the train made it over the top then
they could come back to san luis obispo
so
he basically did that run
from the station san luis obispo over
the grade to what we call the santa
margarita transfer point then he would
come back
now this guy
gavin arthur
the grandson of president chester a
arthur
he was like a santa barbara trust baby
that
went to ireland
in the 19s
and
ran into a lot of irish republicans
there
and even
provided funds so they could import guns
and
they gave him
his nickname
of gavin
so then that gavin came back to santa
barbara and he eventually
went down to
the dunes in oceano and to halcyon
the theosophist
utopia
and
he decided to do
to publish the dune forum and make it
like
this west coast literary magazine
and
gavin was the editor
along with another guy
but gavin
was
very creative and he built muy mail
which was a lodge
where
other creative writers and people could
come to and that was frequented by
you know
a lot of famous people they say
everybody from
wc fields to
john steinbeck to uh georgia o'keeffe
those people would visit the dunes and
they would stay at moy mail
where gavin was
well the thing is so then
world war ii comes along gavin becomes a
merchant marine
and then he moves to san francisco
and in san francisco he had a newspaper
kiosk
and the same uh the famous san francisco
columnist herb kane would always buy his
paper there
at gavin's kiosk and gavin
by this time
wrote a book wrote a book which we have
over here the circle of sex but he was
talking about
no one's completely straight no one's
completely gay there's just different
dials of straightness and gayness and
this was really a popular book it was
like the kinsey report and so in san
francisco
they would call
gavin
the father of the gay liberation
movement and that's gavin
okay this is ella young
and ella
was irish
and she met gavin in the in the 19s in
ireland gave him the name of gavin
and she
supported the irish republican army
and was disgusted in the 1920 deal they
had with
england where northern ireland would
remain
under english control so she left and
moved to the united states
and she ended up being at halcyon
the theosophist
commune and
she also ended up teaching irish
mythology
at the university of california in
berkeley and she
was a great storyteller she wrote books
about irish myths
poetry books she had a program on the
radio and she was like
the heart and soul
of the mystic do nights
ellie young
last but not least we're talking about
another due night that was off the
beaten path
george blaze
now george
became famous
as the character
in um whiteman's book face of the clam
and face of the clam came out in 47
but it was just
whiteman's view from the 20s to the 30s
what went on in the dunes and so
he's the star face of the clan
and he's known as french in the face of
the clan
he was the quintessential mystic in
other words he was always trying to find
ways to reach satori or nirvana through
different
meditation fasting
whatever techniques
but then with his long hair and beard
he ended up going to where they were
filming the movie the ten commandments
and he was spotted by
a producer director
and they decided he would be perfect for
the movie
and so he
played a role in that movie and then he
at the end of face of the clam he parts
and goes down to hollywood
saying he will be back and so this is
the quintessential nudist
frenchie
could all this go on now
well frenchy would have been run over by
a a dune buggy
ella young would be deported because she
was a ira
no one would ever let a house like art
beale's nitwit ridge be built
because of county codes and so forth the
only thing they would allow now would be
jack kerouac to go to mission plaza and
score marijuana
and maybe frenchy to go naked at pirates
cove
san luis obispo california is one of the
many cities we've toured to explore the
american story to watch more of our
visit to san luis obispo and